hey everyone welcome to this video on
pmp certification full course
we'll begin this full course video by
talking about what project management is
learn about project planning and how it
can be done in excel you will understand
cost quality communication and other
forms of management the best project
management tools and how you can prepare
for the pmp exam
you will understand the role of a
project manager discuss the crucial
interview questions and much more
by the time we are done you will be well
versed in some of the most important
concepts in project management
for this training with me
we have our specialist chandra mr and
ishan together they will take you
through the different topics
so let's start by answering the question
what is project management
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
hi
welcome to project management tutorial
from simple learn i am chandra mr a
professional consultant and coach
in best practices related to project
management and i.t service management
today as part of this tutorial we are
going to learn the basic understanding
about the project management and the
required knowledge for a project manager
to become successful in managing
projects so as part of this tutorial we
are going to look at
what is project management what is
project components of project management
project life cycle key focus areas in
project management job roles in project
management and project management
certifications so what is project
management now as defined in pmis pmbok
project management is application of
knowledge skills tools and techniques to
project activities to meet project
requirements so every project will have
an objective to accomplish similarly the
objective of project management is to
make the final deliverables in a finite
time and budget this involves having
clear understanding about the
deliverables of the project required
resources for the project resource in
terms of human resources technical
resources financial resources etc
project managers should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
as constraints or aspects and manage
those throughout the project life cycle
for which a project manager should have
a full view about a project and what is
that this project has to accomplish that
objective should be clear
so as part of project management the six
constraints which project manager should
look at are scope time quality cost risk
and resources so each of these areas has
very important role to play in project
management the clarity in scope the
clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incurs to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary when cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the scope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated for various
deliverables from the project so every
projects require resources resources may
be in terms of human resources financial
resources
technology resources environmental
resources so all these resources are
used to produce the output of the
project so these resources has to be
managed with the sufficient optimization
and standardizations required now let us
understand the definition of a project
so what is the project pmi defines a
project as a temporary endower
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result the temporary nature
of a project indicates that a project
has a definite beginning and end so when
i say product unique product it means
every output it may be similar products
you are producing with the same features
and functionality but the output of
every project is unique because it is
unique in terms of all the six
constraints what we just discussed now
now when i say product it is very easy
for us to visualize it may be a desktop
it may be a laptop it may be a car it
may be a machine etc but how do i
visualize a service a project output is
a service now it is it's about building
a capability a project by through a
project a capability can be built to
ensure services can be provided that's
what the output of project is service
for example if i think about a taxi
services for providing a taxi services i
need a mobile app i need taxi i need a
server i need a data center
so all these are various different
products and services here service
example can be internet service so
combination of all the services and
products builds the capability for an
organizations who can provide the tax
services so building that capability we
say it is an output of a particular
project which is called service
similarly results can be
improvement of something improvement in
customer satisfaction increase in
some specific objectives or specific
results needs to be achieved in
performance perspective so output of
every project will be unique product or
a service or a result this we need to
clearly understand so when we say there
is a definite beginning and end every
project starts at a certain point in
time and ends at certain point in time
so it has a definite beginning and end
that is the reason it is temporary in
nature it is not an ongoing business
activity right so every project will
have a life cycle a beginning and end so
when it starts till end until the result
or a service or a product which comes as
an output of a project project lifecycle
is not ended so interestingly in a
product life cycle or in a service
lifecycle you come across
many project life cycles so one project
life cycle means one project is
initiated to introduce a product or
services next project or
initiated would be to enhance the
capability of a service or a product
next project initiated after some time
is to optimize something similarly at
the end of the product life cycle
project is initiated to retire that
product or services so in a given
product life cycle there may be multiple
project life cycle so what is involved
in the project life cycle it involves
five areas five groups we can call it so
initiation planning execution monitoring
and closure so when i say initiation
it's all about understanding what is
project giving the basic understanding
of the project collating the details and
having key stakeholders identified once
that is done one will move towards
planning so here in the initiation
it is very clearly one has to understand
is project is worthwhile of doing so one
has to check the feasibility one has to
measure that particular investment is
making sense
and then confirm yes it makes sense to
invest now next planning as we have a
basic understanding of yes this project
has to be done and a discussion with the
key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you're going in a
project in an agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
education you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that a
clear blueprint often project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the project lifecycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project execute in the sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure a
resource you ensure right resources are
required if it is human resource one has
to educate that human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what they should have is
acquired by those individuals so that
deliverables can happen
and they need to be managed the entire
team needs to be managed for that a
clear structure has to be created
similarly when you do technology
resource perspective those components
has to be tested configured then
integrated again tested for uncheck the
performances so collective action of
this results in a deliverable during the
execution so as the deliverables are
happening in the execution it is quite
obvious project manager has to monitor
review control that particular
deliverable and also the processes tools
resources used during the project even
those needs to be monitored so that they
are complying to the defined processes
so during monitoring there may be a
deviation one can found during
monitoring there may be the project is
running the way it is required so in
this monitoring phase it involves an
action from project manager to monitor
and control the work of the project so
comparing with the blueprint of plan
what is accomplished what is created
during the planning
phase of this project and as the
execution happens monitoring and control
is monitoring it and checking is that
activities what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of a projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project
deliverables needs to be accomplished
within the cost what is budgeted for the
project so during the project your
project manager may find there are
certain uh deviations which are occurred
there are additional challenges which
has come in so for this reason one has
to ensure continued monitoring as the
execution happens and identify those
deviation and ensure whenever there is a
deviation there is a correction whenever
there is an additional things coming in
that needs to be considered carefully
whether that need to be involved as part
of this deliverable or should be taken
it separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stakeholders
of the project during the entire project
life cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify
so may require to have a change in the
blueprint itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand in
hand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process work instructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it is
very important and project is done
within the scope schedule and time and
the quality matrix defined then as the
completion of the project happens as the
monitoring and control says yes
deliverable has happened according to
the requirement
then the project moves to the closure
the closure may be closure of a specific
project phase a milestone deliverable or
a faisal deliverable
or it can be a deliverable at the end of
the project which is the ultimate
deliverable so processes in closing has
to be triggered whenever there is end of
the phase whenever there is a
deliverable to conclude and also at the
end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is defined what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or next phase or
to the next project and at the same time
a sign-off has to be obtained formally
and everything should be summarized and
have a good handshake with the project
stakeholder mainly a business or
customer and also disseminating of team
means you will dismantle the entire team
and send them back to their specific
units or specialization and they may get
assigned to new project or if it is a
functional they can go back to their
functions to do their functional
activities so that was about entire
project lifecycle what happens now while
doing this i mentioned there are six
constraints that is scope schedule cost
quality risk and resources so keeping
these in mind one has to ensure project
is successful in all aspects so to
become successful there are few key
areas which has to be looked at so first
six key areas are scope schedule cost
quality resources and stakeholders now
let us look at the scope what does scope
means scope is about what needs to be
delivered what is in scope what is out
of the scope so this refers to all those
deliverable scope all those activity
scope basically we speak about two
things one is product scope and project
scope product scope is all about
ensuring the features functionality of
products are well defined and understood
and signed off and while delivering that
product that is tested against those
defined features and functionalities
whereas project score focus on all the
activities needs to be done all those
templates which has to be used all the
process which has to be complied with
all the skills which is required to be
applied so it is going as defined so by
doing this activities which is defined
as part of project scope the result the
deliverable will come out which will be
in line with the deliverables features
and functionality which is defined as
part of product scope it is very
important to ensure entire projects
happens within this particular scope
there should not be any deviations from
this schedule perspective for that
specifications what we are defined for a
product and project so these needs to be
done in a specific point in time means
in a specific schedule there will be
start time and time right so
one has to plan how long a project would
take and what are the deliverables
should happen in what sequence what
activities are required to accomplish
this
so all these needs to be understood so
while performing the schedule management
one has to look at a specific
deliverable at a specific point in time
by applying a specific set of activities
required so this will tell you the
duration of the project this will
provide you the sequence of project this
will also help you to understand the
dependency between one task to another
task this will also help you to
understand how the deliverables
happening in what sequence which helps
in prioritizing your deliverables third
is cost so as we know to do any project
it is very essential to ensure project
happens within that budget so project
cost is estimated initially then that
estimated cost will be checked checked
in terms of is the assumptions
considerations are right or wrong is
that really so much of a monetary are
required for the project
and then after understanding the
justification and obtaining the clarity
budget is i mean monetary resources are
allocated and confirmed approved then it
will become a budget that will be a cost
baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of uh
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost
now quality as we know quality is a very
important area which ensures the project
is delivered in time with all the
specifications defined
by using all the methods means by
following all the processes work
instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same steps do the activity
so what quality management focus is to
ensure the intended objectives of
projects are achieved already there is a
definition done in terms of various
different practices or processes needs
to be followed similarly specification
of each of the products are defined and
from that there should not be any
deviation so quality management should
focus on ensuring those activities are
done as defined those deliverables are
done according to the specifications
what is different it is very important
that way so for that there is a layer of
quality management there should be a
layer of quality management where
auditing our control activities are
initiated periodically so that any
deviations can be seen easily and
remember
a project manager can become cannot
become part of quality management like
project manager cannot audit project
managers should have a team or take the
help of a team who can able to do mostly
the one which is who is not part of the
project is always better resources
now as i mentioned earlier every project
need resources it may be human resources
it may be technology resources it may be
any other resources which are required
to do the project so organization
acquires resources configured and then
deployed
for example in the project you acquire a
server you configure a server you deploy
a server technology resource human
resource is onboarded recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
clear to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in the
project in the best possible manner so
interestingly when i say human resource
always there is a possibility that
a conflict can occur so when i say
conflict conflict of interest may be in
terms of what the individuals has to do
conflict in terms of the preferences in
terms of solutions what they're looking
at conflict in terms of using resources
different opinions different preferences
various reasons conflict can come across
so it is very important to project
manager to understand this dynamics of
human resources
and manage those conflicts project
manager cannot shy away from handling
conflicts project manager has to hone
and resolve those conflicts in the favor
of project not in the favor of any
individuals so there are various
techniques to look at resolving
conflicts so that is like compromising
problem solving smoothening
accommodating
so whichever helps for that project
scenario for the project objectives that
needs to be applied that technique has
to be taken up so here the resolution is
not at the specific individual's
preference it is with the objective of
whether projects has any impact what
kind of impact positive or negative if
it is negative no that's not the
direction the direction should be
ensuring project gets that value through
this conflict resolution so project
manager should own it it's an
accountability of a project manager then
as the human resource are acquired there
are five stages
team dynamics are involved so one has to
bring them
then educate them about a project as the
education on the project happens one has
to go and do the job on floor that needs
to be observed means one has to manage
by looking at it and
any corrections needs to be done that
needs to be guided so it is very dynamic
thing when it comes to human resources
similarly in technology resources
standardization there is no ambiguity as
such but right resources with the right
configurations should be acquired that
is very important the next stakeholders
so who can be stakeholders every project
will have a stakeholder who are internal
and external to the project so the
internal stakeholders are those who are
part of the project who are part of the
organization who are part of the
customer organization or part of
supplier organization a competition to
my business means my organization's
business all this we can call it as a
stakeholders now every stakeholders will
have a specific interest a power an
ability to influence now through their
position through their
distance from the project
they will get impacted at the same time
they will also impact the project
similarly they influence and they get
influenced because of the project so a
project manager should identify all the
stakeholders and understand this what is
the kind of stakeholder is this in terms
of power in terms of legitimacy in terms
of influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be a
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am i going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get that
inputs required through review or
periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up-to-date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
focus areas to mention is communication
risk procurement critical success
factors deliverables and work breakdown
so this list is not exhaustive as we
deep dive into project i think you can
just keep listing the key focus areas
more than this but whatever we have
indicated are the minimum which needs to
be looked at so when i say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be a
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any sense there should be a
receiver and there should be an
acknowledgement from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication
how frequently we should do that
interactions or communications intent of
that particular communication what is
the expected action or response from
that communication all this needs to be
very very clear and this can be
articulated it has to be articulated so
one it is articulated once there is a
picture in terms of what kind of
communication has to happen it is quite
obvious there should not be any
deviation from the agreed communications
requirements and whenever there is a
need of change to the communication
requirements from the stakeholders that
needs to be updated for this one has to
have a stakeholders identified so
stakeholder management and communication
are very closely linked and associated
engagement with the stakeholder will
become successful within effective
communication approaches next is risk so
every project which is undertaken by
organization that will have certain
amount of risk which organization will
evaluate similarly within the project
life cycle lot of risk comes up which
would have certain impact to the project
now risk refers to by definition an
uncertain event it has an uncertainty an
event which is uncertain and when it
occurs it will have an impact on the
project positively or negatively now
current scenario in everywhere the
projects what you observe closely people
tend to look at the risk which are
threats that is negative only but they
fail to recognize the risks which are
opportunities the positive risks so
another gap which we see when do the
risk management is that is done in the
initial phase of the project as the
project is kicked off someone will do
the risk assessment have a list of risk
identified but unfortunately there is no
categorizations for that risk and how is
that going to impact the project that is
not clear thirdly risk management or
list of risk
are created only once it is not done
repeatedly so risk identification and
analysis and assessment of that risk has
to be done throughout the lifecycle of
your project reason being the risk which
looks as in high impact when project is
initiated as the project progresses the
impact levels will vary maybe in the
middle of the project the impact may be
very high or low so likewise the impacts
of the risk will vary throughout the
project life cycle it may be positive it
may be negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the project life
cycle as i said that is also a dynamic i
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and i keep it as it is i need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and analysis should also be
done regularly periodically so that one
will have a clear understanding about is
that risk still valid is that risk is
there still or not what is the level of
variations in terms of impact of the
risks so this clarity will be there so
that necess organization or project
manager can get ready to face those risk
if it is a negative risk definitely
should have a mitigation or avoidance or
acceptance whatever the mitigation plan
you have to eliminate the negative
impact of the risk when it occurs if it
is a project positive risk it's quite
obvious one has to take the advantage of
that one has to enhance exploit share a
positive risk so that organization is
benefited further procurement so
whenever a project is initiated whenever
a project is taken up the organization
who is doing the project cannot create
everything cannot develop everything in
that project life cycle so organization
would take a decision make a decision
stating that some of the deliverables we
make ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a
specific supplier you cannot go with
every supplier you should evaluate the
suppliers qualify the suppliers and then
select onboard the supplier and then get
the services or products supplied by
that particular supplier so while doing
this one has to understand what type of
contracting they need to enter with so
three types of contracts we speak
basically one is about
a cost plus contract where cost is fully
known to the project manager and to the
organization so apart from known cost a
fee will be paid to the supplier another
one is fixed price where project manager
or the organization who is awarding that
contract to a supplier will not know
what is the cost instead it is a fixed
price but important here is the scope of
work needs to be clearly articulated and
defined another type of contracting can
be time and material where
the billing will happen based on the
amount of time one is spent on that
particular a higher resource or on board
resource on a time on material basis and
what is that effort that resource has
been put based on that building will
happen so three types of contracts
depending on the different scenarios of
the project will be signed with the
contractor however before doing that it
is very essential to identify those
suppliers sign off with them and monitor
and manage them so if deliverables are
not there it is very essential to look
at the
termination one has to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
terminating should be able to put some
effort to educate them also so that they
come up to the mark so project is
benefited so depending on what needs to
be done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor so based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved his objectives
our project has not achieved his
objectives so key critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if i want to
become successful in an exam critical
success factor is scoring or passing the
examination or let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60 percent and above so critical
success factor for me to get promoted is
to pass in this particular exam so to
pass in this exam minimum i should score
is 60 percent that is kpi passing in the
exam that is critical success factor so
how will i measure that success factor
is kpi so every project which it
produces a specific product or services
by using a specific resources and each
of these the resources the processes the
templates the deliverables all these
needs to be measured on a continual
basis so there are critical success
factors defined and those are measured
by defining kpis to that critical
success factors so basically critical
success factor provides the insight
towards what needs to be measured and
when you measure what should be the
focus and to achieve those critical
success factors the indicator is key
performance indicators when you measure
yes the moment you achieve that your csf
is achieved next deliverables so
deliverables are those which comes as an
output of the project right it may be
product it may be a service it may be a
result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables may
be the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have a defined scope will have a defined
specification so those deliverables has
to be measured tested and one has to
confirm yes this deliverable is
performing as we are intended to have
the performance accordingly the decision
will happen should we accept this
particular deliverable or not if there
is deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focus on
the product state whether it has
achieved that results or not is that
functional as needed or not one has to
ensure these deliverables has all those
features and functionalities only then
that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when i
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture i
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if i say a car so
i can think of a body external i can
think of a mirror on that body i can
think of a
glass in the front side as well as the
back side and also i can think of
interiors like seat then accelerator
steering dashboard all this i can
visualize but since i am not a
technology expert relating to car can i
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like
engine the battery assembly i don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or services should be broken down into
multiple pieces i'm not saying go and
break that product i'm saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if i say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever you visualize body body
structure mirror mirror assembly
headlights then the tires so likewise
whatever i can visualize i will make it
as a line items under the exterior so
under for example under a mirror mirror
i can speak about mirror glass mirror
cap mirror pedestal and mirror of
assembly where it moves where you can
move the mirror so these are the various
components involved in a mirror so i
need to ensure
by breaking down the product into
multiple levels but depos decomposing it
to multiple levels i can able to
visualize the product very clearly what
is there in detail so once i have the
details i will articulate those what is
that particular work breakdown element
is product breakdown element is then i
will look at what skills and
capabilities required for that product
and i will assign the resources
accordingly so once activities resources
everything is assigned automatically
this will become a work breakdown
structure further after creating a work
breakdown structure one will go and
sequence the activity look at sequencing
will happen based on in what priority
deliverable should happen what order
deliverable should happen then once the
sequencing is done it will be checked to
see whether anything can be optimized
anything can be
done in such a way that smooth flow of
the project can happen there is no
dependencies which will make project to
delay like as the flow happens smoothly
so you would find the various techniques
like critical path method network
diagramming critical chain method so all
these are used the floats of an
activities are checked then leads and
lags of the activities the relationship
between activities so accordingly full
visualization in terms of how the
project will flow and how in what order
the deliverables are happening can be
easily visualized so that is the reason
first activity is to do the product
breakdown which would result in work
background structure so those are the
points till now whatever i mentioned are
the basic understanding one should have
about a project and project management
so as you deep dive into various best
practices like a pmp by pa pmi prince2
by axelos scrum mass regional scrum
master similarly you have certified
scrum master so many agile practices so
when you look at any of the best
practices that will tell you clearly
articulate what should be the practice
for you to
adopt and adapt that practices so that
your project can become successful so
any of those approach you touch upon all
those refers to these basic things in
the absence of these basic things none
of those best practices discusses the
project management now typically in the
industry there are a lot of job roles to
the project management which we have
seen so based on that this information
is captured here on various job rules in
a project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager project lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member
so
not necessarily all the project
management roles are limited to this so
these are the roles which commonly you
see and we are trying to capture that to
give the insight right when i say
project manager the project manager is
the owner one has to take an
accountability for the project right so
project managers takes the project
according to the plan and plays a lead
role in all the steps of the project
management right so responsibility
should be managing reviewing and
prioritizing the task wherever necessary
looking after risk management
stakeholder management and project
communication management some of the
salary what we found while we were doing
the survey the success ratio of a
project depends majorly on the project
manager so the demand for project
manager is rapidly increasing in the
market so accordingly
75 474 per year that is the usd in inr
it is 1500 000 so this is what the
salary of an approximation what was
found next role we look at senior
project manager where senior project
manager is ahead of the overall project
management plan the role demands
in-depth knowledge of all the project
aspects on a specific on the specifics
of the project the responsibilities
would be planning and coordinating
complex projects visiting project sites
to check progress and handle complex
issues so salary
looks like one or four thousand dollars
per year here 20 92 000 inr per year so
the role of senior project manager is
one of the highest paying roles in the
industry as we have seen having several
allowances and bonuses because of the
criticality involved in the project and
the accountability level of that
particular individuals in the
organization next role project lead so
project leads are the one who leads the
people throughout the project and
provide them with all the information
required throughout so responsibilities
involve motivating the team beneath
taking care of their needs and paying
attention to what they feel ordering or
controlling the project team since the
project lead has more freedom than the
project manager salary project lead
makes sure that project gives the best
possible outcome and is hence the demand
for the project lead in the company
never reduces so in usd 82 000 per year
whereas in inr it is one million two
sixty nine thousand per year next role
look at on resource manager so resource
manager is the human resource needed to
make the project
success right so one has to manage those
resources responsibility involved
assigning the right people to the right
projects at the right time managing
employees currently and determining
hiring needs depending on the project's
requirements so salary would be around
64 000 usd which comes around 966 794 in
inr project management office analyst
for this role the project management
office analyst works with pmo means
project management office and does not
look at the project or manage the
project directly instead does most of
the data driven work which required for
a project to have our project to get
supported by that so that project
managers will have a better insight
analyzing and interpreting the data
concerning the project figuring out the
future risks to the project finding new
ways to advance the idea of the project
management so salary would be one or six
thousand two fifty three per year in usd
whereas four forty nine thousand three
thirty seven in inr per year so steering
committee member so the steering
committee members are the members who do
not work on the project themselves they
are there to help the project manager
like providing inputs during the
development of a project advising on the
budget and evaluating the project
strategies taking regular feedbacks on
the project managers and asking
necessary questions so salary would be
around 68
497 dollars per year so those were the
various roles and that is not that list
is not an exhaustive list various
different roles we come across but these
are the basic roles which is seen in the
industry these roles are being recruited
now there are various project management
certifications which are offered as i
mentioned earlier so those
certifications are pmp that is project
management professional from pmi agile
certified practitioner that is pmi acp
again from pmi then certified associate
in project management so difference
between ca pm and pmp is like capm would
act as a basic level of certification
for those who does not have a sufficient
project experience project management
experience whereas pmp is for those who
has some project management experience
similarly pmi sap is the one who is
aspiring to look at agility in project
management and they can go for it
certified scrum master yes it is a scrum
master certificate which will explain
the role of a scrum master in detail
similarly prince2
a certification from axoloths which also
speak about all the aspects of the
project what we discussed and provides
the framework for project management
excelos also provides prince2
certification in agile also agile
prince2 certification so we will look at
each one of this certain details which
are required for us to know so project
management professional as i mentioned
is most acknowledged and value the
certificate value what it carries which
has resulted to the certified
professionals in landing up in highest
paid jobs in the world so certified
managers gets 20 percent more salary
than the average salary so to take up an
examination one has to go through the
formal training of 35 hours that is one
of the prerequisites and there should be
some experience of 400 hours of project
managing project by leading
various activities of a project and once
the person becomes eligible with that
prerequisites person will become
register in the pmi's website becomes
member and then go for examination so
examination fee for pmp would be 4.5
dollars for the members who are
registered with pmi and for those who
are not registered as a member with pmi
it is 555 the duration of the
examination is 4 hours and the number of
questions will be 200 which are multiple
choice questions so each questions
carries one marks there is no negative
score now prerequisites one has to have
500 hours directing and leading the
projects that experience has to be
filled in while filling the application
if a person is a bachelor degree holder
and along with that 35 contactors of pmi
pm education now prerequisites for
the one who is not a graduate who may be
high school or diploma is 7500 hours of
directing and leading projects 35 hours
of pm education so those are the
prerequisites before one will go and
appear for examination so once an
individual passes pmp examination that
certificate is valid for three years so
now after three years if the person
aspires to keep the certificate
continued they need to produce 60 pdus
professional development units which has
to be acquired during those three years
how to acquire one has to go through
additional learning one has to
contribute towards project management
knowledge base so those needs to be
evidenced and then renewable fee has to
be paid and certificate has to be
renewed then agile certified
practitioner as we saw for pmp here
agile certified practitioner
demonstrates that one has relevant
experience and education to handle and
lead agile projects the organization has
started shifting towards agile as we
know in today's
industry which makes this certification
fast growing in the world so examination
fee would be 435 dollars for pmi members
495 for non-pmi members duration is
three hours and multiple choice
questions 120 questions prerequisites is
2 000 hours project management
experience with thousand 500 hours agile
experience and 21 contact hours of agile
practices so maintenance 30 videos are
required for every three years and after
paying the renewal fee that can be
renewed now certified associate in
project management so here this is an
entry level certificate of pmi
especially for those people who has less
project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project management so examination fee
would be dollar 225 for pmi members
whereas 300 dollars for non-members of
pmi so duration of examination is three
hours and examination will have 150
multiple choice questions so
prerequisites someone who has secondary
diploma 23 contact hours of pm education
is enough there is no experience of
doing the project is required as we saw
in pmp so maintenance is again three
years
someone who need to continue the
certification has to retake the
examination every three years next
certified scrum master so certified
scrum master is an entry level
certification that helps the
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most sought
after certifications as other after this
one can get the designation of certified
scrum master which is offered by scrum
alliance so examination fee which will
change time to time which is not
revealed so one has to approach the
training organization where they will
get trained on certified scrum master so
duration of examination is 60 minutes
and pattern would be 16 hours 2 days of
training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
of training then prerequisite is done
for maintaining these credentials so one
has to ensure it has renewed every two
years then projects in controlled
environment that is prince2 so prince2
is a method which is effective mostly
from the base of uk all the
organizations who are from uk region
prefers to have prince2 certification
and it is as popular as any other
project management certifications like
pmp so examination fee would vary from
900 dollars to thousand dollars
depending on where exactly you're taking
the examination and certification will
happen at two levels one is at
foundation level and other one is
practitioner so in foundation it is 60
questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it's 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55 percent to
clear the examination so prerequisites
for prince2 foundation is none whereas
prince2 foundation is a prerequisite for
prince2 practitioner examination so to
maintain the certificate one has to
achieve 20 cpds every year continued
professional development hi guys my name
is ishan and i welcome you all to this
session of project planning today we
will be learning about different aspects
of project planning but before we begin
let's have a look at an incident here's
max an assistant project manager who
looks tensed and is pacing around the
room then jack a project manager who
works with him walks into the room and
asks him why does he seem so tensed to
which max replies he is facing
difficulty in estimating the budget jack
responds it might be because he is not
planning the project properly jack
reassures max and begins to tell him
about project planning so today we will
be learning about what is project
planning and check out the fundamentals
of project planning then we will see why
project planning is so essential for a
project to be successful after that we
will check the tools for project
planning and finally we will have a look
at the steps for project planning so
without any further ado let's begin with
what is project planning project
planning is the second step or phase of
the project life cycle project lifecycle
has five different phrases from
initiation to closure today we will be
learning about this phase that comes
immediately after initiation in which
the project plan is documented and
further requirements are defined project
planning includes the following things
the first and foremost thing is
describing the objectives or outputs we
are expecting the project to yield
second we have is the elaboration of the
scope to make sure what the project is
all about and what all can be expected
from the project the third step we have
is forming a schedule this schedule is
important to run or perform different
tasks of a project each task having its
own start date and end date this helps
the project to finish in the scheduled
time and limit lastly we have making and
generating progress reports in which all
that went during the tenure of the
project is documented this helps in
evaluating the project and helps in the
forthcoming projects now let's have a
look at the project planning
fundamentals the first fundamental that
we have is the determination of scope
cost and resources their determination
helps us in having a rough estimate
about the time that is required to
finish the project it helps us in
determining the number of people
required and what should be their skill
set we can divide the project into
smaller manageable sections and this is
made possible with the help of work
breakdown structure the second
fundamental refers to identifying the
problem there are several techniques by
which we can collect information and
discover issues there may be several
problems in a project and in that case
several risks or issues are prioritized
and the risk that requires immediate
attention is dealt with first then comes
identification of stakeholders when we
can identify the stakeholders we can
know who all will be affected and in
what way which helps us having a better
understanding of the project
stakeholders may be anybody they may be
the part of the project team or project
managers or customers they help during
the project and contribute to its
success then the last fundamental we
will discuss is defining project
objectives a project plan is made
keeping in mind the requirements of the
project team and expectations of the
stakeholders if the project team can
meet the expectations of the
stakeholders then only we can say that
the project is successful now when we
know about project planning and its
fundamentals it's time to see why
project planning is so important project
planning reduces the cost and time of
the project as every step is monitored
and optimized in the best possible
manner project planning increases
employee satisfaction as every employee
who is a part is engaged in the team for
improved project performance project
planning helps in the implementation of
quality assurance as the output of every
step is duly tested lastly project
planning helps in reducing project risk
as planning helps to analyze prioritize
and deal with that risk moving on let's
have a look at the tools for project
planning the first tool that we have is
a gantt chart today gantt charts are one
of the most popular project management
tools they help in tracking the status
of the work at a particular time and
their independencies on each other gantt
charts help in showing different phases
and steps involved in a project the
second tool we will talk about is
critical path method or cpm critical
path method helps in scheduling the
project activities so that the project
runs properly the critical path method
focuses on the longest stretch of
dependent tasks and determines the time
needed to complete them the next tool is
project evaluation and review technique
or pert chart bird provides a graphical
representation of the project's timeline
explaining the independencies of
different tasks this tool not only helps
in making a schedule but also helps in
coordinating with all the team members
the fourth tool we will check is work
breakdown structure work breakdown
structure is a very common tool that
makes it possible for the team to break
its work into manageable sections work
breakdown structure is a step to step
process that helps in completing the
project efficiently the last tool we
will see is project documentation
project documentation is an integral
part of the project lifecycle project
documentation helps in understanding the
mistakes done during the project and
more importantly provides guidelines for
the upcoming project now when we know
about different tools for project
planning it becomes essential that we
know the necessary steps of project
planning there are seven steps in
project planning let's have a look at
each of them in detail the first step is
identification of stakeholders as we
have discussed stakeholders could be
anybody they could be a part of the team
or a project manager or a customer when
we identify stakeholders we can find out
the expectations and requirements that
are to be looked upon in this project
this gives us a clearer picture of the
project and helps in establishing the
project scope so the next step we have
is defining the project scope this helps
in determining a list of specific
project goals and deliverables that are
to be achieved during the course of the
project after we have defined the
project scope it is time to set project
objectives and prioritize them the
initial ideas that were there before are
now elaborated and final steps to
complete the project are defined in the
next step the deliverables are
determined after all project
deliverables are the only reason why the
project is being created this step
involves finding out what these
deliverables will be and the deadlines
of the delivery then the step that comes
into picture is creating a project
schedule the project schedule refers to
the guidelines when a particular task is
to be started and when it is supposed to
end this helps in monitoring the growth
of the project and later helps in
generating progress reports the next
step is the step of risk analysis this
step plays an extremely important role
in the success of the overall project it
helps in identifying the risk
prioritizing them and taking steps to
limit them the last step in project
planning is to generate progress reports
in this step we update the stakeholders
about the project growth and it is done
so that all the concerned team members
can have a look at the progress of the
project after all this information max
thanks jack for the explanation and
looks forward to plan projects within
the budget and of better quality in this
session we will talk about project plan
in excel we will learn about a project
plan and how we can make an effective
plan in microsoft excel before we begin
let's have a look at all the topics we
will be covering today first we will see
the basics of a project plan then we
will check the process of project
management in microsoft excel and why
should one refer to microsoft excel
apart from this we will learn about how
to make a gantt chart in excel towards
the end we will check some microsoft
excel templates so without any further
ado let's get started let's see what is
a project plan project plan is a basic
thing that is needed to execute a
project according to project management
book of knowledge a project can be
defined as an approved collaborative
document that guides the team during
project execution and project control
when we are making a project plan a
project plan must answer several
questions for us these questions are
like what are we expecting our project
to deliver how are we expecting to get
our deliverables within the desired time
who all will be a part of a project and
what tasks they will have in the project
when will the project start and when it
is expected to end that is the deadlines
of the project now let us learn about
project management in excel microsoft
excel is one of the most common
application these days it is used in
both offices and at homes microsoft
excel is an easy project management tool
that allows the team members to easily
see the tasks in a project develop a
plan and track its progress before we
learn more about project management in
excel let's first have a look why do we
use excel microsoft excel is an easy
tool to plan a project so it can be used
by people who are beginners in terms of
project management in excel one can find
several analytical tools like
concatenate len and counter so this
makes data analysis easy and effective
as the entry of data is easy same is
tracking and controlling our project
status then there are several project
management templates in excel that help
us to have an effective distribution of
project data we will be checking several
project management templates towards the
end of this video now let's have a look
at the process of making a gantt chart
in excel before we begin this it's
important we know what is a gantt chart
a gantt chart is like a horizontal bar
chart that is used for project
management with the help of a gantt
chart we can check the status of the
task the date they start the date the
end and the dependencies on each other
gantt chart helps in coordinating and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at the steps that
will help us in making a gantt chart
first step we have is make a project
table we have several rows and columns
like here we have three columns in the
first column we have the tasks in the
second we have a start date and in the
third column we have the duration or
tenure of the task the second step is to
make a bar chart in excel for this we
will select the entire second column
then we will go on the insert tab and
click on the bar graph chart there we
can select stack bar graph in 2d bar
charts as a result we will have the
entitled bar graph on the screen in the
third step we will add the duration to
the bar graph we will right click on the
chart and in the menu that appears we
will select select data option a window
that appears on the screen in that
window we will select add option as
shown we can also see the start date is
already in the entry section then in the
dialog box that appears type tenure in
the series name and click on the rain
selection icon that's shown in the
figure now select the relevant data from
the tenure column and click on ok now we
can see a bar graph that has two colors
on the screen this bar graph now has the
duration of the tasks the fourth step we
have is adding description to the gantt
chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the edit
option as shown in the figure then we
will select the tasks as we had selected
the duration of the tasks before and
click on ok we can now see the tasks
have appeared towards the left side of
the gantt chart the fifth and the
remarkable step will help us convert
this bar graph into a gantt chart we
will now click on the bars and select
the format data series option from the
menu that appears then in the format
data series dialog box we will select no
fill option we can find our gantt chart
on the screen now in accordance with the
data that we had entered now we can see
the tasks on the left side are in the
reverse order so what we will do next is
we will click on the task panel then go
to the format access dialog box and
select the categories in reverse order
option now we can find the tasks in the
right order one more thing we can notice
is gantt chart is starting with some
other date and not with the dates that
we had entered so for this we will copy
the first date in some other cell then
clicking on the copied cell we will go
to the home menu to select the dialog
box as shown in the figure then in that
drop down menu we will select the number
option we can now find a value displayed
in the copied cell we'll copy that value
click on the dates on the chart and as
the format access dialog box opens we
will paste that value in the box that
says minimum shown in the figure as a
result we will have our final gantt
chart on the screen in the last step we
can give several designs to a gantt
chart change colors and make it more
presentable for us now when we know the
basic steps of making a gantt chart i
will show that practically to you in
microsoft excel our first step is to
open microsoft excel and in microsoft
excel we will make a project table in
our project table we will have three
columns the first column will be task
the second column will have the start
date the third column will have tenure
or the duration of the task so beginning
with tasks we have task 1 in task 1 we
have 1.1 1.2 1.3 then comes task 2. in
task 2 we have 2.1 2.2 2.3 and 2.4 then
we have task 3 in task 3 we will have 2
subsections 3.1 and 3.2 then we will
start with the starting dates in
starting dates we will put 1st january
the task 1 1.1 will be 1st of january
then this will be 4th january let's say
this is 5th january then we will put
this as 11th of january and this will be
again 11th january only this will be
15th january let's put this as 17th
january let this be 19th january task 3
begins on 23rd january
and it the 3.2 section begins at 26th of
january now let's put the tenure or the
duration of the task we will begin with
task 1. it takes 12 days then 1.1 takes
7 days we say this takes 4 days and this
takes 8 days then for task 2 it again
takes 12 days it takes 5 days
5 days
and let's say this takes 6 days and this
takes 4 days then we come to task 3 this
takes 8 days and let's say this takes 6
days and the 3.2 section takes 5 days so
this is how our project table is ready
in the second step we will select the
entire second column after we have
selected this column we will go to the
insert tab in the insert tab we'll go to
the bar columns and in this we will
select 2d stacked bar charts now we have
the entitled bar chart in accordance to
our data on the screen then comes the
third step we will add the duration of
the tasks to the bar graph we will click
on the chart and after we click on the
chart we will select
select data option in the select data
source dialog box we find the start date
is already there now we will click on
add and after we click on add in the
series name section we will put tenure
then in the series value we will click
on this icon and select the entire
tenure series and click on ok so this is
the bar graph that we have now this is
now in two colors the orange color and
the blue color this bar graph now has
the duration of all the tasks in our
project table now in the fourth step now
it's time for us to add description to
our gantt chart instead of this 1 2 3 4
5 we will put task 1 task 2 and the sub
tasks so what we will do is we will
again go to that box we will left click
on the gantt chart select the select
data option and then we'll go to the
start date here we'll select the edit
option in the edit option we will select
all the tasks and click on ok now we can
see all the tasks are aligned towards
the left of the bar chart as we can see
this is a bar chart or a bar graph and
not a gantt chart the next step we have
is converting this bar graph into a
gantt chart so we will click on the bars
and select the format data series option
from the menu that appears here we have
this format data series option now we
can see the dialog box on the screen
here we'll go into the color section
fill section
and then we will select no fill now we
can see the blue lines have disappeared
so this looks like a gantt chart so now
when we have a gantt chart on the screen
we can notice that the task here are in
the reverse order so what we will do is
we will click on these tasks and select
the format access option here we will
select categories in reverse order we
can see our gantt chart is now in order
like we have a task 1 on the top and
task 3 at the bottom the dates are
starting from 11th of december but the
dates we have provided are from 1st of
january now we will copy this cell then
go on the dates box here we'll go to
format access in the format axis we can
see
minimum in this minimum we will paste
this value and press enter as we press
enter we can see our gantt chart
starting from the date that we wanted to
start and that too in the correct order
starting from task 1 to task 3. now as a
result we have our final gantt chart on
the screen in the last step what we can
do is make our gantt chart more
representable we can change the color of
these bars we can give them shapes and
we can do many other things to make it
more presentable we will first select
the bars like what we will do is we will
select task 1 and let's say we give it
the color blue then task 2 we will give
it color green and in task 3 we'll give
give it the color black so here the sub
sections will give different colors to
the subsections as well then we come to
task 2.1 this is how we can change the
color of these cells or apart from
changing colors we can select a bar
graph and do the gradient fill so this
is how we can make a gantt chart more
presentable after changing the colors or
changing the shapes we have our final
gantt chart on the screen finally let's
have a look at some microsoft excel
templates for project management
microsoft excel templates help in
collecting data putting them into order
and check their dependencies with each
other with the help of these templates
we can monitor the status of the tasks
and we can also check the progress our
project has made moving forward we will
check some important microsoft excel
templates the first template we have is
excel project review template this
template helps us have an overview of
the project we can have a clear
understanding of all the tasks that are
planned and that are completed this
helps project managers to measure the
progress of the project and take further
steps accordingly second template we
will check is excel budget template in
this template we can monitor all the
expenditures of our project it helps us
in managing the budget of a project and
also helps in comparing the budget of a
project at different phases let's have a
look at the budget template in excel
once we can download this template from
officetimeline.com the gantt chart
towards the right is in accordance with
the dates towards the left if we
fluctuate the date we can see the
template working the start date for task
1 could be changed to 10th june if we
change this date to 10 june we can see
the fluctuation in the gantt chart so
this is how we can use this template
directly let's have a look at the third
template now third template we will see
is excel sprint project tracker template
this template is used majorly in agile
projects where the project is made in
several sprints or sessions this
template includes the start date the end
date and the duration of each task we
can also see the percentage completed of
each task let's have a look at the
sprint project tracker template as well
we can see the gantt chart towards the
right and the data towards the left
so if we change any data we can see the
gantt chart changing for example we can
change the data in sprint to feature 3.
let's change the start date to july 2nd
we can see the gantt chart changing
this is how we can use this template
directly to track our sessions let's
have a look at the fourth excel template
this template is excel project tracker
in this template we have the data of all
the tasks with the status and owners we
can track the percentage of task
completed and also compare the planned
duration of the task to the actual
duration of the task after the critical
part tracker let's check the excel
project schedule template this template
helps in effective management of the
project as it helps in monitoring the
time that each task of the project takes
it provides a clear view of all the work
associated with the project let's have a
look at this template in excel once we
can see the gantt chart in accordance to
the data if we change the estimated
hours at two places let's say at the
design review we make it 15 hours
instead of five hours and at the create
staffing plan we make it two hours
instead of 20 hours we can see the gantt
chart fluctuating this is how we can use
this template to manage the schedule in
a project moving forward the next
template we will see is excel project
status report template this template
helps us having a list of project
deliverables and the risks associated
with that project this template helps
the project managers about different
crucial activities involved in a project
after this we have excel milestone
tracker the milestone tracker helps us
in tracking or monitoring different
tasks in a project project managers use
this template to monitor the project
performance with respect to the
timelines the last template we will see
is excel project planner excel project
planner includes a list of tasks with
the respected owners along with the
start date and the end date of that task
this helps in monitoring each task and
comparing the estimated task date with
the actual ones let's have a look at
this template in excel we can see the
gantt chart with respect to the data
entered let's make changes at several
places in the data we can make this 22
to 24 we will make this 23 go to 2 and
we can make this 5th september go to 15
september and when we make the changes
we can realize the gantt chart is
fluctuating so this is how we can use
this template to plan a project
effectively and efficiently in this
lesson we will focus on project time
management let us begin with the
objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project time management
explain project schedule
gap charts and network diagrams
identify the key terms used in project
time management
describe the project time management
processes
explain various schedule network
analysis techniques
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the third
knowledge area that is project time
management and its processes
let us begin with the first topic of
this lesson project time management
the purpose of project time management
is to ensure that the projects get
completed on time
this knowledge area is primarily
concerned with developing a project
schedule and ensuring that project goes
as per the agreed schedule
if there is a need to change the project
schedule the change should happen by
following a proper change control
procedure
another term used in the pmp examination
is schedule management plan
schedule management plan is part of the
project management plan and has
information on the planned project
schedule and its management and control
let us discuss the key activities of
project time management in the next
screen
the key activities that are part of the
project time management include
identifying activities estimating time
and resources and sequencing activities
it is important to identify a list of
activities that would be a part of the
project
next an estimation of time and resources
required for completing the identified
activities are done
finally these activities need to be
sequenced as per the dependencies
in the next screen let us discuss
project schedule
project schedule represents the time
dimension of the project plan and has
information like when the project would
start when each of the project
activities would happen
in what order the project activities
would happen when project would be
completed etcetera
usually software system is used to
develop the project schedule
the project team can enter the list of
activities in the software as well as
their dependencies and the software can
produce the project schedule as the
output microsoft project is the most
popular tool used for project schedule
development generally project schedule
is considered similar to project
management plan
project management plan is different
from project schedule
project management plan not only has
information about the project's schedule
but also other important project related
plans like risk management plan cost
management plan etc
let us focus on gantt chart in the next
screen
gantt chart is a type of bar chart that
illustrates a project schedule
it shows the dependencies between the
project activities as well as their
percent completion
a sample gap chart is shown on the
screen
two summary elements of the work
breakdown structure are depicted to
complete those elements there are a
number of activities under them
some of these activities have
dependencies
for example
activity b and c have a dependency
activity c can start only when activity
b is completed
the chart gives you an idea about when
specific activities are planned to
finish and when the overall wbs element
will get delivered
create tasks and work with the gantt
chart
this will make answering gantt chart
based questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us understand the
relationships that exist among project
activities
network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model pdm or
activity on node aon
boxes represent activities and the
arrows indicate the dependency this type
of network can have all four types of
relationships between the activities
in arrow diagramming model adm or
activity on arrow aoa
the arrows represent activities the
relationships and sequences can be
inferred from the direction of the
arrows and linkages between the
activities
in such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the network diagram
so create and work with the diagram this
will make answering network diagram
based questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us look at a
network diagram
a sample network diagram is shown on the
screen
activities a and c can happen in
parallel
b and d require both a and c to complete
whereas e requires both b and d to
complete activity on aero network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
reporting purposes in the next screen
let us look at a few important terms in
time management
when a successor activity can start
before the predecessor activity can
complete it is considered lead for
example you can start preparing the test
environment two weeks before the
development activity finishes
when the successor activity has to wait
for a few days after the predecessor
activity has been completed it is
considered lag
for example one needs to wait for two
days for the foundation to settle before
work on the pillars for the next floor
starts
rolling wave planning is an iterative
planning technique in which the work to
be accomplished in the near term is
planned in detail while the work in the
future is planned at a higher level it
is a form of progressive elaboration
in the context of estimating techniques
analogous estimating is based on the
previous project data
therefore if the last five similar
projects took six months to complete the
next one will also take six months
this technique employs expert judgment
another estimating technique is
parametric estimating
this technique uses a mathematical model
to calculate projected time for an
activity based on the historical records
from previous projects and other
information
a few common parameters are identified
based on the previous project data
and that parameter is used to predict
the time required to complete the next
activity or project
for example you can normally complete 10
kilometers of highway construction lanes
a week effort is the total amount of
work required to complete the activity
duration is the amount of time it takes
in terms of a lab store calendar days
if you have an activity that requires 10
people to work for five days the total
effort is 50 person days but the
duration is only five days
in the next screen let us look at the
project time management processes
there are seven project time management
processes
they are plan schedule management define
activities
sequence activities
estimate activity resources
estimate activity durations develop
schedule and control schedule
the first six processes are executed
during the planning process group
the ultimate goal of these planning
processes is to develop the project
schedule
the seventh and the last process
is a part of the monitoring and
controlling process group
in the next few screens let us discuss
these processes in detail
we will begin with plan schedule
management
as defined in pmbok guide plan schedule
management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning developing
managing executing and controlling the
project schedule it belongs to the
planning process group
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and will guide
the schedule planning activities on the
project
the project charter provides an overall
context and the high level product and
project description
which might help determine the approach
for schedule management few projects
might have scheduling constraint
for example
projects of olympics 2016 should be
completed at the same time
enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project including the culture of the
organization the infrastructure like
scheduling systems available key
personnel and so on
organizational process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base
now let us look at the tools and
techniques employed in this process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can draw from their previous
experiences the proper approach to
govern the schedule on a project
meetings may be organized to determine
the schedule management plan
anybody responsible for the project
schedule management such as the project
manager sponsor customer and other
stakeholders must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the schedule
management plan
these may include different planning
approaches and philosophies such as
rolling wave planning or different
scheduling software that allow to build
what-if scenarios
and study the effect of advanced
scheduling techniques like leveling fast
tracking and crashing
now let us look at the outputs of this
process
schedule management plan is a component
of the project management plan that
describes the criteria and activities
required to arrive at the project
schedule as well as how the project may
be baselined monitored and controlled
in the next screen let us define
activities process
define activities is the process of
identifying the specific actions to be
performed
to produce the project deliverables
it belongs to the planning process group
the important input for the define
activities process is the scope baseline
scope baseline is a term used
collectively to refer to project
deliverables constraints and assumptions
of the project
in addition to the scope baseline the
other inputs in this process are
enterprise environmental factors
organizational process assets
and schedule management plan
a reason why enterprise environmental
factors is an input to define activities
is because the organization might be
using project management software to
define activities and that may influence
the activity definition process
the knowledge base containing historical
information regarding activities lists
used by previous similar projects is a
good example of organization process
assets applied to scheduling
the tools and techniques used in
defining activities are decomposition
and rolling wave planning
the last technique is expert judgment
where the experience of project team
members is used in developing detailed
activity lists
the output of the process is activity
list activity attributes and milestone
list
activity list contains a list of
identified activities
activity attributes are the additional
information about the activity itself
a milestone is a significant point or
event in the project
a milestone list identifies all the
milestones and indicates whether the
milestone is mandatory or optional
let us move on to the next process
sequence activities
sequence activities is the process of
identifying and documenting
relationships among the project
activities and is also part of the
planning process group
for every activity and milestone except
the first and last one is connected to
or at least one predecessor and one
successor
the inputs to this process are activity
list activity attributes and milestone
list
all these are the outputs of the define
activity process
the other inputs are schedule management
plan and project scope statement
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
organization process assets are also an
input to sequencing activities because
the organization might have some kind of
knowledge base for scheduling project
activities
the enterprise environmental factors
relevant to this process may be
scheduling tools in use project
management information systems
work authorization systems etc
one of the important tools and
techniques used in sequencing activities
is the precedence diagramming method
in this method the activities are drawn
on a network diagram and all the
different kinds of dependencies between
the activities are determined
while determining activity dependency it
is important to identify the type of
relationship or dependency between the
activities
the other technique is leads and lag
which is widely used for sequencing
activities
the output of the process is the project
schedule network diagram
which is a graphical representation of
the project activities in a form of
network which also shows the activity
dependencies
while designing the network diagram new
activities might be identified and that
would result in some of the project
document updates especially the ones
that list all the project activities
in the next screen let us look at the
estimate activity resources process
after sequencing the activities the next
step in project time management is
estimating the resources required to
accomplish each of the identified
activities
estimate activity resources process also
belongs to the planning process group
here resources do not mean only the
human resources but includes all other
resources like equipment raw materials
machinery etc
schedule management plan is the first
input
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
the other inputs to this process are an
activity list and activity attributes
that are the outputs of the time
management processes
risk register is another input
risks to the project may influence the
decisions about the resources that need
to be deployed hence risk register
becomes an input to this project
in addition activity cost estimates are
another input
cost and resource estimates on a project
are interrelated and influence each
other
for example the cost might dictate the
number and type of resources that can be
employed or the time might dictate the
cost that may need to be incurred
along with this the resource calendar is
also an important input because it has
the information about the availability
of each of the resources
some of the enterprise environmental
factors that can influence estimating
activity resources are
availability of required resources
within the organization
the organizational process assets is
also an important input as the
organization might have standard
policies for staffing or for hiring
contractors on the project
with all these inputs available for
estimating activity resources
there are various techniques used for
estimating the required resources
the first technique is using expert
judgment
in this technique an expert in resource
planning and estimating can estimate
each of the activities
the next technique used is alternative
analysis
in this the activities are analyzed to
identify different ways of completing
them
this is to ensure only the required
resources are assigned to each of the
activities
this helps in resource optimization
along with the two techniques many
organizations routinely publish their
estimating data and this could be used
in activity resource estimation
another technique that is routinely used
in activity estimation is bottom-up
estimating which is decomposing the
activity further down to understand it
in more detail and estimating at that
level
later all such estimates are added to
arrive at the estimate of the activity
in real projects one has to use all the
estimate each of the activities
sometimes the project management
software also helps in estimating
the software estimates are based on the
inputs provided to it
software should only be considered as a
supporting tool in estimation and never
fully rely on its output
clearly the output of this process is
the activity resource requirements
along with this resource breakdown
structure is also prepared
the resource breakdown structure is the
categorization of all the required
resources in various categories that is
human resources equipment raw materials
etc
in the process of estimation several
other project documents may also be
updated
for example the resource estimates are
directly correlated with cost estimates
let us now move on to the next process
estimate activity durations
the next process is to estimate the
duration required to complete each of
the activities
the duration estimation should be done
by someone who is familiar with the
project
for example the same activity if done by
a high skilled resource would take less
time compared to a less skilled resource
this may vary regardless of the resource
used due to the project requirements
in addition the activity duration
estimation should be updated
continuously as you move ahead with the
project
because as the project progresses there
will be more clarity on the project the
inputs of this process are similar to
the ones in sequence activities process
schedule management plan is the first
input
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
for instance it may contain information
about the estimation techniques to be
employed and the people who need to be
involved in the estimation process
activity resource requirements is also
an input to this process because
resources assigned to an activity would
significantly affect the activity
duration
that is the lower skilled resources
would take more time than the high
skilled resources
the other inputs include activity list
activity attributes and resource
breakdown structure
resource calendars are also an input to
this process
the type and skill set of resources
available to the team may have an impact
on the time it would take to complete
the activities
risks to the project may influence the
decisions about the time required to
complete the activity
hint risk register becomes an input to
this process
the project scope statement defines the
constraints and assumptions affecting
the project duration
an example of enterprise environmental
factor that can affect duration is
organization's productivity metrics
which is collected based on the
experiences from multiple projects
the last input in this process is
organizational process assets
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used for estimating activity
durations
first is the expert judgment which means
using previous project experiences and
estimating the current project duration
this can be used with other estimation
techniques and used to reconcile
differences if different techniques
result in different estimates
three-point estimating is a method where
three estimates are used instead of one
it is part of a project management
philosophy known as program evaluation
and review technique
pert
estimating activity durations is often
done as a team exercise as each activity
may require multiple skill sets to be
applied
therefore it is important to use group
decision making techniques to arrive at
a consensus or at least an estimate that
is acceptable to all the team members
reserve analysis adds buffer into the
project schedule to deal with any
uncertainty
the contingency reserve may be added as
a percentage of the activity duration or
fixed number of work periods
the other tools and techniques are
analogous estimating and parametric
estimating
the outputs of this process are the
activity duration estimates and project
documents updates
the activity duration estimates is
represented in terms of the range of
possible results
for example
10 days plus minus 2 days that is the
activity would take minimum 8 days and
maximum 12 days in the next screen let
us look into a business scenario to
understand this concept better
after reading the problem statement
click the solution button to look at a
possible answer
develop schedule is the process of
analyzing activity sequences durations
resource requirements and schedule
constraints to create the project
schedule
it belongs to the planning process group
generally scheduling software is used
for developing the project schedule
entering the activities durations and
resources into a scheduling tool
generates a schedule with planned dates
for completing project activities
developing a project schedule is an
iterative process
revising and maintaining a realistic
schedule is a task in itself and it
continues throughout the project as the
work progresses
the most of the inputs of this process
are the outputs of estimate activity
durations process
they are risk register project scope
statement project staff assignments
resources calendars
organizational process assets
enterprise environmental factors
schedule management plan
activity list
activity attributes
project schedule network diagrams
activity resource requirements
resource breakdown structure and
activity duration estimates
various tools and techniques are used to
develop schedule process
schedule network analysis is a technique
that generates project schedule
it employs various analytical techniques
such as critical path method
critical chain method
modeling techniques and resource
optimization techniques to create the
project schedule the other tools and
techniques include leads and lags
schedule compression and scheduling tool
let us now look at the outputs of this
process
the project schedule consists of a
minimum plan start date and planned
finish date for each activity
although project schedule can be
represented in tabular format it is more
often represented graphically using
either bar charts or network diagrams
or a combination of the two
the final schedule which is the output
of the developed schedule process is
also called schedule baseline
once the schedule is baselined it can be
changed only through formal approvals
meeting the schedule baseline is one of
the measures of project success
scheduled data produced may include
number of resources key milestones etc
project
specify the available working days and
the number of shifts in each day
it indicates how many hours and days are
available for the work of the project to
be completed
project management plan updates are a
result of the develop schedule process
many of the other subsidiary plans of
the project plan may get impacted which
may include cost management plan scope
management plan risk management plan etc
this may also result in other project
documents being updated
in the next few screens let us discuss
schedule network analysis techniques
it is essential to know if the required
resources are available at that time
along with the time estimate of each of
the activities
since schedule is calendar based it
helps in estimating the same
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule
there are various schedule network
techniques
critical path method relies on
determining the critical path on a
project schedule
critical chain method is a variant of
the critical path method wherein the
critical chain is determined based on
the logical resource and other kinds of
dependencies between the activities
what-if scenario analysis is about
trying to vary a certain parameter to
observe the impact on the schedule
for instance you may want to check
result if you put in more resources on a
particular activity to reduce its
duration
resource optimization techniques try to
arrive at the optimal utilization of the
resources used on a project
ideally you would want the resources to
be fully utilized but you would also
want to build insufficient buffers in
case a certain resource is not available
due to various reasons in the next
screen let us look at the program
evaluation and review technique
program evaluation and review technique
is based on three-point estimates for an
activity
the pessimistic estimate refers to the
worst case scenario
whereas most likely estimate is what you
expect to happen in a realistic scenario
the optimistic estimate on the other
hand represents the amount of time an
activity would take in the best case
scenario
based on these three estimates the
expected duration of the estimate is
calculated as per the formula given on
the screen
the formula for calculating standard
deviation of an activity and variance of
an activity is also given
there is no question asked on variance
but the formula is important because if
the standard deviation of the whole
project is to be calculated the process
is to calculate the variance of the
whole project and then take its square
root to calculate the standard deviation
of the project
concept-based questions on pert can be
expected in the pmp exam
so make a note of the formulae while you
prepare for the exam
in the next screen let us understand
pert with an example
let us now figure out how we can apply
the three-point estimation that pert
uses in order to draw some useful
conclusions
assume that the optimistic pessimistic
and most likely estimates are 20 70 and
30 respectively
using these values you can determine the
expected duration and the standard
deviation as indicated
now if the causes of variation are
random you can assume that the actual
values would be evenly distributed about
the mean
and will follow the normal distribution
sometimes referred to as the bell curve
further you can use the properties of
the normal distribution
there is a 68 probability of the actual
value falling within first sigma from
the mean
95.4 percent probability for the second
sigma and 99.7 percent probability of
the actual value falling within third
sigma
extending this logic the notion of six
sigma is reaching a level of confidence
that only 3.4 times out of a million
would the actual value fall outside the
stated range
pert allows you to plan based on the
intended level of confidence in the
outcome and determine buffers
accordingly
let us discuss the critical path method
in the next screen
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project
float can be considered as a buffer time
available to complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack
there are three kinds of float
the first being the total float which is
the amount of time an activity can be
delayed without delaying the project end
date or an intermediary milestone
the second type of float is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successors activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero
because there is no scope to delay
activities on the critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration
delaying activities on the critical path
is as good as delaying the project
duration concept-based questions on
critical path can be expected in the
exam so it is essential to have a clear
understanding of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
float of an activity can be calculated
by two methods
however the first step in critical path
method is to identify the critical path
of the network
once the critical path is identified
follow the forward pass to find early
start and early finish for each activity
the float of the activities on the
critical path is zero so they represent
the overall project duration
use forward pass or backward pass to
calculate the total activity time
calculate late finish and late start
using backward pass method
note the total float formula before you
start for the exam
in the next screen let us look at
forward pass and backward pass methods
in detail
in forward pass you can either go
through the network starting with time
zero and keep calculating the time
required to complete each of the
activities until you reach the last
activity of the project
the starting time for each of the
activity in this approach is called
early start and the end time for each
activity is called the early finish
alternatively in backward pass you can
travel through the network from the
project and date and calculate the time
required to complete each activity
the end date in this approach is called
the late finish and the start date of
the activity in this approach is called
the late start
the float of the activity is either the
difference between the late start and
early start or the difference between
the late finish and early finish
both the differences work out to be the
same before the start of the pmp exam
please make a note of the total float
formula
let us understand the critical path
calculation with an example in the next
screen
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram
start 1 2 4
5 and is one path
and start one three five and is the
second path
since the duration of the path start one
two four five end is 18 days
which is more than the duration of the
path start 1 3 5 and
the critical path of the project is
start 1 2 4 5 and
let us take activity 3 as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
activity 3 can start only after activity
1.
since the early finish of activity 1 is
3 it becomes the early start of activity
three
activity three cannot start earlier than
three because activity one can be
completed only by then
therefore early start of activity three
is three
since the duration of the activity is
four days
the early finish of activity three is
three plus four equals seven days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity three
late start of activity 5 is 14 days the
activity 3 happens just before activity
so the late finish of activity 3 is 14
days
to calculate the late start you can
subtract the duration from late finish
therefore the late start of activity
three is fourteen minus four equals ten
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression
look at the four activities in the table
the normal cost of executing each of the
activities as well as how much each of
the activities can be crashed is also
provided
which activity would you crash to reduce
the project time by one day
activity a will be crashed if the
duration of the project is reduced by
one day
as the per unit cost of crashing the
activity a is the least
all the activities are assumed to be on
the critical path here
while crashing if you end up saving time
on a path which is not the critical path
you will not end up saving time on the
project
in the next screen let us look into the
impact of schedule compression
different schedule compression
techniques have different impact on the
project
the impact of fast track leads to risk
additions and increase in management
time for the project manager
crash leads to cost addition and
increase in management time for the
project manager
reduce scope on the other hand saves
cost and resources but increases
customer dissatisfaction
likewise cut quality saves cost and
resources but increases risk
resource reallocation does not add cost
or increase risk
in the next screen let us look into the
other techniques used in scheduling
there are several techniques that are
used in scheduling projects
what-if scenario analysis in this
technique questions like what if a
particular scenario changed on the
project would that produce a shorter
schedule
are put forth to understand the impact
of specific changes on the schedule the
goal is to produce a realistic schedule
monte carlo analysis
in this method a computer simulates the
outcomes of a project making use of
randomly generated values that map the
probability distribution of the input
variables
together these two techniques are called
modeling techniques
resource optimization techniques
these are also used to produce a
resource limited schedule
resource optimization results in more
stable number of resources used in the
project
critical chain method
this technique develops the project
schedule that takes into account both
the activity and resource dependencies
in the next screen let us look at the
last process in project time management
control schedule
control schedule is concerned with
determining the status of the project
schedule determining that the project
schedule has changed and managing the
actual changes as they occur
the project schedule is an important
input to this process
it is the actual schedule that needs to
be controlled
scheduled data contains information
related to the schedule that may need to
be monitored in order to take actions to
bring the project back on schedule
project calendar describes the working
hours and days for the project
work performance data has information
like which activities have started their
progress and which activities have
finished
the other inputs of this process are
project management plan and
organizational process assets
the key tools and techniques of this
process are the performance reviews
performance review is measuring
comparing and analyzing schedule
performance such as actual start and
finish dates percent complete and
remaining duration for work in progress
the other tools and techniques include
resource optimization techniques
modeling techniques schedule compression
leads and lags scheduling tool
and project management software
in development schedule process
these techniques are used for the first
time to develop the project schedule
whereas in control schedule process
these techniques are used to update the
project schedule
the key output of the control schedule
process is the
work performance information
this is represented in the form of
schedule variance sv
and schedule performance index spi
as a part of the control schedule
process the project team will generate
forecasts
likely schedule for forthcoming
activities and project as a whole
the other outputs include organizational
process assets updates
change requests
project management plan updates and
project document updates
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project time management includes the
processes required to manage the timely
completion of the project
a project schedule defines the start and
end dates of the project and the project
activities
these activities are assigned a duration
and sequenced in a logical order
gantt charts and network diagrams are
used to identify project activities and
determine the relationships and
dependencies between them
get chart displays the start and end
dates of project activities the overall
project schedule and the logical task
relationships while network diagram is
used to plot the activity dependencies
plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity resources estimate activity
durations
develop schedule and control schedule
are the seven processes under project
time management
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule based on the
estimates of time and resource
requirements
in this lesson we will focus on project
cost management
let us begin with the objectives of this
lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project cost management
differentiate between cost estimation
and cost budgeting
explain control accounts
describe the project cost management
processes
apply earned value management technique
to track project performance
identify key terminologies used in
project cost management
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
fourth knowledge area that is project
cost management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project cost management
project cost management involves
activities like estimating the cost of
each of the project activities adding
the cost estimates of the related
activities to arrive at the cost budget
and controlling the cost to ensure that
project activities are completed within
the defined budget in the next screen
let us discuss cost management plan
the cost management plan is a vital step
in project cost management
it contains information like planning
the project cost managing and
controlling the project in relation to
the cost baseline and managing cost
variances
project cost management plan is a part
of the project management plan
the methods used in estimating the cost
of each of the project activities are
similar to the ones used in estimating
project time
for example time estimation methods like
expert judgment analogous estimating
bottom up estimating and reserve
analysis are few of the techniques that
are also used in estimating activity
cost
let us discuss control account in the
next screen
control account is an important concept
in the project cost management
project cost is generally estimated at
individual activity level
it becomes difficult to manage cost at
the activity level in large projects
therefore the cost is managed at a
higher level
this requires related activities to be
clubbed and their cost being managed
together as one unit this unit is called
control account
while estimating the project time
wbs is created to break down the project
into smaller deliverables
these deliverables are broken down into
work packages and these work packages
are in turn broken into activities
control account is defined at a level
higher than the work packages for
example
if five work packages are part of the
one control account
the cost of all activities belonging to
these five work packages are managed as
one unit
in the next screen let us discuss the
project cost management process
project cost management has four
processes
they are plan cost management estimate
costs determine budget and control costs
the three processes plan cost management
estimate costs and determined budget are
a part of planning process group and
control cost process is a part of
monitoring and controlling process group
let us look at each of these processes
in detail
let us begin with the first process that
is plan cost management in the next
screen
managing costs on a project is a
critical exercise if the activities are
planned well it becomes easier to
achieve harmony with the overall cost
and budget of the project
plan cost management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning managing
expending and controlling the project
costs
let us look at the inputs required for
this process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and guides the
cost planning activities on the project
the project charter provides an overall
context and high level product and
project description
which help determine the approach for
cost management
for example for some projects budget
could be a constraint whereas for others
budget would not be a constraint but
subject to the other objectives
enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project
including the culture of the
organization and the infrastructure
for instance the scheduling systems
available the key personnel and so on
organizational process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base
now let us look at the tools and
techniques employed in this process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can devise an approach to govern
the costs on a project by using their
previous experiences
meetings may be organized to determine
the cost management plan
everyone responsible for the project
schedule management such as the project
manager representatives from the
appropriate accounting or financial
organization sponsor customer and other
stakeholders must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the cost management
plan
these techniques help to map the impact
of various decisions on cost
for example how do risk management
processes impact cost etc
cost management plan is the primary
output of this process
it establishes the units of measure
levels of precision organizational
process links control accounts to be
used rules for performance measurement
and reporting frequency and methodology
of monitoring the costs and various
other details that lay the overall
framework for cost management on a
project in the next screen let us
discuss the second process under project
cost management
estimate cost
estimate cost is the approximation of
the monetary resources required to
complete a project activity
cost of a specific activity is estimated
based on the information available at
that point of time
as the project team gets more
information about the project the
activity cost estimation may change
let us look at the inputs of this
process
scope baseline is the most important
input as it details out the project
scope of work
along with that project schedule is also
important
this contains information like when and
which resource is required for the
project
it is good to remember that the same
kind of resources may have different
costs at different points of time human
resource management plan is another
important input
various elements like personnel rates
rewards or recognition programs etc are
covered in the human resource management
plan which is important in approximating
the cost estimate
human resource management plan will be
discussed in detail in the human
resource management knowledge area
risk register is also an input because
risk mitigation costs should be
considered in cost planning
more information on risk and its effect
in the project will be looked at in
detail in risk management knowledge area
another input enterprise environmental
factors provides organizational context
to the project
organization process asset is listed as
an input as organizations might have
standard set of cost estimation policies
or templates
cost management plan is another
important input
the cost management plan lays the
framework for the cost management
processes in the project
it provides guidelines such as the units
of measure accuracy desired
methodologies and tools to be used etc
let us now look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
expert judgment reserve analysis
analogous estimating cost of quality
parametric estimating project management
software bottom-up estimating
three-point estimating vendor bid
analysis and group decision making are
the various tools and techniques used in
this process
most of the tools and techniques used
here are similar to the ones used in the
time management knowledge area
vendor bid analysis is a technique used
to estimate project cost
for example a project requires material
procured externally through suppliers
in order to get that you invite bids
from three or four suppliers and assess
their quotations based on their
quotations you can get an idea of the
cost that will be involved in getting
the material for the project
group decision making technique is
another important technique for project
cost estimation
cost estimation is an exercise which may
be carried out by a group or committee
in order to gather well-rounded input
therefore group decision making
techniques may be used to arrive at a
decision that team can work with
the outputs of this process are quite
straightforward
estimates of each of the activities are
arrived at
basis of the estimate includes things
like how the estimate was developed what
were the assumptions made in estimating
etc
project document updates is also one of
the outputs because the cost estimates
may result in updates to other aspects
of the project for example quality risk
time etc
in the next screen let us discuss the
third process under project cost
management determine budget
once the estimate of each of the
activities is arrived at the next
project cost management process is to
determine budget
it is the process of aggregating the
estimated cost of individual activities
or work packages to establish an
authorized cost baseline
this is where the control account
concept comes into picture
the estimated costs of the activities
are aggregated to arrive at the cost
budget at the control account level
once approved this cost budget becomes
the cost baseline of the project
project cost performance is measured
against the cost baseline that is how
much more would the project cost be
compared to the original cost baseline
the cost baseline includes all
authorized budgets but excludes
management reserves
the inputs used in determining the
project budget are the activity cost
estimates and the basis of estimates
which are the output of the previous
cost management process
the cost management plan lays the
framework for the cost management
processes in the project
it provides guidelines such as the
budgeting cycle tools and techniques
used to prepare and approve the budget
etc
in addition to these two important
inputs scope baseline is also looked at
project schedule provides aggregate cost
in a particular calendar period to
ensure how much money can be made
available during that time
similarly resource calendar provides
information on the resource which is
assigned to the project at a particular
point of time
this information is then used to
indicate resource costs over the
duration of the project
risk register gives an understanding of
the overall level of risk on the project
and
therefore the level of contingency
reserves that need to be built into the
budget
agreements entered into with the
suppliers are also required to finalize
the budget
again organizational process asset is an
input because organization may have few
policies for reporting the cost budget
or there might be some cost budgeting
tools being used
there are various tools and techniques
used in determining budgets
cost aggregation technique involves
adding up the cost and aggregating them
at the control account level so that the
cost can be managed in a better way
in reserve analysis once the costs are
estimated some extra amount is added to
the estimate as a management reserve to
take care of any unplanned activities
expert judgment is a technique in which
an expert's help is sought to estimate
the activity cost
expert is someone who might have worked
on a similar project in the past and has
a good idea to estimate the activity
cost involved
historical relationships are used to
predict the total project cost using
mathematical model
this is similar to analogous estimate or
parametric estimate method
funding limit reconciliation technique
is used to ensure that cost on the
project is budgeted or spent as per the
availability of the fund
for example if the project can get the
funding of only fifty thousand dollars a
month the project budget should be
planned accordingly
the output of this process is the cost
baseline
this is an authorized project budget
over a period
this is used to measure monitor and
control overall cost performance of the
project
in addition to this the project funding
requirements are also arrived at
funding requirements means how much fund
the project requires monthly quarterly
or yearly for the execution
the last output of this process is
project document updates
an understanding of determining budget
may be useful when answering questions
in the pmp exam so make a note of the
inputs tools and techniques and outputs
of determining budget
in the next screen let us discuss the
last process of project cost management
that is control cost
control costs is the process of
monitoring the status of the project to
update the project budget and managing
changes to the cost baseline
updating the budget involves recording
actual costs spent until date
any increase to the authorized budget
can only be approved through the perform
integrated change control process
some of the typical activities that
happen as part of the control cost
process
are ensuring that cost expenditure does
not exceed the authorized funding
monitor the cost performance to
understand variants and monitoring the
work performance against the funds
expended
the inputs to the process are project
management plan organizational process
assets
project funding requirements and work
performance data
work performance data contains the
information about the project progress
the important tools and techniques used
in controlling costs are
earned value analysis management
forecasting
to complete performance index
other important aspects of controlling
costs are the review the performance
analyze the reserves to make sure the
project has enough budgetary reserves to
meet the expenses and project management
software which helps in tracking and
managing costs
now
let us look at the output of this
process
the key outputs of this process are work
performance information in terms of cost
variance cv
schedule variance sv
and earned value ev and forecasts about
the cost performance
this process may also result in change
requests arising out of cost control
measures as well as updates to project
documents the project management plan
and organizational process assets
business scenario based questions on
project cost control can be expected in
the exam
so if you have questions on these
concepts get them cleared as that will
help you score higher
in the next screen let us learn about
earned value management and its related
terms
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan it is a method
of measuring the project performance
objectively and comparing it against the
project baseline
results from an earned value analysis
indicate deviation of the project from
cost and schedule baselines
baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes therefore
schedule baseline is the first approved
project schedule along with approved
changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique
planned value is the authorized budget
assigned to the scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed
budget at completion is the budgeted
amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
estimate to complete is the expected
cost to finish all the remaining project
work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit at the end of
the project all the parameters displayed
on the screen are measured in terms of
cost you may come across business
scenario based questions on earned value
management in the pmp exam so ensure
that you develop a clear understanding
of this topic
let us look at an example of a planned
value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned
this value is measured in terms of
currency say dollar
if the plan value is 340 dollars then
the work plan is worth hundred forty
dollars
how do you calculate earned value the
solution is add the budget allocated to
each of the activities that have been
completed at the point of time
the resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget
positive means the project is under
budget similarly in schedule variance
negative means the project is behind
schedule whereas positive means the
project is ahead of schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index cpi and schedule
performance index spi values vary
between 0 and 1.
for example a cpi of 0.8 implies that 80
cents of work is obtained for every
dollar spent in the project similarly if
spi is 0.9
it implies that project is progressing
at only 90 percent of the speed
originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or eac
there are different ways of calculating
the eac value the method used depends on
how the cost and schedule variances are
expected to play for the rest of the
project
bac by cpi is used if you expect that
the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
ac plus bac minus ev is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate ac plus
bac minus ev by the product of cpi and
sbi
is used if you want to factor in the
impact of the cost as well as schedule
variances
ac plus etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or etc which is the cost of
project from this point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate and
completion
in addition variance at completion can
be calculated by subtracting the
estimate at completion from the budget
at completion
variance at completion is the cost
estimation whether it is over or under
budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi
this is the cost performance needed to
achieve a desired outcome
for example
if the project needs to be managed to
the original budget bac then tcpi that
is the cpi that must be maintained for
the rest of the project
is calculated as
bac minus ev by bac minus ac
similarly if it has to be managed within
a revised target say eac
then tcpi is calculated as
bac minus ev by eac minus ac
before the start of the pmp exam please
make a note of the formulas of earned
value technique
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars
the phases are planned to be completed
one after the other the status of the
project at the end of the month three is
summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars
development and unit testing is only
fifty percent done though it was
supposed to be completed by third month
it has cost nine thousand dollars until
date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
note s indicates start time
f indicates finish time and pf indicates
that it is partly finished at the end of
the month
based on the above information calculate
the cv sv cpi and spi of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson
let us also look at a few definitions
that might be useful for your pmp
examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily
have the time working capital the amount
of money the company has to invest on
the project and the day-to-day company
operations funding limit reconciliation
the process of comparing the planned
expenditure in a given period with the
available funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time
this is called depreciation
there are two forms of depreciation
straight line and accelerated
same amount of depreciation is taken
every year for instance a car with a
price tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful life of ten years is depreciated
one thousand dollars per year
at the end of the tenth year the value
of the car is considered zero for all
accounting purposes accelerated
depreciation depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on let us now check
your understanding of the topics covered
in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project cost management includes the
processes involved in estimating
budgeting and controlling costs so that
the project can be completed within the
approved budget
cost management plan contains details on
how to plan manage and control the
project cost in relation to the cost
baseline and manage the cost variances
cost estimate is an educated guess of
how much an activity or project will
cost
budget considers the cost estimate and
accordingly sets aside funds for the
completion of the project
under control account technique related
activities are clubbed and their costs
are managed as one unit
the four project cost management
processes are
plan cost management estimate costs
determine budget control costs
earned value management technique
indicates potential deviation of the
project from the cost and or schedule
baselines
in this lesson we will focus on project
quality management let us begin with the
objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to define quality and quality
management differentiate between quality
planning quality assurance and quality
control
explain cost of quality and its
categories
describe the project quality management
processes
explain the seven basic tools of quality
explain six sigma
in the next screen
let us take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the fifth
knowledge area that is project quality
management and its processes in the next
screen let us understand what quality is
the project manager is responsible for
quality in a project however it is also
the responsibility of each and every one
in the project to ensure that whatever
they do meets project quality
expectations quality is defined as the
degree to which a set of inherent
characteristics fulfills requirements a
project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
usable means that the intended users can
use the product without any problem in
the next screen let us look at some
quality related terms
it is important to discuss a few terms
to understand the concept of quality
better customer satisfaction is defined
as conformance to requirements and
fitness for use it is important to
understand the subtle distinction
between quality and grade grade is a
classification
based on technical characteristics low
quality is always a problem but low
grade may not be a problem rather it
would be a matter of choice
similarly it is important to understand
the distinction between precision and
accuracy precision is the granularity of
measurement that is how fine grained can
you measure the outcome
accuracy is how correct you are that is
how close you are to the desired value
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of optimal level of quality
quality comes at a cost more effort put
in quality will give better results
however you cannot keep on investing on
increasing the quality as there is no
limit to how much a product can be
improved
investment in quality is determined by
knowing the optimal level of quality
optimal level of quality as shown in the
diagram is said to be achieved at the
point where the incremental revenue from
improvement equals the incremental cost
to secure it suppose you are the
manufacturer of toys but the toys are
below quality and the sales are low to
improve the quality you invest in
identifying the demands of children
sharing few samples and recording their
feedbacks
once all these are captured and
implemented in the products you lure the
parents to buy them as the investment is
increased to manufacture good quality
toys the cost will therefore increase
and it might become prohibitive for
parents to buy
optimal level of quality is reached at a
point where you get maximum number of
buyers for the toys manufactured now
that we are clear on the concept of
quality in the next screen let us
discuss quality management
quality management involves performing
activities like creating standard
policies and procedures and ensuring
that those standard procedures are being
followed properly in the project it aims
to ensure that project meets all the
initial agreed requirements without any
deviation and that the specified
approach to quality is implemented on
the project
three broad activities are done as part
of quality management they are quality
planning quality assurance and quality
control
quality planning is the first step when
quality related activities of the
project are planned
quality assurance is the next stage of
implementing those quality plans
and quality control is the last stage
when periodic checks are done to see if
project quality is improving
in the next screen let us look into the
differences between the three aspects of
quality management
it is important to understand the
different kinds of activities that come
under quality planning quality assurance
and quality control
once the quality planning is done the
quality management plan is ready
this quality management plan has
standards templates policies and
procedures to be followed in the project
it contains information on the level of
quality being aimed and the plan to
achieve that level it is the aim of
quality assurance activities to ensure
that the activities planned under
quality planning phase gets executed for
the project it is the task of quality
assurance to determine if the project is
complying with the organizational as
well as project policies and procedures
this is ensured by conducting regular
process audits to identify deviation
from what is planned in the quality
management plan
these audits are generally done by
quality department of the organizations
quality assurance focuses on the process
not on specific products the role of
quality control is to measure specific
project data or results against
standards to inspect and verify the
project's product defect repair and
measure whether quality indicators are
improving
quality control is about the product and
data
for example
it was planned as part of quality
management that project would get
completed plus or minus 10 percent
within the cost budget
three months back when the measurement
was done project was over budget by 20
percent
when the measurement was done a day
before it was only 15 percent over
budget
therefore the project has showed an
improvement of five percent in the last
three months and it is quite likely that
over the next three months project may
get within the planned limit of 10
percent instead of showing improvement
if the data shows cost increase then
corrective and preventative actions are
required to get the project within the
10 percent limit
this is quality control
in the next screen let us discuss a few
quality management concepts
let us look at some terms that are
commonly used in quality management
parlance total quality management or tqm
is a quality management philosophy that
involves holistic thinking about meeting
the objectives of an organization it
places the responsibility of quality
squarely on the management kaizen is a
japanese term that stands for change for
better kaizen philosophy is one that
should always be looking for small and
continuous improvements in the process
deeming cycle or pdca cycle that is plan
do check act is a process control and
improvement approach propagated by the
famous quality guru edward deming
it means you plan for something execute
it check the output and based on the
lessons you act to bring the deviations
under control
kanban is a poll based management system
that originated in japan
based on just in time jit inventory
management
the idea behind kanban is to minimize
the work in progress and achieve a
smooth flow in the process from start to
finish
because building up inventory only to
paper over the imperfections in the
system tends to hide the problems
in the next screen let us focus on cost
of quality
cost of quality is the cost that needs
to be incurred to make a quality product
the sum of all the costs incurred is
ensuring that project conforms to
requirement is cost of quality
cost of quality can be broken down into
two major categories
first is the cost of conformance or the
money spent during the project to avoid
failures
this can further be subdivided into
prevention costs which is the cost to
prevent errors
like training the team creating
documents on equipment and in time to do
it right the other subdivision is
appraisal costs or the cost for
assessing quality like testing
destructive testing loss and inspections
the second category is the cost of
non-conformance it is the money spent
during and after the project because of
failures this is subdivided into
internal failure costs it is the cost of
failures that occur before the product
is released to customers for example
rework and scrap the second subdivision
is external failure costs it is cost
incurred on failures that occur after it
has been released by the team for
example liabilities warranty work and
lost business
concept based questions on cost of
quality can be expected in the exam so
please make a note of the categories of
cost of quality let us look at the
project quality management processes in
the next screen
there are three project quality
management processes
of which the first process plan quality
management is done as part of the
planning process group the next process
perform quality assurance is done as
part of the executing process group and
the last process control quality is done
as part of the monitoring and
controlling process group
in the next three screens let us look
into each of these processes in detail
the aim of the plan quality management
process is to identify the relevant
requirements or standards to execute the
project effectively to achieve the
desired quality level
quality planning results in the creation
of the quality management plan
aim of the plan quality process is to
identify the standards
a standard is an agreed-upon process to
work or achieve a result a standard can
be set from within the organization or
government
once all the standards for the project
are identified the aim of the quality
planning activities involves determining
what work needs to be done to meet those
standards
before adhering to the standards you
should question their relevance with the
project
implementing all possible standards
applicable to the project in random will
have cost and time implications
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides the
scope schedule and cost baseline
all of which have an implication on the
quality management plan
quality plan has a direct correlation
with these
it might also have an impact on and be
impacted by other subsidiary management
plans such as risk management the
stakeholders of the project may have
specific requirements and views about
the quality parameters of the project
and these have to be considered
the risk register gives an indication
about the kind of risks that are
inherent in the project and also those
which must be considered while planning
the activities to ensure quality the
requirements for the project need to be
considered for planning quality related
activities
because quality is all about meeting the
requirements in addition to these
enterprise environmental factors and
organization process assets are also
listed as inputs because the standards
can be either from within the
organization or from government or other
external bodies
standards from within the organizations
are usually the best practices learned
over a period while executing numerous
projects an example of government
standards can be standards to control
air pollution by the motor vehicles
which vehicle manufacturers must adhere
to to accomplish quality planning first
analyze the benefits versus the costs of
meeting quality requirements
next identify the cost of quality and
confirm if that kind of investment in
quality is justified
in addition to these two benchmarking
helps in analyzing the quality of
activities of similar projects executed
in the past this helps in identifying
the particular quality of output of the
previous project which in turn acts as a
basis for the current project's quality
planning
design of experiments can also be used
for quality planning
this is a statistical way to determine
what variables will improve quality the
most for example in case of
manufacturing doors it can be determined
that increasing the quality of the wood
can have maximum impact on improving the
quality of the door in addition the 76
quality tools also known as the seven qc
tools are used to determine the plan to
achieve the desired level of quality
statistical sampling as a tool becomes
relevant whenever the quality plan
cannot be applied to all the artifacts
produced
for example if destructive testing is a
requirement then it can be carried out
only on a sample not on the entire
population
statistical sampling helps in arriving
at a representative sample that can give
useful information other additional
tools such as brainstorming force field
analysis etc may be used to determine
the quality management plan for the
project
conducting regular meetings is another
important tool the quality management
plan has to be determined in a
collaborative manner by consulting the
team members and other stakeholders
quality management plan is a key output
of this process
checklist is a list of items to inspect
for example many of the office buildings
have housekeeping checklists to ensure
that all floors cabins etc are cleaned
checklists are created during quality
planning and used in quality control
metrics are project specific data that
need to be measured to check the status
of the project the simplest project
metrics can be cost and schedule metrics
are also decided during quality planning
and used in quality control
one of the roles of the project manager
is to not only manage the project but
also improve processes in the project to
decrease the instances of defects which
in turn saves time and money such
activities are listed in the process
improvement plan which eventually
becomes part of project management plan
as a result of the planning activities
other project documents may also get
updated for example the quality
management plan may result in updates to
the cost or resource requirements there
may be questions in the pmp exam based
on the plan quality management process
so please ensure you have a fair
understanding of the concept before you
take the exam
in the next screen
let us discuss the second quality
management process
once the quality planning is over the
next process and project quality
management is quality assurance which
involves determining whether the
standards are being met and the
processes are being followed
therefore the input for this process is
the work that has been completed during
the quality planning stage
they are project documents quality
management plan
process improvement plan quality metrics
and quality control measurements
let us look at the tools and techniques
used in this process
quality audit is the process to check
whether the project is complying with
the organization policies standards and
procedures and determine whether these
policies standards and procedures used
are efficient and effective
so a good audit not only looks at this
compliance but also for the new lessons
learned from the current project that
can help make the future projects better
process analysis involves using the
lessons learned from doing the initial
few work to make the remaining work more
efficient
for example if the project involves
installing a software package then the
lesson learned from the first few
installations can be used to improve the
process on remaining installations
apart from these all the quality
management and control tools such as the
seven basic quality tools will be
relevant to this process
the key output of this process is
project documents updates to ensure that
if there is any deviation from agreed
standards it is corrected
also if there are any lessons learned
that can help improve the future
projects the organization process assets
get updated
this quality assurance may result in
improvement suggestions change requests
may be generated and the project
management plan may need to be updated
understanding characteristics of quality
assurance tools and techniques may be
useful while answering the exam
so prepare this topic well before you
take the exam
in the next screen let us discuss the
last process of quality management
the key focus of the quality control
activities is on the correctness of the
work
quality control helps answer questions
like is everything okay with the project
does the project plan require changes to
successfully execute the project
will the project succeed etc
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the quality metrics measurements are
done continuously to see whether the
project quality is improving the project
deliverables are inspected against the
planned checklists quality control acts
upon the deliverables and work
performance data produced in execution
it also refers to the project management
plan for understanding deviations from
the plan
it also considers the approved change
requests
information from other project documents
and organizational process assets there
are seven popular tools and techniques
used in doing the quality control
activities
they are collectively known as seven
basic tools of quality other relevant
tools are statistical sampling
inspection or testing and review of the
approved changes quality control
activities result in quality control
measurements the verified deliverables
validated changes
information about the work being
performed recommended changes and
updates to the organizational process
assets
project management plan and other
project documents
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
six sigma is a highly disciplined
process that focuses on developing and
delivering near perfect products and
services consistently if large volume of
data is plotted over a period of time
you would most probably have a
bell-shaped graph such graphs are also
called normal distribution graph
it's called as normal distribution
because any large volume of data is
plotted with the intent to track
variations would most probably be in a
bell-shaped curve the line corresponding
to the top of the bell curve is the
median of the data sample
standard deviation concept is used to
measure how far any data is from the
mean
standard deviation is also called sigma
one standard deviation from the mean
covers 68 percent of the data
six sigma means six standard deviations
from the mean
this would cover
99.99966 percent of the data
we will look at an example of six sigma
in the following screen
to understand six sigma let us look at
an example a tire manufacturing company
produces 100 000 tires a day it is not
possible to verify each and every tire
manually to ensure it is defect-free
instead random sample of these
manufactured tires are taken and checked
for defects assuming that the thickness
of the tires is a parameter to measure
defect any tire that has a thickness
more than or less than 10 millimeters is
considered to be defective
now if you measure the actual thickness
of all one hundred thousand tires
manufactured daily and plot them on a
graph you get normal distribution graph
one standard deviation from the mean
covers sixty eight percent of the data
meaning if the thickness of the one
hundred thousand tires are plotted sixty
eight thousand of them lie within one
standard deviation above or below the
mean now if a company operates at six
sigma level
they would ensure that all tires that
are up to six standard deviations from
the mean are defect free
therefore in such cases you can expect
only three defective tires out of a
million tires manufactured let us now
check your understanding of the topics
covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
a project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
quality management includes creating and
following policies and procedures that
meet the project's defined quality needs
quality planning defines the standards
templates policies and procedures
quality assurance determines if the
project is complying with the policies
and procedures quality control measures
specific project results against
standards
plan quality management perform quality
assurance and control quality are the
three project quality management
processes
seven basic quality tools are used to
plan and achieve the desired levels of
quality
at six sigma level there would be only
three defects out of a million units
manufactured
in this lesson we will focus on project
management framework let us begin with
the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project project management
program management and portfolio
management
recognize the roles of project
management office
identify the project constraints and
their impact on the project
explain the role of a project manager in
stakeholder management describe
different organization structure
differentiate between a project life
cycle and a product life cycle
let's begin this lesson with
understanding what a project is in the
next screen
a project is a temporary endeavor
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result for example developing
a new product service or result
constructing a building industrial plant
or infrastructure and implementing
improving or enhancing existing business
processes and procedures in the next
screen we will focus on the
characteristics of a project
project can be distinguished based on
its characteristics
the definition describes two
characteristics of a project
first it is temporary in nature
temporary here does not mean short in
duration a project can extend for long
duration based on the requirements for
example creating a new indigenous
missile defense system for a country
however there is always a definite
planned start and end date for a project
it cannot go on indefinitely
secondly the project is supposed to
produce a unique output
the output could be a product service or
result
there can be many common activities
between two projects but the outcome of
each project should be unique in some
way or the other
now let us look at what marks the end of
a project
a project ends when either the
objectives are met or the project is
terminated because the objectives will
not or cannot be met
the other reason to terminate the
project can be that the need for the
output of the project does not exist
anymore
usually the sponsor of the project takes
a call about the closure of the project
it is important to differentiate project
work from regular operational work
for example your office receptionist
does the same work every day of picking
any incoming call and directing the call
to the right person in the office
this is an ongoing repetitive work and
can be classified as operation
operations unlike projects are neither
temporary nor unique
creating a new software system to
effectively track your customer
complaint can be an example of a project
when the software is successfully
developed the project objective is met
which marks the end of the project
when you start using this software to
track customer complaints you are
entering into the operations phase
in the next screen let us now look into
project management
as defined in the pmbok guide project
management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
project management is achieved by proper
application and integration of the 47
processes project application and
integration means these processes should
be executed in the right manner as well
as in the right order in the next screen
let us discuss how to manage a project
program management is defined as the
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to a program to meet the
program requirements and to obtain
benefits and control not available by
managing projects individually as
defined in pmbok guide a program is a
group of related projects which when
managed as a group in a coordinated
fashion provides benefits and control
that are not available while managing
them individually these benefits could
be from decreased risk economies of
scale improved management of
dependencies delivery of additional
capabilities optimal utilization of
shared resources and so on
let us now learn the various features of
program management
random projects cannot be grouped
together as a program
the projects in a program should be
related in some way or the other and
there should be some value added in
managing them together
a project may not be a part of any
program but a program will always have
projects a project can also be executed
as a standalone project a program is
designed to deliver some strategic
benefits value to the organization
these benefits can be tangible or
intangible
examples of tangible benefit could be
increased profit margins or operational
cost savings
examples of intangible benefits could be
improved team morale or building up
certain competencies
while a project manager focuses
relentlessly on the fulfillment of the
project's requirements that is scope
cost time quality a program manager
needs to focus on ensuring that the
organizational benefits are realized
in the next screen let us understand
what a portfolio is
portfolio is yet another term used along
with project and program
a portfolio may have multiple projects
and programs that are managed as a group
to achieve strategic objectives
note that all projects and programs in a
portfolio may not be necessarily
interdependent or directly related
a portfolio can be created based on the
business objectives
for example an i.t service company can
have a portfolio named japanese projects
which is formed with an aim to take over
the japanese market by giving more
attention to these projects
within this portfolio similar projects
can be managed as a program
and all banking projects from japan can
be managed as a banking program
in the next screen let us discuss
portfolio management
portfolio management is the centralized
management of one or more portfolios
this includes identifying prioritizing
authorizing managing and controlling
projects programs and other related work
to achieve strategic business objectives
therefore whether the company should
have japanese projects as portfolio or
not is decided by portfolio management
in the next screen let us understand the
relationship between portfolios programs
and projects
the image on the screen will help you to
understand the terms portfolios programs
and projects
a portfolio is part of an organization's
overall strategy it represents a
conscious decision by an organization to
invest in the portfolio
the overall objectives of a portfolio
are then cascaded down to the lower
level components
the components could be sub portfolios
programs or projects
these components can further be broken
down into smaller components for ease of
management
although a project may not contain
operations a program or a portfolio it
can include other work
this other work may comprise training
and development customer support and
services etc
if the other work has synergy with the
overall objectives and adds to the
capability to deliver the higher level
benefits then it can be included in the
program or portfolio as well
in the next screen we will discuss
project management office
project management office or pmo is a
specific type of body or department
within an organization
pmo performs several roles in the
organization and these can broadly be
classified as primary roles and other
roles
typically the pmo may take up any one or
a combination of the three primary roles
it provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization
it provides support and training in
organization on how to manage projects
and finally it provides project managers
for different ongoing projects in the
organization
pmo may also help in managing
interdependencies between the projects
selecting managing and deploying shared
or dedicated project resources if need
be terminating a project and organizing
lessons learnt sessions and maintaining
the project management knowledge base
for an organization
in the next screen we will discuss how
to manage the triple constraints
any project can be done successfully if
there is no constraint on time or there
is unlimited budget available
unfortunately that is not true in real
life
a project is performed within some
constraint and these constraints are
usually competing
therefore if you change one it would
affect the other
for example if the project duration
increases it would lead to increase in
the project cost as well
triple constraint is a term that
originally referred to the three
competing project constraints within
which the projects are performed
these constraints are cost time and
scope
quality is a primary concern for a
project manager
therefore the project manager has to
make trade-offs to keep the scope cost
time quality plane in balance
to achieve the balance the project
manager also needs to manage other
aspects of the project
for instance the people stakeholders
risks communication and procurements
the project manager plays the essential
role of integrating all these different
aspects of project management
in the pmp examination you can expect
business scenario based questions
focusing on the triple constraints
in the next screen let us understand who
a stakeholder is
a stakeholder can be defined as the one
whose interests may positively or
negatively be affected or perceived to
be affected by the decision activity or
outcome of the project
as per the definition the project team
project manager project sponsor pmo
office customer etcetera are the
stakeholders of the project
a project sponsor is the one who gives a
go ahead for a project
and provides the necessary resources to
execute the project
therefore the head of projects in the
organization who provides a green signal
to start a project and allocates
required resources to the project is the
project sponsor a project sponsor is
usually somebody placed high up in the
organizational hierarchy of the
performing organization that is the
organization in which the work of the
project is being carried out in the next
screen let us look at stakeholder
management
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to manage
stakeholders a project manager has to
involve the stakeholders from the
beginning of the project
until the end so they are aware of every
step
a project manager has to take up
specific activities for stakeholder
management
identifying both internal and external
stakeholders missing out any stakeholder
can be disastrous for a project
a stakeholder who has identified towards
the end of the project may come up with
his own requirement at that stage and
incorporating them can be risky
determining stakeholder requirements
after identifying all the stakeholders
the project manager also needs to ensure
that their requirements are clearly
identified
sometimes stakeholders might themselves
not know of their requirement and it is
the job of the project manager to get
them right by doing a proper stakeholder
requirement analysis
determining stakeholder expectations
stakeholders might also have some
unstated expectations
which need to be clarified to see if it
can become a project requirement
it is again the role of the project
manager to determine the stakeholders
expectation
communicating with stakeholders
once all the stated and unstated
stakeholder requirements are known the
project manager as part of stakeholder
analysis should focus on communicating
them regularly to keep stakeholders
involved in the project once you
understand the practices of stakeholder
management it will be easier for you to
answer scenario based questions in the
examination
in the next screen let us look at the
various organization structure
projects are performed in an
organization and the functioning of the
organization might affect the project
the different organization structure
types explained here are based on the
level of authority that a project
manager gets into in those organizations
in a functional type of organization the
organization is grouped by the area of
specialization within different
functional areas
for instance marketing accounting
engineering etc are departments within
the organization each employee typically
reports to a functional manager
in such types of organization normally
projects are undertaken within the
department itself
if a project requires any assistance
from another department the request
moves from the head of the requesting
department to the head of the concerned
department
the team members do their normal
departmental work in addition to the
project work
the next type of organization is
projectized organization
in such organizations there are no
departments
the organization's resources mostly work
on projects team members report to a
project manager
the project manager has complete control
over the resources when the project is
completed either they move on to another
project or they look for some job
outside the company
they do not have a department for
themselves
the third type of organization is a
matrix organization which is a blend of
functional and projectized
organizational structure
a team member belongs to a department as
well as they are part of a project team
in such organization team members have
two bosses one their department head and
the second their project manager since
there are two bosses here this type of
organization is further classified into
three different types
they are weak strong and balanced matrix
organization
so out of the two bosses that team
members have in matrix organization if
the project manager has more authority
over the team member such organizations
are called strong matrix
where the functional manager has more
authority it's a weak matrix
organization
if they both share equal authority then
it is a balanced organization
there is another term that you might
find in the exam called tight matrix
this generally refers to a co-located
team that is a team that has been placed
in the same location to enhance their
performance
in the pmp exam
if there is no mention of the
organization type you can assume it to
be a matrix organization
let us look at each of these
organization structures in detail in the
next screen let us look at functional
organization
in a functional organization the
resources of the organization are
grouped by functions sometimes called
departments
examples of functions could be sales
finance administration manufacturing etc
each function plays a definite role in
the organization and is headed by a
functional head or supervisor
all the resources in such an
organization report directly into their
functions
therefore a salesperson would report
into the sales organizational hierarchy
a purchase executive would report into
procurement and so on
you would notice that in a functional
organization the project manager's role
is not explicitly called out
when a functional organization embarks
on a project each of the functions that
are involved may volunteer some
resources to work on the project
one of these resources may end up
playing the project manager's role
the resource assignments may not even be
full time and sometimes even the project
manager is part-time
since the project manager has no
authority over any of the resources they
are dependent on the functional heads
this makes it more challenging for the
project manager to coordinate in the
team
however functional organizations provide
an opportunity for specialization
for example if a purchase executive was
reporting into the purchase department
that executive would have exposure to
all the purchasing that happens within
the organization and has a well-defined
career path
in functional organizations project
management happens at the functional
head level
next let us look at the projectized
organization in the next screen
the projectized organization has all the
resources aligned around projects
the project managers have complete
control over the resources working on
their projects
the biggest advantage of the projectized
organization is that the resources have
loyalty to their projects and project
execution becomes easier this kind of
structure is suitable for organizations
whose work is in the nature of projects
there are few disadvantages in this
structure as well
firstly the role of the resources over
once the project is completed secondly
highly specialized roles within a
project may not be fully occupied all
the time
for example a purchase executive may
have work for selected periods on a
project while purchase activities are
going on
however for the rest of the period their
capability may not be optimally utilized
there is less scope for functional
specialization as the project boundaries
limit the kind of work for the resources
each project manager is in charge of a
project and its resources
next let us look at the matrix
organization
in a matrix organization the resources
report to the functional managers and
are managed by the project managers as
well
there might even be a function that
represents all the project managers in
the organization which provides project
management expertise
the matrix structure has three variants
commonly referred to as weak balanced
and strong
in a weak matrix the authority of the
project manager is the weakest and
strongest in a strong matrix structure
the titles given to project managers and
functional or weak matrix organizations
are project expediter or project
coordinator
they would be called project managers in
a balanced or strong matrix structure
and have slightly more authority over
the time of the team members
the advantage of the matrix structure is
that resources can be optimally utilized
while preserving the capacity of the
project managers to get projects
executed efficiently
resources can specialize in their
functions and have stability in their
careers also contribute to the projects
at the same time potentially
the disadvantage of matrix organization
is that the communication overhead
increases significantly
this is because every resource in the
organization belongs into a project and
into a function
leading to a dual reporting structure
in a matrix organization project
management happens at project resource
level
in the next screen let us summarize the
advantages and disadvantages of
different organizational structures
each organization structure has its own
set of advantages and disadvantages
the advantage of functional
organizations is that resources may find
clearly defined career paths and achieve
specialization and skill development in
their respective fields
it will be a flexible workforce since
only one manager will be responsible
avoiding confusion the disadvantage of
such organization type is that project
work is hampered department work is
always given higher priority than the
project work in addition there is no
career path in project management which
leads to lower interest in projects
in the case of the projectized
organization one of the clear advantages
is better communication within the
projects since project work is the only
work team members are doing it also
leads to loyalty towards the project
goals
the disadvantage of such organization
type is the inefficient use of resources
because every project team has their own
support function
therefore this might lead to the
duplication of effort
it also leads to the resources being
left with no work since their roles are
over once the project is completed
it also hampers skill development
because the project requirements dictate
what kind of work team members perform
at different stages on a project
now let us look at the matrix
organization
it also has the advantage of better
coordination and maximum utilization of
resources
however the disadvantage is the higher
potential for conflict among the
managers which might lead to
communication complexity and overhead
management
in the next screen let us focus on the
comparison on project life cycle and
product life cycle
project life cycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure of the
project
the product life cycle on the other hand
also encompasses the operational and
maintenance phases a typical product
life cycle starts with conception of the
product and goes until it's withdrawal
from the market
the withdrawal might be because it
becomes obsolete or there is no further
need for the product in the market
a product has a long life cycle
a product can require or spawn many
projects over its life
for example a project in product
consumption phase could be to determine
customer needs whereas a project during
product maturity phase could be used to
perform competitive analysis
typically a product life cycle is longer
than the project life cycle
a project also has its own life cycle
and this life cycle depends upon the
industry and the organization within
which the project is being executed
sometimes different organizations within
the same industry use different life
cycles
there can be questions in the exam based
on the comparison of project life cycle
and product life cycle so understanding
the differences will be useful in
answering such questions
in the next screen let us discuss more
on project life cycle
a life cycle is composed of phases each
phase represents a discrete unit of work
required to be done on the project
there are different ways of classifying
project life cycles
let us first discuss the sequential
versus overlapping life cycle
in sequential phases the subsequent
phase starts only after the previous
phase has been completed whereas in
overlapping phases two or more phases
may run in parallel for some time
this could help fast tracking and
compressing the amount of time required
the other way of classifying life cycles
is how they go about the process of
planning
in predictive life cycles there is a
large upfront planning phase where all
the details of scope cost time are
planned before beginning the subsequent
phases
these phases then are executed in either
sequential or overlapping modes
they are suitable for large projects
where all the requirements are likely to
be known in advance and where upfront
planning effort is required to get the
necessary approvals
another feature of predictive life
cycles is that each phase may
potentially be different in the nature
of activities and may require people
with different skill sets for example
traditional software development life
cycle has phases like requirements
feasibility planning design construction
testing and transition
we will continue project life cycles in
the next screen
incremental and iterative life cycles
have a short up front high level
definition and planning phase
the product is then developed through a
series of iterations
where iteration increments or adds to
the functionality by a little all the
activities are intentionally repeated in
iterations
adaptive or agile life cycles are
variants of incremental and iterative
life cycles where iteration is very
short typically two to four weeks
agile methodologies are becoming very
popular in the software development
industry and in other industries where
the requirements are highly changeable
and frequent feedback is beneficial
let us now check your understanding of
the topics covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
pmo provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization
project manager has to integrate various
project aspects like the people
stakeholders risks communication and
procurements with the project
constraints
time scope cost and quality
identifying internal and external
stakeholders determining their
requirements and communicating with them
regularly is an important role of a
project manager
functional projectized and matrix are
the three types of organization
structures based on the level of
authority given to the project manager
project lifecycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure while
product life cycle also encompasses the
operational and maintenance phases
in this lesson we will focus on project
communications management let us begin
with the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to define communication and project
communications management identify the
different communication methods
technology and channels explain the
elements of a basic communication model
describe the project communications
management processes
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes and project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped into five process
groups in this lesson we will look at
the seventh knowledge area that is
project communications management and
its processes in the next screen
let us understand communication
communication can be best defined as a
two-way process of exchanging
information between two entities as you
can see on the screen if project is an
entity the project needs to communicate
with other entities in the organization
like project managers senior management
of the organization and any other
stakeholder of the project similarly
these entities may also have to
communicate with the projects the
communication between project and the
stakeholders is always two-sided project
manager is responsible for ensuring
proper communication to and from the
project in fact a project manager spends
almost ninety percent of his or her time
on communication you can now understand
how important it is for a project
manager to plan this activity well in
the next screen let us discuss
communication methods
communication can be done in two ways it
can be done written or verbal both
written as well as verbal communication
can either be formal or informal formal
means communicating by following some
basic rules whereas informal means
taking a casual approach these two
combinations result in four different
communication methods they are formal
written
formal verbal informal written and
informal verbal formal written method is
used for project management plans
project charter and over long distance
communication formal verbal method is
used during presentations whereas
informal written method is applicable
while writing notes or emails informal
verbal on the other hand is applied
during conversations
you can expect questions in the pmp exam
which require choosing a communication
method for a given situation
so a fair understanding of the
communication methods can help you score
higher
in the next screen let us look at the
various communication technologies
communication technology refers to the
different media used for communicating a
few such technologies are listed on
screen
among which email fax and telephone are
a few popular communication technologies
in the next screen let us understand the
communication channel with the help of
an example
communication takes place between four
people in a team
the lines across the members represent
there can be six unique channels of
communication existing within the team
now if the team comprises ten members
how many unique channels of
communication will be calculated you can
use the formula
n multiplied with n minus 1 and the
resulting sum divided by 2. n is the
total number of people involved in
communication in this case n equals to
10 if this is put into the formula you
will get 45 as the result
therefore 45 unique communication
channels exist in a team of 10 people it
is difficult to manage such a large
number of communication channels
therefore it is important to structure
communication otherwise everyone starts
communicating everything to everyone and
it can become a real chaos in the
project in the pmp exam you may be asked
to calculate the number of communication
channels in a scenario based question so
please make a note of the formula to
answer the question correctly
in the next screen let us discuss the
basic communication model
project communications management
includes the processes required to
ensure that information about timely and
appropriate generation collection
distribution storage and ultimate
disposition of project is prepared and
circulated to all project stakeholders
it is the responsibility of a project
manager to ensure that the information
requested by the stakeholder is
communicated to them the frequency at
which the information needs to be shared
may also vary from stakeholder to
stakeholder for example think about a
simple process of sharing a project
status report with the customer and
senior management this knowledge area
explains how it should be done as per
pmi
in the next screen let us discuss the
project communications management
processes
there are three project communications
management processes
process is carried during different
process groups planned communication
management is done during planning
process group managed communications is
done during executing process group and
control communications is done during
monitoring and controlling process group
in the next few screens we will cover
each of these processes in detail
plan communications management is the
process of developing an appropriate
approach and plan for project
communications based on stakeholders
information needs and requirements
and available organizational assets
this belongs to the planning process
group
stakeholder register is an important
input to this process
it is a list of all the stakeholders the
project management plan has information
about a large number of the project's
requirements and the stakeholders who
need to receive communication of various
kinds are therefore a critical input to
this process
in addition to these two organization
process assets and enterprise
environmental factors are also inputs to
this process
many organizations have standard
templates to prepare communication
management plan which are part of the
organizational process assets and
enterprise environmental factors
the first technique used in this process
is the communication requirements
analysis where the communication
requirements of each of the stakeholders
are analyzed and categorized in this you
try to find how many of the stakeholders
need similar kind of information which
can be grouped together
if you send information through an email
system all those stakeholders who need
similar information can be marked in cc
in the email
next you can decide on the communication
technology these days email is the most
widely used technology but in few cases
you might have to send information using
some other technology like fax or
registered post for example all
government communications are done using
registered post to keep a written record
finally you need to understand how
communication really happens
that is the communication models and the
various communication methods used you
may need to conduct meetings before
agreeing on and finalizing the
communications management plan the
communications management plan is the
primary output of this process which
lays down the procedures around
communications in the organization
communication management plan has
information like which stakeholder needs
what kind of information at what
frequency and how as a result of this
process some other project documents may
also get updated
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the plan communications
management process so a fair
understanding of the process will help
you answer such questions correctly in
the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
manage communications is the process of
creating collecting distributing storing
retrieving and the ultimate disposition
of project information in accordance to
the communications management plan it
belongs to the executing process group
managed communications is done
throughout the project life cycle
everything cannot be planned during
communication planning so manage
communications takes care of responding
to unexpected requests for information
as well communications management plan
is an important input work performance
reports have information regarding
project performance and status
information organizational process
assets are the standard templates
created for the status report by
organizations in some organizations
there are guidelines for communication
distribution enterprise environmental
factors are the other inputs to this
process
various tools and techniques are used in
this process communications technology
represents the means of technology that
is email instant messaging telephone
conferencing etcetera that are used to
exchange information the use of
communication models helps you determine
the technique that is best suited for a
particular situation
communication methods are the various
methods used to communicate
for example whether it is interactive or
offline whether information is being
pushed by the provider or pulled by the
recipient etc information management
systems help design a framework for
managing the information within a
project that is how it is acquired where
it is stored and how it is distributed
and destroyed in performance reporting
all the information is synthesized in
the form of performance reports that are
later distributed to the appropriate
stakeholders and forms an important part
of the communications strategy on a
project the first and primary output of
this process is the communications
messages that are generated during the
project the other outputs include
project management plan updates project
document updates and organizational
process assets updates in the next
screen let us discuss control
communications process
control communications is the process of
monitoring and controlling
communications throughout the entire
project life cycle to ensure the
information needs of the project
stakeholders are met
it is part of the monitoring and
controlling process group the inputs to
this process are the project
communications project management plan
and issue log which has a list of issues
that are raised by different project
stakeholders data related to the work
being performed on the project and
various other project documents which
may have to be communicated other inputs
include work performance data and
organizational process assets
let us look at the tools and techniques
in detail the information management
systems provide tools to collect
consolidate and present the information
in the form of cogent concise
communications expertise must be sought
from different stakeholders on how you
should go about this process
several meetings may be needed to ensure
the efficiency and efficacy of the
communications the major outputs of this
process is the work performance
information which indicates that the
work performance data has been analyzed
interpreted and presented in an easily
comprehensible form this process may
also give rise to change requests
updates to the project management plan
project documents and organizational
process assets in the next screen let us
look into a business scenario to
understand this concept better after
reading the problem statement click the
solution button to look at a possible
answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson communication is
a two-way process of transferring
information from one entity to another
the four commonly used communication
methods are formal written formal verbal
informal written and informal verbal the
total number of unique channel of
communication can be calculated using
the formula n multiplied with n minus
one and the resulting sum divided by two
by analyzing the communication model
problems in project communication can be
identified
project manager is responsible for
timely availability of information to
all stakeholders
the three project communications
management processes are
planned communication management
management communications and control
communications
in this lesson we will focus on project
human resource management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the sixth
knowledge area that is project human
resource management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand
project human resource management
includes the processes that organize
manage and lead the project team
one of the key elements of human
resource management is that each of the
project team members should have clear
assignment of their roles and
responsibilities
in addition even the team working on
project management tasks should be a
part of the project team and they are
responsible for project management
functions like initiating planning
executing monitoring and controlling and
closing along with other leadership
activities in the next screen let us
understand the difference between
functional and project manager
an organization may have both functional
managers and project managers the
difference
functional manager is the one who
handles a business function or
department for instance the hr manager
is responsible for the hr department in
an organization therefore an hr manager
will be a functional manager
generally a functional manager is also a
subject matter expert
the roles and responsibilities of the
functional manager depend upon the core
business of the organization and overall
organization structure functional
managers normally own the resources and
provide the projects with necessary
resources they also negotiate with the
project manager regarding resources the
project manager on the other hand is
responsible and accountable for the
success or failure of a project and the
quality of the project
they are not technical experts the
project manager may not have authority
over the resources depending upon the
organizational structure they often have
to negotiate with the functional manager
for the resources and are responsible
for the product quality a project
manager will credit the team with the
success of the project
and accept the blame for the failure
now let us look at an example to
understand the roles played by
functional and project managers
the ceo of an organization initiates a
new project to secure an iso 9001
2008 certification for the company
now this project would require team
members from each of the company
departments
and whoever is the project manager of
this project will have to request the
functional manager to assign one of
their team members to the project
resources assigned to the project go
back to their respective departments
once the project is completed
let us now discuss the project human
resource management processes in the
next screen
there are four project human resource
management processes
the first process plan human resource
management is done as part of the
planning process group
the next three processes are part of the
executing process group these processes
are acquire project team develop project
team and manage project team let us now
look into each of these processes in
detail in the next screen let us begin
with plan human resource management
plan human resource management is the
process of identifying and documenting
project roles
responsibilities
required skills reporting relationships
and creating a staffing management plan
this process is part of the planning
process group in addition to that
finalizing the project hierarchy of who
reports to whom
and designing the staffing management
plan is also part of this process
the first input to this process is the
project management plan there could be a
lot of information in the project
management plan and subsidiary plans
that may be relevant to the creation of
the human resource management plan for
example the project life cycle processes
the timelines how the work will be
accomplished etcetera the other key
input for this process is the activity
resource requirement team members can be
identified based on these requirements
in addition to this enterprise
environmental factors like current
employment outlook etc are also
important for example if the economy is
booming and there are ample job
opportunities for the team members the
reward and recognition system can keep
the project team interested in the
project organizational process asset is
also an input to this process
an example of the organization process
assets can be template or a form to
request for a new resource let us now
look at the tools and techniques used to
develop human resource plan
the roles and responsibilities are
captured in the form of organization
charts and position descriptions
there are various ways to draw this
chart it can be either hierarchical
chart which shows the reporting function
or it can be text based
the other technique used for developing
the human resource plan is networking
this involves formal or informal
interactions within the organization and
outside by the project manager to
identify the best team for the project
depending upon various interpersonal
factors
organizational theory helps to
understand how individuals come together
and function as an organization
expert judgment and meetings are
required to put the human resource plan
together
the output of this process is human
resource management plan this plan
contains documents like staffing
management plan
project organization chart and roles and
responsibilities matrix
the staffing management plan is a
comprehensive document that describes
when and how team members would be added
to and released from the project
another component of the staffing
management plan is the recognition and
reward system
recognition and reward system helps
project managers motivate their team
the staffing management plan is relevant
to the projects of a functional or
matrix organization where project team
members are always caught in a dilemma
about prioritizing project work against
regular departmental work
in the next screen let us discuss
organization charts and role
descriptions
a project manager needs to make sure
that there is an organization chart
prepared specifically for the project it
should clearly identify the roles and
the reporting relationships between them
a sample organization chart is shown on
the slide
another way of clearly delineating
responsibilities among team members is
by using a responsibility assignment
matrix one form of responsibility
assignment matrix is the raci chart in
the raci chart r stands for responsible
a for accountable c for concerned or
consulted and i for informed for each
important activity or deliverable on the
project it needs to be clearly
identified who is responsible or
contributes to it who is ultimately
accountable who is merely concerned
about the success and who needs to be
informed or kept in the loop an example
of the raci chart is shown on the screen
in this case project manager john is
accountable for the project plan and the
other team members chris sally and ting
are responsible for completing the plan
similarly you can note the roles of each
resource in the other activities
in the next screen let us understand
resource histogram
resource histogram is a method of
depicting how many resources are
required for the life of a project if
you observe the chart shown on the
screen it indicates that the number of
staff hours required on the project
increases to a peak in 2014 and then
slowly tapers off especially for
long-running projects the level of
staffing needed may vary considerably
over a period this has implications for
other parts of the plan as well for
example the cost will vary as the number
of resources change this piece of
information helps a project manager to
understand at what time they need to
onboard and off board resources on a
project in the next screen
let us look into the second human
resource management process that is
acquire project team
acquire project team is the process of
confirming human resource availability
and obtaining the team necessary to
complete project activities
this process belongs to the executing
process group
acquiring resources may not be required
in the planning phase therefore it is
done in execution phase though you may
plan to acquire few in the planning
phase major acquisition is done in
execution phase
this may be true where large projects
are run spanning over many years with
several detailed activities
the key input is the human resource
management plan
enterprise environmental factors help
understand which team members will be
available to work on the project
how much they will cost etc
organizational process assets will help
understand the hiring procedure of the
company the policies that govern the use
of team members on the project etc the
key technique for acquiring the project
team is negotiation as a project manager
you have to negotiate with the company's
senior management resource manager or
with prospective candidates to secure
the most suitable resources on the
project sometimes the resources may be
pre-assigned to a project
this typically happens when they are the
key resources without which the project
cannot take off sometimes the project
team is acquired by getting required
resources through external vendors most
of the bigger organizations have
approved a list of vendors who provide
resources on a contractual basis
nowadays the concept of virtual team is
also quite popular to get a project team
so even though the project is being
conceived in one country a big part of
the team can be in another country for
example if the project is conceived in
the usa majority of the team can be in
germany and both the teams can
coordinate over the phone email chat etc
multi-criteria decision analysis is also
an important tool to achieve the
objectives while acquiring the human
resources for the project it is
important to consider a number of
factors such as availability cost skill
set experience attitude relocation needs
etc these criteria have to be considered
in totality and balanced out against the
project's requirements
the output of this process is project
staff assignments resource calendars and
updates on project management plan let
us now discuss the next process develop
project team
once the project team is acquired the
next step is developing the project team
develop project team is the process of
improving competencies
team member interaction and overall team
environment to enhance project
performance
this process belongs to the executing
process group
the inputs to this process include
project staff assignments resource
calendars and human resource management
plan
one of the techniques used in developing
project team is interpersonal skills
it is more of an art than a science and
this is where individual characteristics
of project managers matter a lot if the
project manager genuinely commands trust
and respects the team members developing
the team becomes easy team members look
up to the project manager not only for
getting project specific instructions
but also for their career advancement as
well social activities like celebrating
a team member's birthday going for
parties outside the office etc helps in
team building
training is also an important tool for
developing the project team as it helps
in increasing the knowledge of
competencies of the team members
sometimes co-locating the team members
at a single place also helps in
developing team bonding this is
especially important if team members
work from different geographical
locations knowing a person face to face
does help in reducing conflict project
managers can also encourage the team
members by providing recognition and
rewards personnel assessment tools give
the project manager insights into the
strengths and opportunities for
improvement in the team members these
tools also help in understanding members
aspirations so that the project manager
can better align the project goals with
the individual aspirations finally the
project manager should also set some
ground rules in the project to ensure
that team performs their work without
any problems some such rules can be
everyone should reach office for daily
meeting by 9 30 am sharp if there is
more than a 10 percent delay in
completing any activity assigned it
should immediately be escalated to
project manager if there are any
unforeseen circumstances it should be
immediately brought to the notice of the
project manager etc the output of this
process is team performance assessments
this is done by the project manager to
evaluate and enhance the effectiveness
of the team as a whole this is a
document which explains team
effectiveness as information about the
team evolves the enterprise
environmental factors may also be
updated questions that test a project
manager's role in developing a project
team can be expected in the pmp exam so
ensure that you have a fair
understanding of the role before you
take the exam
in the next screen let us discuss the
manage project team process
managing the project team is different
from developing the project team though
it is also done during the execution
process group it relates to measuring
team members performance providing
feedback resolving issues and managing
changes to optimize project performance
to measure team members performance the
manager should know the work assigned to
them as well as their performance on the
assigned work hence project staff
assignments and team performance
assessments are listed as input to this
process the human resource management
plan serves as a guideline for managing
project teams
some organizations have templates and
procedures to do such assessment and
that being the reason why organization
process asset is also one of the inputs
to this process the work performance
reports as well as issue logs will be
inputs because the team management
activities have to be performed in this
context observation and conversation is
a technique where the project manager
monitors and discusses the tasks done by
the team this does not imply formal
project status reports but having an
informal interaction with the team
before documenting the project status
report knowing about the issue early
helps in resolving them early
formal performance appraisals are
helpful in evaluating the team members
performance on the project the project
manager creates these with the help of
the team supervisors it is an
established practice in most
organizations to evaluate team members
for their work this may have a bearing
on their future assignments salary
promotions etc since the power of
appraising lies within the project
manager the project manager can use this
as an effective tool for managing the
team since multiple resources work on a
single project it is quite natural to
expect conflicts
it is the responsibility of project
manager to resolve conflicts
conflict management has been discussed
in detail later in the lesson you can
expect questions on conflict management
in the exam
the other tool is interpersonal skills
the output of managing a project team
includes corrective action
recommendations like which team members
to be changed implementing some reward
system to motivate the team etc
updating the project management plans
documents organization process asset and
enterprise environmental factors are the
other outputs of this process
there can be questions in the pmp exam
that test a project manager's skill in
managing a project team
so ensure that you are aware of the
inputs tools and techniques and outputs
of managing a project team
let us discuss team dynamics in the next
screen
any team naturally goes through several
stages as it gets together these stages
are forming storming norming performing
and adjourning in forming stage a team
formally comes together for the first
time
in storming stage disagreements start to
surface this is followed by norming when
the teams start working together and
trusting each other in performing stage
they are able to deliver results as a
team finally the team is adjourned when
the work of the project is completed or
the project is terminated
in the next screen let us discuss
conflict management
many organizations look for people with
diverse background to get different
perspectives about work
if people with diverse backgrounds and
culture work on a project it is quite
natural to expect conflict conflict
often results in opportunities for
improvement the root causes of conflict
can be scarce resources scheduling
priorities and personal work styles
while the popular belief is that
personality or ego can be the key reason
for conflict it is the least possible
reason for conflict
as a project manager if you find
yourself in between a conflict with a
team member sit across the table and
resolve it if not they should get their
immediate managers involved and try to
resolve it to avoid conflicts a project
manager should let everyone involved
have complete clarity about the project
assign the roles and responsibilities to
each of the team members clearly ensure
that there are no overlapping
responsibilities which could be a
possible cause for conflict sometimes
boredom at work can also lead to
conflict so one of the responsibilities
of project manager is to keep motivating
the team members and let them work on
interesting and challenging assignments
business scenarios based questions on
conflict management can be expected in
the pmp exam so it is essential to have
a fair understanding of the topic
in the next screen let us look at
conflict resolution techniques
there are five techniques of resolving
conflict they are withdraw or avoid
smooth or accommodate compromise or
reconcile force or direct collaborate or
problem solve in withdraw or avoid one
retreats from a potential conflict
situation or defers the resolution to a
later date this does not resolve the
conflict but allows for more time in
smooth or accommodate areas of agreement
are emphasized to reduce the intensity
of the conflict again this does not on
its own result in a resolution but it
may succeed in changing the perceptions
about the situation in compromise or
reconcile there is some give and take in
order to bring some satisfaction to all
parties depending on how the process
went this may be perceived as a win-win
or a lose-lose situation because none of
the parties really get what they want in
force or direct a person in a position
of authority directs how the matter
should be resolved it may be necessary
to do this when the matter has to be
resolved immediately however this may
result in upsetting one or more of the
conflicting parties
in collaborate or problem solving the
parties in the conflict are asked to
come together to collaborate and look
for resolution to the problem
this offers the greatest likelihood of a
satisfactory and permanent resolution
and should be resorted to whenever
possible
business scenario based problems where a
resolution technique has to be selected
can be expected in the pmp exam
so understanding the conflict resolution
techniques is essential
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to get work done by
the team there are certain powers that a
project manager can use to get the work
done
a project manager has to use a
combination of techniques to get this
accomplished various powers of a project
manager are legitimate or formal reward
penalty expert and referent in
legitimate or formal project manager can
formally assign a work to a team member
that he or she has to do project manager
can reward and recognize the team
members
the reward could be as simple as
assigning challenging or sought after
work to a team member this can motivate
good performers on the project sometimes
project manager can penalize the team
members for poor performance some
project managers are able to command
authority because of their expertise in
a certain field project manager can be
considered as a reference of higher
authority to get the work done
sometimes referent authority also arises
from the personal charm or charisma of
the project manager legitimate reward
and penalty are the powers derived from
the project manager's position in the
company expert power exists when the
project manager is an expert on the
subject matter reward and expert are
usually the best forms of authority to
use penalty is the worst way of
influencing and managing the team a
project manager should resort to this
only as a last option
regardless of the project manager having
formal reporting authority over the team
they are naturally looked upon as the
leaders for their projects project
managers need to be familiar with the
leadership styles and be able to tailor
their style according to the needs of
the project and that of the team there
are three leadership styles the first
one is authoritarian or autocratic in
this style the leader sets clear
expectations of the team and expects
complete compliance in a participative
or democratic style the leader offers
guidance but also involves the team in
decision making
in a delegative or laissez-faire style
the leader leaves the work to the team
without offering much guidance in most
circumstances you would want your leader
to employ a participative style but
there may be occasions when other styles
might be appropriate in the next screen
let us discuss mckinsey's 7s framework
a popular framework in management
science is the mckinsey's 7s framework
there are seven elements that are
divided into two categories
an organization working on a project
will have these elements already in
place and hence these become the hard
elements the first three elements of the
7s framework are the strategy structure
and systems the leader or project
manager is expected to step in and
exhibit soft elements to earn the mantle
of leadership
the next four elements are shared values
skills style and staff
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
eighth knowledge area that is project
risk management and its processes
risk is an uncertain event or condition
that can affect a project positively or
negatively although most of the time you
view this uncertainty as bad sometimes
it also has a likely positive outcome
let us look at an example of risk having
a positive outcome you are using a
software for managing time timesheet of
your team members due to budget
constraints you are forced to use a new
software though you were initially
reluctant to use it you found the new
software to do better than the current
one it is more efficient and has better
reporting facility an example of bad
uncertainty can be swine flu government
declares mandatory holiday to check flu
spread which may affect your project
work
risks can be managed only if they are
measured quantitatively suppose there
are many risks identified in a project
and you have limited resources to manage
them you should know which risk is most
important that has to be managed first
therefore measuring risk becomes very
critical risk is measured by assigning a
monetary value to it and that value is
arrived at by multiplying the
probability and impact of the risk
risk can be categorized in various ways
one such categorization is external
internal technical or project management
related risk
external risk arises out of external
policies or regulations for example
government policy that the river water
can be used for drinking purposes may
hinder your production which is
dependent on the river water internal
risk arises from within the project for
example the complexity of the work may
result in time and cost escalation
technical risks arise from the
technology being used projects and space
exploration have a lot of technical
complexity
risks could be related to project
management for example if there are many
interdependencies between the sub
projects it is a risk from the project
management standpoint
the categorization of risk can be based
on the origin
risks can be classified as scope risk
resource risk
schedule risk
cost risk
and quality risk
scope risk can include redoing the same
task if the scope is not well understood
when the only resource is assigned to
some other project it is called resource
risk
a decision tree helps in analyzing risk
and its impact on making decisions in a
scenario where there is uncertainty on
the outcome suppose you want to buy a
car you can buy either a new car or an
old car
which one should you buy
which has more risk over a period of
five years
consider the concept of decision tree to
solve this problem the initial cost of
buying a new car is twenty thousand
dollars and the cost of buying an old
car is fifteen thousand dollars for a
new car the probability of it having any
problem failed scenario
is only ten percent that is there is a
ninety percent likelihood that it will
just work without any problems past
scenario and if it does have any at all
the impact of the problem is fifteen
thousand dollars
the reason is that it was bought at a
higher cost
an old car has seventy percent
probability of having a problem the
reason being the probability is high
because the car was already used by
someone else in the past
however the impact here is low say ten
thousand dollars if you add probability
multiplied by impact of both the options
at the decision nodes you will find
buying an old car over a period more
risky than buying a new car
the project cost will be arrived at
after considering the risk reserves of
both the known risks and unknown risks
there is a specific order in which these
reserves are calculated in the project
cost first the cost of all activities is
identified
activities are the smallest unique
project tasks all the activity costs add
up to the cost of the work packages work
packages are the last level of
classification in a work breakdown
structure work packages cost adds up to
the control account cost one or more
work packages are clubbed together to
create a control account and manage the
cost of the work packages next the
project costs are identified there can
be multiple control accounts in a
project now once the project cost is
calculated some reserve is added to take
care of any uncertainties you may have
made some assumptions to calculate the
cost of the activities and by adding
some reserve you would want to take care
of those uncertainties in this case make
a note that you are accounting for the
assumptions made and it can be said that
this reserve takes care of known
uncertainties this reserve is also
called contingency reserve at this point
you have arrived at the cost baseline
that is the cost for the project that
will be used for budgeting and tracking
purposes once the planned cost is
arrived there is another reserve that
gets added called management reserve
note that management reserves are not
part of the cost baseline and are used
during emergencies only by adding
contingency reserve you have taken care
of known uncertainties and by adding
management reserve you take care of
unknown uncertainties that is those
risks that perhaps have not yet been
identified unknown uncertainties are
added based on experience or expert
judgment
project risk management includes the
processes of conducting risk management
planning
identification analysis
response planning and controlling risk
on a project
the key objective of risk management is
to increase the probability and or
impact of positive events and decrease
the probability and or impact of
negative events
there are six risk management processes
plan risk management identify risks
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis and
plan risk responses belong to the
project planning group and control risks
belong to the monitoring and controlling
process group in this lesson we will
focus on project stakeholder management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the tenth
knowledge area that is project
stakeholder management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand who
stakeholders are
a stakeholder is anybody who has a stake
in the project a stakeholder may be an
individual a group or an organization
who may affect or be affected by or
perceived to be affected by a decision
activity or outcome of a project further
the nature of the impact can be positive
or negative thus giving rise to the
notion of positive or negative
stakeholders irrespective of whether a
stakeholder is positive or negative it
is important to engage with the
stakeholders and get them involved in
the project this can make a critical
difference to the success or failure of
the project a single disgruntled
stakeholder can bring the entire project
to its knees whereas an actively engaged
and influential stakeholder can have the
opposite effect let us understand who
the common stakeholders of a project are
there are several categorizations of
stakeholders the project managers
themselves are important stakeholders
the project team members represent
stakeholders in the project the senior
management of the organization which is
working on the project has a stake in
the project the sponsor that is the
person or entity that provides the money
and resources for the project and
essentially champions the project is an
important stakeholder the customer which
may be different from the sponsor is a
stakeholder as well for instance and
many of the projects in the social
sector the sponsor may be the government
or a development agency whereas the
customers would be the people who
actually benefit from it the end users
which may be different from the
customers or the sponsors are
stakeholders too the vendors or
suppliers who provide goods or services
to the project are important
stakeholders people whose lives may be
impacted by the output of the project
are also stakeholders for example if a
highway project requires possession of
privately owned land people whose land
is being taken away are the stakeholders
if the construction of a dam or water
reservoir benefits the downstream
farming communities they are the
stakeholders here competitors who
provide alternative goods or services
are stakeholders too sometimes
environmentalists or other social groups
may become stakeholders the government
or political leadership may become
stakeholders for projects in the public
domain it is sufficient to state that
there could potentially be hundreds of
stakeholders for a large project it is
in the interest of the project manager
and the project team to clearly identify
all such stakeholders up front and then
actively manage them throughout the
project in the next screen let us
discuss the classification models for
stakeholder analysis
not all the stakeholders have the same
amount of influence or power over the
project
therefore the way to manage each
stakeholder needs to be calibrated based
on a proper classification of the
stakeholders
this is the role of the classification
model you can come up with a grid that
maps the power of the stakeholders the
interest they have the influence they
may have or the impact that they can
have on the project through the power
interest power influence or influence
impact grids it can be represented by
mapping stakeholders to a power or
interest grid the diagram on the screen
has x-axis which represents interest
level and y-axis which represents the
power level based on the various
combinations of power levels and
interest levels the grid can be divided
into four quadrants the stakeholders on
the top right quadrant with high power
and high interest need to be managed
closely that is you have to monitor
their involvement and engagement very
closely the stakeholders on the bottom
right quadrant with high interest but
low power need to be kept in the loop
that is you should share information
with them and keep them regularly
informed the stakeholders on the top
left quadrant with high power but low
interest can be managed by keeping them
happy for example by making sure that
their interests and opinions are taken
into consideration the stakeholders on
the left bottom quadrant with low power
and low interest may be managed less
actively by simply monitoring how things
are going with them the salience model
describes classes of stakeholders based
on their power ability to impose their
will
urgency
need for immediate attention and
legitimacy appropriateness of their
involvement level
this is a useful framework to guide the
stakeholder management strategy on a
project practice creating power grids
for business scenarios this will help in
understanding the level of engagement a
project manager needs to maintain with
various stakeholders
in the next screen
let us discuss the stakeholder
engagement assessment matrix
the stakeholder engagement assessment
matrix allows visualizing the current
and desired states of a stakeholder's
involvement in the project the five
levels of involvement are as unaware
resistant neutral supportive and leading
unaware is where the stakeholder is not
aware of the project or its impact
resistant is where the stakeholder is
aware of the impacts and is resistant to
change
neutral is where the stakeholder is
aware of the project and is neither
supportive nor in opposition to the
project supportive is where the
stakeholder is aware of the project and
its impact and is supportive of the
change leading is where the stakeholder
is aware of the project and impacts and
is actively engaged to ensure that the
project is successful
let us now look at the matrix the table
has one row per stakeholder identified
you place c in the column which best
indicates the current level of
engagement for that stakeholder
then you place d in the column which
best indicates the desired state of
engagement this table can be a quick
visualization tool that helps understand
where work has to be done in the
stakeholder management activities in the
next screen let us discuss the skills
required for stakeholder management
stakeholder management is both an art
and a science since it involves dealing
with people and people are inherently
non-linear and unpredictable there is no
one size that fits all strategies or
tools that will work while managing them
however a project manager may use a few
traits and techniques while managing
stakeholders which are classified as
interpersonal skills and managerial
skills a project manager must possess
good interpersonal skills that is must
invest the time and energy to build
trust this involves multiple things such
as establishing a personal rapport
following through on commitments being
punctual etc once the trust is
established it helps in smoothing many
difficult bends
conflict management is an important
skill for a project manager while
communicating with stakeholders the
project manager must practice active
listening they must not assume that they
have all the answers
instead they should spend some time to
understand the issues and the
stakeholders points of view
this alone can go a long way in
smoothing ruffled feathers and building
constructive relationships resistance to
change is natural a project manager must
know how to convert that into a positive
energy in its favor managerial skills
that may help in accomplishing the
project objectives a project manager
must be able to build consensus among
the group
while absolute uniformity may not always
be possible or desirable the project
manager must use techniques to ensure
widespread discussions and arrive at a
path that the group can buy into
the project manager must be able to
influence people
often without necessarily being in the
position of authority
the project manager must be skillful to
negotiate agreements
the project manager must be able to
understand and modify organizational
behavior in order to move the project in
a certain direction
network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model pdm or
activity on node aon
boxes represent activities and the
arrows indicate the dependency
this type of network can have all four
types of relationships between the
activities
in arrow diagramming model adm or
activity on arrow aoa
the arrows represent activities the
relationships and sequences can be
inferred from the direction of the
arrows and linkages between the
activities
in such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the network diagram
so create and work with the diagram
this will make answering network diagram
based questions easy and fun in the next
screen let us look at a network diagram
a sample network diagram is shown on the
screen
activities a and c can happen in
parallel
b and d require both a and c to complete
whereas e requires both b and d to
complete activity on aero network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
reporting purposes
in this lesson we will focus on project
scope management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into ten knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
second knowledge area that is project
scope management and its processes
let us begin with the first topic of
this lesson that is project scope
management
project scope management includes the
processes required to ensure that a
project comprises all and only the work
required to complete the project
successfully
the project scope management is
concerned about the scope
what is not there in the scope is also
clearly identified
in the next screen let us look at the
key activities performed under project
scope management
let us look at a few of the typical
activities that happen as part of the
project scope management
constant monitoring is essential to make
sure that all the project work is being
completed the gradual uncontrolled
increase in scope of the project is
referred as scope creep
it is necessary to define the project
scope boundaries and not let people
randomly add to the project scope
gold plating is doing more than what is
required as part of the project scope
this has to be avoided in projects
as per the published statistics about
projects done globally less than forty
percent of projects can be considered
successful
therefore the focus should be on what is
required rather than squandering around
with what is not required
forty percent might be considered less
but a project is classified as
successful only if it meets all its
objectives and is done within time and
cost budgets
in the next screen let us understand the
differences between product scope and
project scope
project scope management deals with
managing both the product scope as well
as the project scope
product scope refers to the features and
functions that characterize a product
service or result
the word product may also include
creation of a service for example in the
banking industry each of their services
is called a product
likewise a savings account is one of
their products
mutual fund is another on the other hand
project scope is the work that needs to
be accomplished to deliver the output of
the project which could be a product
service or result with the specific
features and functions
for instance to deliver a product you
may also need to produce a requirements
document or a design document
these are not part of the product scope
but it may very well be part of the
project scope in the next screen let us
discuss a few key terms used in the
project scope management
wbs stands for work breakdown structure
it means breaking the project
deliverables into smaller and more
manageable components called work
packages
the last level of work in such
subdivision is called work packages and
the whole structure is called wbs
for example a typical software
development project would have various
activities like finalizing requirements
designing the new system coding testing
and going live with the new system
each of these translates into level
deliverables which can be further
subdivided into smaller activities which
are more predictable
wbs dictionary like any dictionary
contains the explanation of the terms
used in wbs
a typical wbs dictionary has details
like the control account name of the
work package description of the work
package resource assigned if there are
any assumptions or dependencies to
complete the work package the due date
to finish the work package technical
dependencies and so on
wbs dictionary is useful for the person
or group working on the work packages as
it further elaborates the decomposed
work package
control account is a level within wbs at
which management wishes to exercise
control
for example perform earned value
analysis track performance etc in this
lesson we will focus on project
integration management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the first
knowledge area that is project
integration management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project integration
management
project integration management involves
unification consolidation articulation
and integrative actions that are crucial
for successfully completing the project
the project integration management is
high-level work that project manager
does and it involves managing
interdependencies among the other
knowledge areas the other nine knowledge
areas involve detailed work in a
specific direction for example project
cost management deals only with how to
manage cost in a project
the project management processes do not
happen independently for example a new
resource added to the project may
require changes in cost or schedule or
both
in dealing with such situations the
project manager integrates the processes
of project management the need for
integration drives much of the
communication and the work of the
project manager
let us discuss the key role of project
manager sponsor and team in the next
screen
project manager team members and project
sponsors have different roles to play in
a project
the project manager is supposed to play
multiple roles in the project the key
role is to perform integration
the project manager puts all the pieces
of the project together into a cohesive
whole
in doing so the project manager tries to
ensure that the project is done faster
cheaper and utilizes resources optimally
while meeting the project objectives
as the project progresses the team
members work on completing the project
activities
the role of the project sponsor is to
protect project from any unnecessary
changes and to ensure that it has the
required resources for completion
the project sponsor is the champion for
the project within the performing
organization
that is the organization in which the
work is being performed
in the next screen we will cover the
project selection methods
an organization can undertake a project
under contract with an external
organization or take up a project driven
by internal business needs
there should be a formal process of
selecting project in all organizations
to ensure that it is making the best
possible use of limited corporate
resources
for example if the organization has an
option to take up any one out of the two
projects
both of which use the same corporate
resources the organization would
naturally select the one which is more
profitable
there are two broad ways to select a
project
one way is the benefit measurement
method where one project is compared
with other competing projects
another approach is based on
mathematical models wherein you examine
the most optimal selection of projects
by trying to optimize a goal for example
maximize operating profits
such methods may be called constrained
optimization methods
there are different methods under both
these categories and you should be
familiar with the names of these methods
broadly the benefit measurement methods
focus on ascertaining the costs and
benefits of undertaking the project
the methods under benefit measurement
method include murderboard where a panel
of experts shoots down a new project
idea peer review scoring models economic
models and benefit compared to cost
the constrained optimization methods
rely on mathematical modeling techniques
to determine the best selection of
projects to achieve certain business
objectives
the methods of constrained optimization
method include linear programming
in reality you might not have seen these
methods to be followed in project
selection
often personal relationship with the
sponsor may be more important than
anything else
this is quite normal and any
organization worldwide works this way
however as a certified project manager
it is important for you to be familiar
with more scientific methods of project
selection
a typical question on the pmp exam could
be
what type of project selection technique
is peer review
and the right answer is benefit
measurement method
you need to understand the
characteristics of various project
selection methods to answer
scenario-based questions
in the next screen we will focus on the
project selection methods
there are five project management
processes which are part of project
integration management knowledge area
they are the develop project charter
done in the initiation process group
develop project management plan
undertaken in the planning process group
direct and manage work carried out in
the executing process group
monitor and control project and perform
integrated change control undertaken in
the monitoring and controlling process
group and close project or phase done in
the closing process group
develop project charter is an initiating
process
a project charter is essentially a
document that authorizes a project
once a project has received a charter it
means that the project manager can start
employing the organization's resources
for the project activities
let us look at the key inputs to be
considered in preparing the project
charter
the first input is the project statement
of work
this is created by project sponsor or
the customer describing their needs
project scope and how the project fits
into their strategic goal
if the project is taken up under a
contract the request for proposal
that is rfp can be considered as project
statement of work
the next input is the business case
this document establishes whether the
investment in a project is worth from a
business point of view the business need
for the project and the cost benefit
analysis
it provides important information to the
project manager about the goals of the
project and the boundaries in terms of
the desired results cost etc
if the project is being undertaken as
part of a contract or agreement the
agreement provides an important input
for the project manager that establishes
what must be done in the project
the next input to be considered for
project charter is enterprise
environmental factors
any project to be executed within the
organization has to deal with the
organization culture and existing
systems
you can consider this as an organization
baggage that comes with the project
this is the reason a project being
executed in two different organizations
may be done differently
another factor to be considered is
organizational process assets
this is a broad term and includes all
the organizational processes procedures
and policies corporate knowledge base
and historical project information
every organization develops a set of
processes procedures and policies that
are based on the best practices learned
by the organization over time
the historical information includes past
project management plans risks lessons
learned etc of similar projects executed
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
the first technique is expert judgment
expert judgment is an invaluable input
to the process of formally authorizing a
project because an expert can provide
insights into why a project makes
business sense or why it does not
from experience they may be able to shed
light about the validity of the business
drivers feasibility assumptions and
constraints that need to be considered
for the project
facilitation techniques is another
technique used
the chartering process is often a
collaborative activity involving many
influential stakeholders in an
organization
facilitation techniques help bring all
these stakeholders together and engage
in fruitful discussions in order to
arrive at an informed decision whether
to go ahead with a project or not
the only output of this project is the
project charter
let us try to understand what the
project charter might contain
the project charter usually contains the
high level project requirement and it
should be created by the project sponsor
and handed over to the project manager
the project manager can do the ground
work to prepare the project charter but
it must be signed by the project sponsor
or somebody in the performing
organization who is higher in authority
than the project manager
it is important to point out that a
project charter is not a project
management plan
the detailed risk schedule cost analysis
etc is part of the project management
plan and should be done during the
project planning phase when there is
more detail on the availability of the
project to do so
the charter should be sufficiently high
level to accommodate the minor changes
that might arise in the project
in this lesson we will focus on project
management processes
project lifecycle addresses the question
what to do to get the work done
it varies industry wise for example let
us look at a typical project life cycle
in a software industry
first you understand what is required
and analyze it as part of the
requirement analysis phase
then as part of the design phase you
figure out the implementation of it and
arrive with the approach
next you implement the functionality by
writing the code as part of the coding
phase
the code is then verified to ensure it
works right as part of the testing phase
the tested and verified software is then
installed at the customer locations as
part of the installation phase
after the installation the system then
moves into operations and support phase
the project management process addresses
the question
what to do to manage the project
the processes for managing the projects
are likely to be the same across
industries
for instance in the develop schedule
process one needs to develop the project
schedule irrespective of the industry or
domain you are working
in the next screen let us understand the
project management process groups
the project management processes are
divided into five process groups
they are initiating process group
planning process group executing process
group monitoring and controlling process
group
and closing process group
the initiating process happens at the
beginning of the project or phase
the planning executing ads monitoring
and controlling processes go together
therefore you plan execute and re-plan
based on the execution result
the project closing processes are
performed when the project work or a
phase within the project is completed
the typical project management process
and the closing phase releases resources
back to the resource pool so the team
members can be assigned to another
project
note the iteration of processes within
the phases is dependent on the scale of
the projects
small projects may have only one
iteration whereas bigger projects may
have multiple iterations before they
enter a new phase
project management processes are
overlapping activities let us look at
the interaction between these activities
in the next screen
process groups have overlapping
activities that occur throughout the
project life cycle
the output of one process group is
generally the input to another or a
deliverable of the project
for example project management plan is
an output of planning process group and
an input to execution process group
note that production of the plan is not
a one-time activity
as the project progresses the project
management plan may get updated as a
result of the monitoring and controlling
processes
the updated project management plan once
again forms an input to the execution
process group
in the next screen we will discuss the
project management process group
knowledge area and project management
process mapping
given on the screen is the list of the
47 project management processes 10
knowledge areas and 5 process groups
the table shows how each of them is
interrelated
you can see that the project integration
management processes can be mapped back
to all five process groups while project
scope management processes are mapped
back to only planning and monitoring
process group study the table to
identify processes under project
management and the knowledge area they
belong to
all the 47 processes are described in
detail in this tutorial
each knowledge area is covered in detail
as a lesson
it also covers how the processes map to
process groups to help you understand
the big picture
further the inputs and outputs of each
of these processes tools and techniques
that are used in these processes and
what exactly happens during these
processes are also discussed
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan
it is a method of measuring the project
performance objectively and comparing it
against the project baseline
results from an earned value analysis
indicate deviation of the project from
cost and schedule baselines
baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes therefore
schedule baseline is the first approved
project schedule along with approved
changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique
planned value is the authorized budget
assigned to the scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed
budget at completion is the budgeted
amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
estimate to complete is the expected
cost to finish all the remaining project
work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit at the end of
the project
all the parameters displayed on the
screen are measured in terms of cost you
may come across business scenario based
questions on earned value management in
the pmp exam so ensure that you develop
a clear understanding of this topic
let us look at an example of a planned
value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned this value is measured
in terms of currency say dollar
if the plan value is three hundred forty
dollars then the work plan is worth
three hundred forty dollars
how do you calculate earned value
the solution is add the budget allocated
to each of the activities that have been
completed at the point of time the
resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget
positive means the project is under
budget
similarly in schedule variance negative
means the project is behind schedule
whereas positive means the project is
ahead of schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index cpi and schedule
performance index spi values vary
between 0 and 1.
for example a cpi of 0.8 implies that 80
cents of work is obtained for every
dollar spent in the project
similarly if spi is 0.9
it implies that project is progressing
at only 90 percent of the speed
originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or eac
there are different ways of calculating
the eac value
the method used depends on how the cost
and schedule variances are expected to
play for the rest of the project
bac by cpi is used if you expect that
the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
ac plus bac minus ev is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate
ac plus
bac minus ev by the product of cpi and
sbi
is used if you want to factor in the
impact of the cost as well as schedule
variances
ac plus etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or etc
which is the cost of project from this
point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate at
completion
in addition variance at completion can
be calculated by subtracting the
estimate at completion from the budget
at completion variance at completion is
the cost estimation whether it is over
or under budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi
this is the cost performance needed to
achieve a desired outcome
for example
if the project needs to be managed to
the original budget bac then tcpi that
is the cpi that must be maintained for
the rest of the project
is calculated as
bac minus ev by bac minus ac
similarly if it has to be managed within
a revised target say eac
then tcpi is calculated as
bac minus ev by eac minus ac
before the start of the pmp exam please
make a note of the formulas of earned
value technique
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars
the phases are planned to be completed
one after the other the status of the
project at the end of the month three is
summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars
development and unit testing is only
fifty percent done though it was
supposed to be completed by third month
it has cost nine thousand dollars until
date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
note s indicates start time
f indicates finish time and pf indicates
that it is partly finished at the end of
the month
based on the above information calculate
the cv sv cpi and spi of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson let us also
look at a few definitions that might be
useful for your pmp examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily have the time
working capital the amount of money the
company has to invest on the project and
the day-to-day company operations
funding limit reconciliation the process
of comparing the planned expenditure in
a given period with the available
funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time
this is called depreciation
there are two forms of depreciation
straight line and accelerated
same amount of depreciation is taken
every year for instance a car with a
price tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful life of ten years is depreciated
one thousand dollars per year
at the end of the tenth year the value
of the car is considered zero for all
accounting purposes accelerated
depreciation depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project float can be
considered as a buffer time available to
complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack
there are three kinds of float the first
being the total float which is the
amount of time an activity can be
delayed without delaying the project end
date or an intermediary milestone
the second type of float is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successors activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero
because there is no scope to delay
activities on the critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration
delaying activities on the critical path
is as good as delaying the project
duration
concept-based questions on critical path
can be expected in the exam so it is
essential to have a clear understanding
of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram
start one two four five and is one path
and start
one three five and is the second path
since the duration of the path start one
two four five end is eighteen days
which is more than the duration of the
path start one three five and
the critical path of the project is
start one two four five end
let us take activity three as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
activity 3 can start only after activity
1.
since the early finish of activity 1 is
3 it becomes the early start of activity
three
activity three cannot start earlier than
three because activity one can be
completed only by then
therefore early start of activity three
is three
since the duration of the activity is
four days
the early finish of activity three is
three plus four equals seven days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity three
late start of activity five is 14 days
the activity 3 happens just before
activity 5.
so the late finish of activity 3 is 14
days
to calculate the late start you can
subtract the duration from late finish
therefore the late start of activity 3
is 14 minus 4 equals 10.
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression
hi welcome to project management tools
tutorial from simply learn i am cmr
chandra mr a certified project
management professional as part of this
tutorial we are going to look at about
project management tools essential
features of project management tools top
10 project management tools currently
used in the industry so what is project
management tools why should we use
project management tools while doing
project management so project management
tools help to keep a streamlining flow
in project management processes the
tools help the team or an individual to
carry out the steps of project
management in an effective and efficient
manner so project management tools
features and functionalities so
basically a project management tool
should have minimum fulfilling these
features and functionality they should
be simple to use customizable they
should have api for integration it
should help in collaboration it should
help in risk analysis and real-time
reporting when we say simple to use the
project management tools need to be
suitable for every project we do one
needs to find a tool that will have a
pleasant interface and increase work
productivity the project management tool
must be easy to configure according to
the organization needs every project
management approach every project
management templates every artifacts
needs tailoring and adaption before
adopting as part of the practice there
are business patterns that change every
day so having customizable tool is an
added advantage api or application
programming interface enables the
sharing of data and application between
devices the tools with api integration
allows seamless connectivity amongst the
team the project management tools must
allow for collaboration so that whole
team can work together collaboration not
only makes the task easier but also
increases the productivity of the
project risk analysis helps to identify
analyze and respond to the risk quickly
and efficiently it needs to capture all
the details of the risks their impacts
the probability of occurrence of the
risk and risk responses and tracking
them throughout the project life cycle
the real-time reporting enables the
access of data at different locations of
the project management one can assess or
access data at any time about the
project's current status this will help
in having a real-time update about the
project status to the stakeholders of
the project the top 10 project
management tools what we have today in
the market are
monday.com ric jira software trello
asana teamwork meister task basecamp
oracle's primavera and microsoft project
management tool so let us look at these
one by one so monday.com was released
during the year 2012 and it is known for
providing features to enable flexible
planning and monitoring capabilities the
website where you can find monday.com
access the tool is
www.monday.com so this tool is used by
more than 90 000 team across the globe
monday.com features and functionality
includes it is easy for collaboration
highly customizable excellent for
analytics integration with dropbox
google drive and pipedrive is possible
surprising the basic version is dollar
25 on monthly basis so which will
provide you 5gb storage one board per
dashboard and it is built annually the
standard package includes 5gb storage
three boards per dashboard and it is 39
per month which is built annually
professional includes unlimited storage
10 boats per dashboard and it costs
dollar 59 per month and it is billed
annually monday.com is used by the
following customers organizations of
monday.com that is carlsberg discovery
channel adidas tom phillips etc rick is
another project management tool which
was released in 2006 so this application
provides its user with robust features
and allows them to collaborate with each
other the website to access the tool is
www.rec.com and this is used by over 18
000 organizations across the globe the
features of rick includes it has
collaborative editing flexible workflow
real-time reporting and efficient work
management the pricing includes 0 to 5
users it has basic integrations and
which is free whereas professional
includes dollar 9.8 per user per month
which is which has a slabs of 5 10 and
15 users and rick proof free trial
business
version has five to two hundred users
and rick proof free trial whereas twenty
four point eight zero dollars per user
per month the companies which uses the
rig tools are airbnb laurel teamviewer
tiffany and co etc now let us look at
jira software jira software was released
during year 2002 it is a software
development tool used by agile teams
famous for its bug tracking system the
website to access this tool is
www.atlacian.com
software jira used by over 65 000
customers the features of jira software
includes agile reporting rich toolkit
for developers bug tracking mobile
applications so the pricing of jira
software is as follows so for forever
2gb storage and community support which
cost dollar zero but a standard is
around dollar seven per user per month
which includes 250 gb storage and nine
to five standard support premium is
dollar 14 per user per month unlimited
storage and has 24 7 premium support
jira software is used by the
organizations that is hitachi visa
dropbox nestle dominos coca-cola samsung
etc now let us look at the tool trello
so this application was released in 2011
it is known for providing flexibility in
organizing and prioritizing the tasks
with the help of its boards lists and
cards website to access the tool is
www.trello.com
used by over 50 million people the
features of trello includes smooth
editing easy file uploads from dropbox
or google drive high security standards
and easy data searching techniques so
the pricing includes it is free for
10 mv per attachment and 10 team boards
business class includes 250 mb
attachment unlimited team boards and it
cost dollar 9.99 per user per month
annually enterprise version provides 250
mb for attachment unlimited team votes
and costs around 20.83 dollars per
hundred users per month the companies
who use trello are google adobe paypal
unicef the new york times etc now let us
look at asana the asana tool was
released during 2008 it is an high
quality task management software that
makes the tracking of tasks easy across
the project management the website to
access this tool is
www.asana.com used by over 140 000
companies the features includes
incredible task management gantt charts
privacy controls easy progress tracking
the pricing includes the basic model
asana is provides 0 to 15 people
beginners in the project management so
premium includes custom fields priority
support where the pricing is dollar
10.99 per user per month annually the
business version includes advanced
integration priority support and it
costs 24.99 per hundred users per month
the companies which uses asana are
deloitte vodafone red bull uber sales
force nasa etc let us look at teamwork
tool teamwork was released during year
2007. it is a cloud-based project
management solution that helps in
managing group activities and
establishing flexible communication the
website to access this tool is
www.teamwork.com
used by over 370 000 organizations the
features of teamwork includes high
quality crm helpdesk software risk
register and easy time tracking the
pricing includes 0 to 5 users and 100 mb
file space is provided free of cost
whereas pro version includes 5 to 50
users 100 gb file spaces which cost nine
dollars per user per month premium
origin costs around dollar fifteen per
user per month which includes five to
hundred users and 250 gb file space the
organizations who use teamworks are
forbes ebay microsoft studios hp paypal
disney's honda
now let us look at the tool meister task
so this tool was released during year
2015 and it is known for providing
automated and streamlined workflows to
make the overall processes more
productive the website to access this is
www.mastertask.com
used by over 2 million users the
features of this tool includes it is
simple to use seamless workflow gantt
charts flexible project boards the
pricing it is zero dollars per month up
to three projects and unlimited project
members the pro version includes
unlimited projects unlimited
integrations which costs around 8.25
dollars per user per month whereas
business costs 20.75 dollars per user
per month which has security
restrictions priority email and phone
support the organization who use the
tool are virgin optics consulting and
data supports expert dot d etc base camp
the base camp tool was released during
the year 1999 it is a real-time
communication tool that allow users to
keep track of priorities and actionable
tasks the website to access this tool is
www.basecam.com
used by over 3 million users the
features of basecamp includes easy to
use various third-party integrations
daily backups and comprehensive project
calendar the personal version is free
and 0-20 users and 1gb store space is
provided in business version it is 99
per month for unlimited users i find gb
storage space the companies who use
basecamp is thought part harvest wlb
groupon etc oracle primavera so this
tool was released during the year 1983
which is acquired by oracle corporation
in the year 2008. primovera helps
project manager to handle a vast number
of tasks with the help of its unlimited
resources and target plans website to
access this tool is
www.primavera.com which is used by over
7143 companies so features of primavera
includes creation of wbs the work
breakdown structure issues and risk
recording supports large number of
activities and easy collaboration with
project users the enterprise project
portfolio management version costs
around 2750 dollars per user which
improves planning and execution
professional project management version
is usd 2500 per user handles large-scale
highly sophisticated projects so oracle
primavera contract management version
module costs around usd 2000 per user
keeps construction projects on schedule
under budget so the companies which use
primavera are burns mcdonald's pond or
caddies etc microsoft project so
microsoft project management tool was
used during the year 1984. so this tool
allows users to develop a schedule
assign resources track progress and
manage budgets all through the project
the website to access this tool is
www.office.microsoft.com
project the features of microsoft
project includes simple to use effective
monitoring easy communication enhanced
decision making so this is a cloud-based
solution and the pricing is project plan
one costs around dollar ten per user per
month on an annual commitment managing
projects web web browser is the feature
project plan three which costs around
dollar 30 per user per month with annual
commitment which is fully updated
project desktop application project plan
5 which costs around 55 dollars per user
per month with annual commitment
evaluating project ideas from anywhere
in the organization is possible through
this project standard 2019 version costs
around 620 dollars per pc per user for
those who don't need collaboration tools
and advanced features project
professional version 2019 costs around
1030 dollars per pc per user syncing
with project online and project server
the organization which uses microsoft
projects are comptel airbus intel volvo
xerox etc hey guys welcome to this
trello tutorial by simply learn so
without further ado let's get started
with what exactly is trello
so trello is a simple and easy to use
collaboration tool that can enable you
to organize projects and everything
related to it into boards
with trello you can find all kinds of
information like what's being worked on
who's working on what and what progress
the project is making now we'll learn
about that in a little bit while we're
talking about the trello demo
now let's talk about the advantages of
trello
now first off trello can be used
immediately after signing up
so trello offers you a free sign up
after which you get access to almost all
of trello's features now it does have a
premium service but most of trello's
important features are available in the
free account
secondly it follows the kanban system so
the kanban system is a popular
methodology that can be used to achieve
lean
so with trello you can also achieve lean
now trello also has a very popular
mobile application which also has the
same features as the interface that you
see on the desktop it's very user
friendly
now the fourth advantage is that all
project related items can be seen on one
page which means everything you need
about the project is available in one
place
next adding new members creating issues
and assigning them are very easy with
the help of trello
now that we had a look at all the
advantages that are provided by trello
let's have a look at a live demo
so first off let's go to trello.com
so here you can see two options to log
in or sign up so first of all if you've
never used the website before go to sign
up
so here you can enter your email or you
can go through google or hotmail or
outlook so it's very simple i already
have an account so i'll just log in
right so i'm just going to login
so if you're using shallow for the first
time this is what it would look like
so here you have personal boards
templates home and so on so let's go one
by one
firstly the most important thing that
you need to know about is boards which
is right here
so let's assume you're using this for a
deal which means that you need people to
share the board along with
so first of all let's create a team
so here i'm just going to name a company
called company go
say we do engineering id
just write a
brief team description
and continue so here say i have four
members
so have bob
i'm adding them here so
depending on what your team is like you
can add those team members so this is
important so that you can connect with
them while you're on the board so this
is company.com so we'll just add them
so the team members that you're going to
invite will get an invite email very
soon as soon as you're done by clicking
the invite to team button
we'll also add bill who also works at my
company
and there's technician one
and there's technician one who works at
company.com
add anybody who's required later so
invite to team
and there you go there's some details
here about the team and all that let's
go back to home
and now let's create a new board under
company co so the difference here is
that
for personal boards is that
like the name says it's personal you can
also add the team if you want later on
but
here you have the option for creating a
team port so i'll show you how you can
create a team board from personal board
so you got create board
here you can
show as this is by default selected with
no team because it's under personal
change it to company
and you can write
business
but anything else like that
and then you create a board
and there you go the board has been set
up
so now
first things first it's that you can
make this team visible which is
either only board members can see it or
since it's a small team the entire team
can seek it
so it's up to you how you want it
there's the public option which everyone
can see which i don't think is necessary
but if you feel like it you can do that
too
first of all you can even
write description of the board which is
what you want to achieve with this board
for example this is business or sales or
something like that
you can change the background into
something more colorful or less colorful
like this
and then
there's search cards which we haven't
added anything so far so there's nothing
to search
there's stickers
which again is i feel unnecessary at the
moment you can also see something called
butler so
based on your usage or how you're using
trello butler can provide you
suggestions like what you can add here
like you can see here
the tips haven't been added so far
because we haven't used cello so far
so based on your usage it will give you
suggestions
now let's go back
so here you see power ups so power offs
are basically additional features that
you can add to your board
so there are features that are connected
to a number of different fields this
analytics automation utilities tools and
so on
so as a free user you get access to
one power up but still we don't have to
use it so far because
we don't have anything on our board but
based on your requirement you can go
through these power-ups and decide on
one of them
so now let's get back to business
or our board so first you can see add a
list
so this basically refers to the
different processes that you want to
follow in this board
so first of all we'll add a list title
i'm going to add
to do
that's the first list
then this in progress
on hold
and completed
so here we have four lists which
represent
the processes in this business
so if you want you can even add another
list depending on your requirement
so in these lists there are things
called cards
so which are like sub topics so first of
all let's add
a very simple
title for example
deliver product
company
a second very simple deliver product
to company
b
like this so on and so forth if you want
it
so here this is a card so this card can
be moved from each stage to another as
it progresses
so this is in the to-do stage since
we've not started with anything so once
you click on a card so this pop-up shows
up
so here you can add a description like
converse with company a
ready to go
just some details that you want to add
you save
now one thing you can see add to cart so
there are a number of different things
you can add to this card
so members
now i have four team members i can add
bob
here i want bob in on this i want bob to
see the activities as it happens
i want bill to also see as things
proceed
right so the bob and bill are in on this
right now
next you have labels so depending on
what you want to use this for for
example i want to use this
to represent that it's important or
immediate
put it as red
say
so
i can select this label to indicate that
this is now very important so depending
on your company's you know style or
depending on your requirements
you can add the labels
then you have a checklist
so
different steps can be focused on with
this checklist for example i'm just
going to write steps
so we're delivering a product for
example
so let's just
use steps
gathering i'm just going to write the
software life cycle steps analysis
design
implementation
testing
deployment and maintenance
so yeah we have all the steps so one
thing is that once each of these steps
are done
you tick it
so a percentage increases so until
you're done with hundred percent you can
just keep ticking finally it'll show 100
and you're done
so another thing is a
due date
so this is basically by when you want it
completed
so this is basically a reminder that we
need to complete it or before a
particular date is done so i'm not
adding a due date out of now but that's
up to you
next you have something called
attachment so say for example all your
requirements have been gathered into one
pdf so where all the requirements that
are required by the company are shown on
that pdf you can attach it here so that
everyone has access to it
then a cover can also be added to your
card which is just basically beautifying
it so we can find one
so for example this
and there you go there's a pretty good
looking code here
now
we have all the information so let's get
started
so to officially mark the beginning of
the project we'll just go and put this
to in progress so at the same time you
can do the same thing with this card as
well about company b so let's just focus
on company a now
so say the steps have already started
requirement gathering is done
designing is done
implementation is also done so
depending on the person you know the
technician
so the technician could respond that you
know
we've already started so before that we
need to add the technician he's already
on this but if you had to add him you
search for members
and you have board members who's already
in the board you can add the technician
now you can also you know add activity
details like technician one
how's it going
how's the process going
now he could respond here with
it's
fine
so each time one of us you know adds the
other or says something to the other
they get notifications so that you know
they get to respond as well they get to
know what's happening
now
now say for example
the technician is
not able to complete the project
or complete his work so it's put on hold
so here
i could say
so testing isn't done so we can say
by the delay or what's going on
and he would given a property response
and once he's ready he can finish the
texting
and put it back to in progress then
eventually all of it is done deployment
and maintenance
so you here you have an option to hide
complete items that's up to you you can
also delete them if you feel like it you
can close this and then after everything
is done and you feel that everything of
the process is done you can put it on
completed so if this is a recurring
process you can you know
make a copy of this which you can find
by doing this copy
or you could just put this on archive
indicating that it's done you can even
get it back by just going
to more
archived items and then there you have
it you can send it back to board that's
up to you
and there you go that's most of
everything you need to know about trello
one another thing is that right now you
can only add 10 boards on this feed as
of now because you're using a free
membership
also depending on the intensity or the
difficulty of the board you can also
have different
boards for different projects i've just
used one for multiple projects but it's
entirely possible for you to have one
board per project you can also you know
favorite this indicating that this is a
very important one that you need to
focus on every day so this is where you
get
all the notifications that x has changed
there you go
all kinds of responses everything that
you need is available on this home
screen which is basically like a home
feed you can also find templates
depending on your requirement
so you can choose a template from a wide
variety of options so i'm just going to
show you the kanban template
so here you have details about the
template
you have an example of what the template
looks like and so on
and there you go that's everything you
need to know about trello
in this session we will be talking about
agile project management and several
other things related to it before we
begin let's have a look at all the
topics we will be covering today first
we will see the basics of agile project
management then we will check the
relevance and principles of agile
project management we will then see
necessary steps to implement agile
methodology along with that we shall
also see different frameworks involved
in the process and finally we shall see
some companies that use agile project
management so without any further ado
let's get started with what is agile
project management agile project
management as the name suggests is a
flexible approach to building a project
in agile project management the project
is broken down into several stages of
sprints agile does not work on the
principle of delivering the final
product at the end of the project it
works on delivering sections of a
project are mini projects the process of
project management in the case of agile
is agile based so there won't be any
central control of project manager as it
was there in the traditional way of
working before we move forward let's
have a look at the agile development
cycle agile methodologies consist of
several small cycles or sprints at the
end of each stage we get a mini project
there's a product backlog that explains
new features changes in the existing
features and several other improvements
in the project then we have a sprint
backlog which has a list of tasks that
are to be completed during each sprint
the sprint consists of planning
designing execution testing and
deployment stages and at the end of each
sprint a mini project is delivered with
every sprint new features are added to
the product which plays a significant
role in the overall project growth after
all the sprints and early validation in
the development the final deliverable
has a fewer chances of failure let's now
have a look at some reasons why
industries have started moving towards
agile project management the first
reason is high product quality when we
talk about high product quality we refer
to the build of the product as per
stakeholders demands testing is
performed at short intervals of time
wherever needed to ensure high quality
of the product then another reason is
customer satisfaction whatever is done
in the project is known by the customer
the deliveries don't take longer
durations as they used to take in the
case of traditional ways the changes may
be provided by the customer in the
execution phase of the project third
reason is reduced risk since the project
is divided into sprints so if the risk
affects one sprint it doesn't mean whole
of the project will be at risk the
process of risk analysis continues to
take place with all the other processes
another significant reason for agile
project management is better and faster
return on investment the project is now
developed in several sprints and each
sprint has its own version therefore the
project becomes market ready after a few
sprints only since the projects can now
be released with ease and in shorter
duration this helps the organization to
stay ahead in competition with respect
to other organizations which have still
not moved to agile methodology now we
shall check the principles of agile
project management there are 10
principles for successful agile project
management the first principle is the
satisfaction of the customer by
delivering the project fast and with
least number of errors the next
principle refers to decreasing the
amount of time between the phase of
planning and delivery the third
principle states that the team of
managers and developers work together
and increase the productivity of their
work the next principle states that the
changes requested by the stakeholders
can be taken into consideration and
worked upon during the development phase
as well the fifth principle pays
attention to the factor of coordination
among the team members then the sixth
principle refers to the process of
monitoring and tracking the progress of
the project at the end of each sprint
and making amendments wherever needed
moving on the next principle states that
there must be a feeling of trust and
support towards the team to complete the
project's objectives the next principle
emphasizes on face-to-face conversations
with the development team the
face-to-face conversation helps in both
solving problems and easy knowledge
sharing then the ninth principle
emphasizes on finding solutions and
maximizing the amount of work done with
simplicity this ensures timely
completion of tasks by all the team
members the last principle states that
scrum tools like monday.com or zoho
sprints must be used to simplify the
complicated codes which further helps in
saving time
we shall now see the steps in agile
project management the goal of agile
methodology is to produce shorter
development life cycles and more
frequent product releases than
traditional waterfall project management
so we will now check 6 steps in agile
project methodology the first step in
the process is project planning project
planning includes feasibility study
development of scope breaking the
project into executable tasks or sprints
and then estimating the amount of time
needed to complete those sprints the
second step is the step of roadmap
creation a roadmap is a plan of action
that shows how a project shall evolve
over time a list of all the features
that the final product should have is
created and the steps to achieve those
features are taken the next important
step is release planning since we are
doing the project keeping in mind the
agile project methodology the project
will complete in sprints that means
there will be the release of features at
the end of each cycle and unlike the
traditional waterfall model the
development cycles will be smaller the
fourth step in agile project management
is sprint planning the sprints are made
keeping in mind what all is to be
accomplished in that particular step at
the beginning of each sprint the goal of
that sprint is decided and steps to
achieve that goal are taken the next
step in the process emphasizes on daily
meetings there are short meetings every
day to discuss if the team was able to
finish the task for each sprint and
check if there are any amendments that
are required each team member talks
about what they achieved in the last
print and what are they going to work on
in the next print the last step is the
step of sprint review and retrospective
there are two meetings after each sprint
first meeting is for the sprint review
this meeting is with the stakeholders to
show them the finished product this
helps both sides to build a relationship
and discuss if there are any issues in
the end product the second meeting is
for having a sprint retrospective this
meeting involves the stakeholders to
discuss what went well and what went
wrong during the sprint sprint
retrospective takes place after the
sprint review and before the next print
planning now when we know the steps
needed for agile project methodology we
must understand some agile project
management frameworks there are several
frameworks available today here we will
be discussing some of the most popular
frameworks the first framework we will
discuss is the kanban framework kanban
framework is a well-known framework for
implementing agile software development
in the case of kanban framework work
items are represented on the kanban
board which helps all the team members
to see the state of every piece of work
at any time kanban board not only helps
in visualizing the work but also
optimizing the workflow among the team
the next framework we will discuss today
is the scrum framework scrum framework
is a popular framework for managing
complex knowledge work like in the field
of research and advanced technologies
scrum is a simple framework that helps
team work together and learn through
their experiences gained while working
on a problem the third framework we will
see today is the hybrid framework the
hybrid framework is a combination of
agile methodology and non-agile
methodology in the case of a hybrid
framework planning is done using the
traditional way of project management
while the execution and delivery is done
using the agile methodology since the
hybrid is a combination of the two it
handles the requirement changes and
delivers the product in different stages
the fourth and the last framework we
will see is the lean framework the lean
framework works on the principle of
providing maximum customer value and
creating zero waste it focuses on
optimizing the flow of products all
through the value stream this helps in
eliminating waste all through the
process and create processes that
requires less human efforts this also
simplifies the process of information
management and makes it more accurate
finally let's have a look at some
companies that have opted for agile
project management today around 22 of
the organizations worldwide have all
their teams working on the principle of
agile project methodology let's have a
look at some of the most prominent
companies in the world that use agile
project management in the list we have
ibm cisco atnt microsoft philips and
samsung welcome to simply launch pmp
sixth edition training tutorial i am cmr
chandra mr a certified project
management professional prince to
practitioner itl expert itl for managing
professional kobit 5 and devops
today we are going to look at
understanding what is the pmp
certification what is pmbok eligibility
criteria to appear in pmp examination
the project management framework
the project management process groups
knowledge areas and processes
so now imagining the world where you
have a project being done so you are the
project manager
and how best a project can be conducted
so to make a project successful it is
required to follow a best practice
so if you have a certification just
imagine having a certification that lets
the world know that you know what you
are doing in project management so pmp
certification gives you all
so what is pmp certification
so the pmp the project management
professional certification is a
certification of pmi the project
management institute
which is at usa so is an internationally
recognized credential for project
managers
see the certification indicates
that the certified professional has a
sufficient experience education skills
and competency reason being
before going for pmp certification it
asks for specific prerequisites which
involves experience in project
management as well as
formal education of project management
and demonstrated skills so that being a
prerequisites for project management
professional certifications it is very
essential that one need to understand
what it takes to become eligible for pmp
examination so that we will go through
the subsequent slides so the moment
one has the pmp certification
that itself indicates
the prerequisites to take up a pmp
certification is accomplished already
before going for certification
and then the individual will go for a
certification and become certified
professional so that way it concludes it
also indicates that person who holds the
pmp certification has sufficient
experience education skills and
competency
moreover there are more than 10 hundred
thousand pmp certification holders
across the globe so pmp certified
individuals earn 25 percent more than
non-certified individuals
so now
pmp certification also has the
advantages which are given here like
helps the project manager to practice
the project management better create the
results better
demonstrate the project management
capability better so this also helps
project manager to show the commitment
towards the project management
profession
and having pmp certification
provides the recognition across the
globe which helps in getting better
salary compared with people the
professionals who are not certified and
also helps in increasing the network
project management network who actually
practices project management the fellow
practice project managers who are
practicing the project management so
there are certain vocabularies jargons
which are used specifically while doing
the project management pmp helps to
understand those
so now let us look at
what does the official guide
which is used
in pmp that can help to become a project
management professionals
so that is pmbok which is
referred as project management body of
knowledge or pmbok
which is the collection of processes
best practices terminologies and
guidelines accepted as standards within
the industry
so the latest edition of this is sixth
edition which was released in 2017.
the first edition of pmbok guide was
published in 1996 and the sixth edition
as i mentioned was released in 2017
and exam format was revised from 26 mark
2018 so pmbok guide will become the
basic reference to appear in the pmp
examination so one needs to go through
the training based on pmbok guidelines
so that will help them to pass the
examination easily so eligibility
criteria for appearing for pmp
certification examinations so you can
have two types of eligibilities which
pmi defines
so option one includes
someone who has secondary degree
should have 7500 hours of leading and
directing project that is an experience
what it is asking as a prerequisite
before
the professional go for examination
plus 35 hours of project management
education formally from a registered
education provider like simply learn
option two someone who has four year
degree
project management experience leading
and directing project this experience
will be 4500
whereas as we saw in option 1 in option
2 35 hours of project management
education is required and that is from
registered education provider like
simply learn as i mentioned earlier so
this training which is conducted by
registered education provider
will have their trainings aligned with
pmbok the latest edition so
simply learn enables people to learn
what are the topics in pmp framework
plus
make the professionals ready to appear
the examination and become successful
the project management framework which
is defined in pmbok
includes 5 process groups 10 knowledge
areas and 49 processes
so when we say 5 process groups this
indicates the way the project flows
how each of these process groups are
connected
while project happens in the project
life cycle whereas 10 knowledge areas
are the one which needs to be looked up
to demonstrated up to considered while
doing the project management
and the 49 processes distributed across
5 process groups and 10 knowledge areas
has the activities the objectives
the inputs outputs tools and techniques
clearly defined so that those can be
applied while doing the project
management so those are aligned the way
it is shown in the table
so five process group that is initiating
planning executing monitoring and
control and closing these are the
process groups whereas 10 knowledge
areas includes project integration
management project scope management
project schedule management project cost
management project quality management
project resource management project
communication management project risk
management project procurement
management and project stakeholder
management so each of these knowledge
areas and process groups are aligned in
such a way where the processes
align with a specific process group
and knowledge area can be demonstrated
accordingly if you look at a process
which goes from initiating to planning
planning to executing and then
monitoring and control while you do
monitoring and control if there is
anything found as a deviation it may
come back to planning or executing for
necessary corrections once the necessary
corrections happens again it moves to
monitoring and control to check whether
it is completely done as expected or not
if it is confirmed everything is done as
per the requirements defined then it
moves to closing this is how the project
flows in the project life cycle whereas
all the 10 knowledge areas happens in
parallel so now if you look at
initiating process group you can see two
processes that is
develop project charter and identify
stakeholders so develop project charter
and identifies stakeholders
basically defines project charter
required for the project as well as
initial identified stakeholders who are
required to move forward in the project
similarly if you look at planning
process group you have 24 processes
which are distributed across all the 10
knowledge areas so these processes
creates a plan for the project which
involves scope baseline
schedule baseline cost baseline
quality management approach then
resource management approach means the
plan i mean to say when i approach i'm
speaking about the plan similarly
communication management plan
risk management plan procurement
management plan stakeholder management
plan and all of these will get
consolidated into project management
plan in the integration management
knowledge area
once this plan is done and
approved then it moves for execution all
that project manager do during execution
is directing and managing project work
and managing the project knowledge
at the same time project manager would
take responsibility of managing quality
acquiring resources developing team
managing team
then communications which are planned as
per the communication management plan
communication should happen during
execution so similarly implementation of
risk responses defined while doing the
planning and conducting the procurements
as planned and then managing stakeholder
engagement so actual execution of those
work packages execution of those
deliverables happens from the team now
as those deliverables happens the
delivered products are checked monitored
and controlled you can see validate
scope control scope likewise for each
knowledge areas there is a control
process which checks is that happened in
execution as it was planned in plan
planning process group so then
that is consolidated here for monitoring
and controlling the project work in
entirety integrated similarly performing
integrated change control any deviations
found in any of these checks which is
being done in the control
now that deviations needs to be
corrected so change will be raised so
request for change will be raised and
that will be approved and controlled and
necessary directions are given approvals
are given and that moves towards
execution for implementation once it is
implemented again validation happens
once control checks if everything is
okay then it moves to the closure
now activities in closure a project or a
face involves just an activities of
closure the products or services or
results which are created from the
project
does not go to closure until
those are validated checked confirmed
and signed off only then it goes to
closing project or phase and necessary
formalities which are required to be
completed before conclusion will happen
in closing project or phase this is how
the project flows second point which
should keep in mind is a project manager
is also called as an integrator so
main focus the umbrella view the word
server project manager should have from
project integration management
so this layer project integration
management where project manager should
have an umbrella view total view about
entire project what is happening so
bigger picture only when project manager
has a bigger picture project manager can
come to the lower levels and see is are
they progressing the way it is supposed
to so then go back look at the words i
view again and see is it going in the
right direction which is very essential
so further i guess we will look at each
of these process groups and what happens
in each of the process groups
similarly in knowledge areas so let us
move forward now project management
process groups
so these process groups details the
necessary requirement that need to be
satisfied to ensure that project
resources are used efficiently
and these represents the chronological
phases that all projects go through
during the project life cycle so
starting from initiating stage it moves
to planning
once the plan is ready then it moves to
execution as the execution happens
validation
checks happens in monitoring and control
and as you find
some deviation in monitoring and control
for correction of the deviation it comes
back to execution or if any necessary
changes needs to be done in planning
also while doing these corrections then
it may move to plan then execution and
then monitoring and control so this loop
continues until the confirmation yes it
is delivered as per the plan and then it
moves to closure so that's how the
project flows and the project life cycle
would be like that so initiating process
group so initiating process group
involves the processes activities and
skills needed to define the beginning of
the project as i mentioned earlier
in initiating process group the creation
of project charter happens and
identification of the basic stakeholders
main stakeholders who are required to
understand the further requirements in
detail who needs to be engaged so those
are identified so setting up permits
authorization and initial work orders
which should be in place
and are important for effective and
logical progress of the project and
success across all project phases so
this clearly sets up the phases for the
work to be completed initializing teams
and having a well thought out budget
which is very important so this gives
that view in totality but it will not
give you the full granular details but
it sets the directions provides that
insight and also one important thing we
should keep in mind is in initiation
stage appointment of project manager
happens the formal declaration of
appointment of project manager happens
and project charter will be formally
handed over to project manager and that
formal declaration of assignment of
project manager happens from then
project manager takes over and first
activity project manager does is
identification of stakeholders so next
process group is planning process group
where
we have around 24 processes
to define the project scope
cost schedule
quality resource
risk
then procurement stakeholder engagement
so comprehensive plan if it is waterfall
approach or basic skeleton plan which is
required if it is agile approach so it
also clarifies the goals and
expectations while putting in place
infrastructure to achieve the goals
keeping in timeline and budgetary
constraints the end-to-end view of the
project is provided in planning so this
acts as a basic reference while the
execution and monitoring and control
happens so based on the planning the way
it is done execution will happen now
next process group is executing process
group where the role of project manager
is to direct and manage project work and
manage the project knowledge main
activities being an integrator of a
project secondly acquiring resources it
may be human resource or technology
resource or any other resource required
for the project then if it is human
resource there needs to be necessary
training
development of the team and then
managing them so lot of team dynamics
are involved that needs to be handled so
this involves managing teams while
handling time expectations and achieving
benchmark goals team members
delivers those results team members does
all the activities and then creates that
results so team concerns needs to be
addressed because as you see the people
together the team members together it is
quite obvious conflict maker so conflict
resolution should happen the engagement
with the team member should happen so
demonstration of work which is done by
the project team that needs to be
monitored and controlled parallely which
happens during the execution monitoring
and control is also happening so project
manager should look at both so consensus
is to be addressed execution is that
happening as per the plan has to be
checked as part of monitoring and
control while execution is happening so
bird's a view in entirety which says how
the execution should happen that needs
to be directed and monitored whereas
coming on ground seeing is that
happening the way it is required that is
also very essential so next is
monitoring and control process group now
as part of these process group as i
mentioned while execution happens it is
very essential to check
validate and control so this process
group involves processing change orders
any deviations being found
change requests are raised and if that
change request needs some modification
or changes in planning
then it goes to planning if no such
planning requirements simple change that
straight go to execution chain get
executed and then again validation
happens so integrated change management
which is there in this particular
process group so this also focuses on
addressing ongoing
budget considerations handling
unexpected circumstances that could
hamper the team's ability to meet the
initial project expectations so it goes
on throughout the project life cycle so
two process groups if you closely
observe planning process groups and
monitoring and control process groups
are the process groups where you see
processes in all the knowledge areas
otherwise if you see an initiating
process group it is only two process one
is an integration management other one
is stakeholder management if you look at
execution you don't see in
scope time cost and risk management
similarly if you see closing process
group only one process which is in
initiating process group so
these are the only two process groups
planning process groups and monitoring
and control process group where you see
the most of the processes so next
process group is closing process group
so closing process group closing project
or phase is a process what we have in
this process group which basically
focuses on addressing the culmination of
project management skills shown through
the other interconnected processes
that guided the projects so all the
aspects of process
are closed and all the necessary
paperwork is submitted so it can lead to
great reviews and word of mouth
referrals in the future so all the
activities which need to be done for
formal closure and conclusion which is
done in the closing process group so
this is about all the five process group
defined in the pmp framework so now let
us move towards understanding each of
the knowledge areas and the different
processes within it so how many
processes in each of the knowledge areas
aligning with the process group we just
saw in the table but when we look at it
understand what are those exactly so now
knowledge areas are necessary for
effective project management which can
take place during any of the explained
process groups so there are 10
so those are project integration
management project scope management
project schedule management project cost
management project quality management
project resource management project
communication management then project
risk management project procurement
management project stakeholder
management so many people ask me when i
train the people they ask me how do we
remember all of this so remembering
process group will be easy because it is
the flow which if which you can remember
then remembering the process group will
be easier but to remember the knowledge
areas
so one thing you should keep in mind is
initially when pmbok were defined mostly
in until third edition or fourth edition
we used to focus on triple constraints
so when we said triple constraints we
used to tell scope cost and time
now later when
as the best practices evolved as the
pmbok world so it did not limit on
triple constraints it actually said six
constraints what are the six constraints
scope
cost time quality
resources
and risk
so if you can able to remember the six
constraints so each of associated with
each of these constraints there is a
knowledge area like you have project
scope management which is one of the
area of constraints similarly schedule
management link to time
cost management quality management
resource management and risk management
so out of 10 easily you can able to
remember six
further there are four
now integration management by default
integrates all the nine knowledge areas
so remembering that may not be difficult
so to consolidate this
to conduct the project properly you need
stakeholders you need to procure
something and you need to communicate
so other three knowledge areas
rememberance should happen by linking to
this so firstly remember
six constraints that is scope time cost
quality resource and risk then you have
communication which needs to happen to
communicate there should be stakeholder
and also there should be supply which
needs to happen to the project so if you
can link like this
nine knowledge areas you can remember so
on all these nine knowledge areas you
will integrate and manage in integration
management so in fact all the plans
which are defined in rest of the nine
knowledge areas except integration
management so all those plans are called
as subsidiary plans so all these nine
subsidiary plans that is scope
management plan schedule management plan
cost management plan quality management
plan resource management plan
communication management plan risk
management plan procurement management
plan and stakeholder management plan so
all these nine subsidiary plans are
integrated together and consolidated in
project management plan so that happens
in project integration management so
this we should keep in mind so project
integration management what does it do
so project integration management
basically includes plans to develop
project charter a document that sets up
the project and assigns the project
manager created during the initiation
phase so a project management plan is
also created which is a roadmap for the
entire project to become a success so
the project plan once approved by
stakeholders and sponsor is monitored
and tracked through the change log it
also directs and manages the project
work
this process is monitored analyzed and
reported to identify and control any
changes or problems that could be
encountered so one thing we should keep
in mind when we say project integration
management
this is the only knowledge area
where we see processes in all the
process group so we have process in
initiating process group we have
processes in planning we have process in
execution process group we have
processes in monitoring and control
process group and also in closing
process group so project integration
management is only knowledge area where
it has a processes in all the process
groups which we don't see in any other
knowledge area now next we look at the
list of processes like develop project
charter is in initiation process group
develop project management plan which
consolidates all the nine knowledge
areas is in planning process group
direct and manage project work manage
project knowledge these two processes
are in
executing process group monitor and
control project work
perform integrated change control
these two processes are in monitoring
and control process group so close
project or phase is in the closing
process group so now we will move to
project scope management so when we use
the term scope
the term scope refers to the boundary
within which we need to
do something so first thing we should
keep in mind when we say project scope
two things one is the scope of that
product service or results which we are
creating which comes out as a product or
a service or result out of a project
which comes out
what is getting created so scoping that
part of it
so other scope part of it the processes
the tools the resources what is being
used
during the project so that deliverables
happen so two part of the scope we
should look at so project scope
management involves those areas deals
with the work of the project and
involves plan scope management an
important part of project management
plan the collection of requirements of
the product or service also takes place
in this process group and also
project scope management knowledge area
deals with work of the project which
involves plan scope management an
important part of the project management
plan so the collection of requirements
of the product or service also takes
place in this stage the scope of project
is also defined in the scope statement
this is expected to undergo change over
the course of project the scope is
validated during the project
ensuring that the deliverables are
approved by sponsors or stakeholders so
as i mentioned earlier it involves the
scope of the results what is being
created and also scope of those
processes resources tools which are used
during the project so processes in
project scope management knowledge area
so plan scope management which is in
planning process group collect
requirements define scope create wbs
even these
three processes are in planning process
group in total four processes in
planning process group
whereas validate scope and control scope
these two processes are in monitoring
and control process group
so when you say plan scope management
it's about defining how to collect the
requirements how to manage those entire
scope management planning and
requirements management plan also has to
be defined then requirements are
collected from the stakeholders who are
being identified
and then scope will be defined now very
important thing here is about work
breakdown structure so we have a product
or a service or a result which we are
working on to create as a result of the
project so how will you understand all
the parts of it that needs breaking down
that particular product or services or
results which we are going to create
into multiple pieces in a
structure which would look like a tree
so that you will get a necessary insight
towards what is being delivered
so firstly product breakdown structure
is made and for each of the layers of
this product breakdown structure you
will be assigning an activities
assigning resources effort estimation
cost estimation sequencing those all
this will will be done later basic thing
needed is work breakdown structure for
that so to create wbs the technique
called decomposition is used and this
approach is top down approach next
validate scope and control scope as wbs
provides that structure of various
things which needs to be delivered
referring to that as the execution
happens validation should happen whether
it is delivered accordingly or not and
is that scope management is being done
according to the plan control scope will
be checking that
so next is the project schedule
management when we say schedule it's
quite obvious for us to understand
when what needs to be done
so what needs to be done is already told
in scope and when are we going to do
that for that you need to have a
specific schedule the timeline so the
project will have various different
activities tasks
which is assigned to the particular wbs
element
so
these activities will have a specific
start date end date and this will have a
specific output which is coming out as
part of those actions which happens so
the project is divided into tasks each
with their own start dates and deadlines
and budgets so these are revised as the
project moves forward depending on how
the project is progressing a schedule
for the project and determining who is
responsible for that so
helps us to understand which resource is
required at what point in time similarly
the cash flow requirement can also be
understood by having a defined schedule
so the tasks are placed in a sensible
order and the dependencies between each
of them are noted once sequenced the
resources required for the tasks are
estimated and assigned the time required
for each of these tasks are also
determined now when we say this we will
require to understand and visualize
while doing a project the wbs structure
is defined and in what sequence each of
these elements are delivered
and what timeline start time end time
and how each of these are connected to
other wbs element in what sequence
what activity is required what resource
required what effort required what
competency skill required so all these
are put in so since we schedule and
sequence it we know when is that
required
so this requires
working with other knowledge area very
closely when i say wbs element it's
quite obvious it comes from scope
management when i say allocation of
resources obviously it has to work with
resource management to create resource
calendars if it's a cost management to
understand the flow money flow cash flow
so budget should be there for the
project so cash flow when what amount is
required to understand that it cost is
linked to schedule so
all these knowledge areas should work
very closely with coordinating with each
other interfacing with each other so
project schedule management also uses a
very important technique called network
analysis technique where we speak about
critical path
then forward pass backward pass
then identification of floats
so when i say critical path critical
path refers to the longest path in the
established network diagram of a project
and that will be the minimum time
required for project to complete
so this critical path needs to be
closely monitored as the execution of
the project happens because any delay in
this critical path will delay the
project itself
so that's about some summary about
schedule management now let us look at
the processes which are involved in
schedule management so plan schedule
management define activities sequence
activities estimate activity durations
develop schedule
so all these five processes are in
planning process group so schedule
management how it has to be done needs
to be clearly planned as part of plan
schedule management then when to define
activities it is quite obvious we need
to know what needs to be delivered so
wbs element helps us when the scope
baseline is provided as an input here
so taking that activities are defined
then the sequencing happens then when we
say estimate activity durations
so we speak about two terms like effort
and duration if i want to deliver
something let me assume uh to deliver x
for a person it requires one day
or for a person it requires 10 days if
we say so to create that working piece
of a product it takes 10 man days we
will say that is an effort
now if i have 100 pieces of suchness to
be created
how many mandates i need so 10 into 100
piece 10 days into 100 piece so
1000 mandates
now how many resources i have i may have
around 25 resources now thousand divided
by 25 it will be around i guess 400 400
band is no i think 2 000 divided by
uh it's about four forty so
forty mandates of effort means that is
duration whereas effort is
one thousand minutes forty days will
become duration
so likewise looking at how many
resources we have how many uh what is
that effort is actually required is
involved and then
what is the duration within which we
need to complete it either you look at
how many resource i have based on that i
look at the duration or i will look at
the target date mainly target date is
given by customers as you discuss when
the project needs to be completed
accordingly you are required to acquire
the resources so this itself is showing
us
these knowledge areas now work very
closely now without scope you cannot
define activities
now without understanding the activities
you don't know what is the effort
so now once you understood the effort
you know what resource what competency
when so you need to work with resource
management so to have those resources uh
onboarded or acquired you need to have
money cost so what cost it takes so
likewise it goes one by one elaborating
that's where you see 24 processes in the
planning process group distributed
across all the 10 knowledge areas so
this is about schedule management now i
look at
the cost management project cost
management so when we say cost it is
quite obvious it's all about money what
money the expenditure the outgoing money
so project incurs cost if any
individuals i keep getting these
questions in lot of trainings
so
is
checking the revenues the invoice rising
and collection of payment is that a job
of a project manager now when we say the
project management
and look at date as a project management
activities now it's all about delivering
the results of the project so when we
say i need to collect invoices and to
submit invoices collect payments when
you say that so that doesn't mean
it is part of a project management role
no now if in your organization if you
have a designation of project manager or
some manager or something and
invoice submission and collection of
payment is also part of your job
description you have to do you don't
have any choice so designation is
totally different when compared with the
meaning of the role called project
manager so any other things which are
associated with your designation in the
organization it may be project manager
also designation possible depending on
what job description what job activities
are associated with it accordingly and
to do but when you do a project
management activity in specific when you
involve in the project so all these
aspects what we're defining that needs
to be taken 300 percent along with that
raising an invoice collection of payment
or coordinating with some other
department to find out new opportunities
in the existing customer those are all
additional things which are given to you
as an individual with that designation
to justify many things so as a
professionals i have a position in
organization with some designations and
there is a ctc salary which is given and
that needs to be justified to justify
that various different roles are
attached to you for your designation so
that you need to look up to accordingly
and to deal with now let us come back to
project cost management so it's about
expanding money what we're speaking
about
which basically focuses on estimating
and allocation of budget to the project
that is first thing one needs to
estimate approximate what cost it takes
for a project now
what are those cost components so where
is that cost incurred so cost is
incurred
to the resources acquired cost is
incurred to the tools cost is incurred
in all that
activity what we do right so everywhere
the one we create a result for raw
material what you acquire the people the
technology this is what you occur the
facility what you have so all this
involves money the cost expenditure so
approximation of the cost needs to be
done what it takes to complete this
project and confirm budget it so this
involves project budgeting so good
estimation tools need to make sure that
the funds are within the need of the
project and stakeholder sponsors are
kept informed so
estimation and budgeting cannot happen
in isolation project manager cannot do a
loan that requires to involve the
experts the divine experts who can
determine how the budget can be
established
how it can change how it can be
controlled what are the regulators need
to be kept in mind so it considers all
those processes required to do that
all the tasks which are involved like
cost and combining them would determine
project budget so firstly approximation
would happen based on that approximation
then the approximation of that will be
submitted
then the budget is confirmed after
allocation so this needs to be monitored
and controlled throughout the project
life cycle so initially i also mentioned
earlier about triple constraints scope
time and cost so it is very important to
monitor these three critically so for
that there is a technique which is used
which is very popular earned value
management
which speaks about or provides you the
insight towards how the project is
progressing in terms of scope time and
cost
which are basically very important ones
then comes rest of the things quality
resource risk which complements to this
right so project cost management
involves
four processes that is plan cost
management estimate cost determine
budget which are part of planning
process group
and control cost is part of monitoring
and control process group now next
knowledge area is
project quality management so when we
say quality it's all about ensuring that
grades are set requirements are clearly
defined and how are you going to ensure
that hindering characteristics what are
defined are accomplished so you need to
have a quality management approach
quality management plan in place
now what quality management i should
follow there are a lot of standards lot
of
best practices
so that
is based on the project environment in
which organization are you doing in any
given organization there will be quality
management practices which are followed
an approach that may require to get
reflected in the projects which is being
done in that environment
or if project has a specific requirement
that specific quality management
standard or practice needs to be
followed then that needs to be defined
accordingly the quality management
should happen so quality management is a
part of entire project management plan
which speaks about quality
specifications products or service the
artifacts which are used as part of the
project so
when we say quality management approach
we speak about many terms like
acceptance criteria quality criteria
customer quality expectations
then quality assurance quality control
so all these needs to be
kept in mind and brought in place
and this
in execution if you look at there is a
process called manage quality when we
looked at scope schedule and cost there
was no processes defined in execution
but since the accountability of ensuring
quality is with project manager there is
a process now remember all these 49
processes defined in pmp are project
management processes these are not the
processes which are for execution so
these are all project management
processes if any team member is
configuring something creating something
delivering something
none of those activities are defined as
part of these processes
as plan when you make a clear plan like
when i said create wbs where you have
the elements which needs to be delivered
or defined when you putting an
activities into it adding activities
into it that anyway you have a domain
expert to do it accordingly execution
happens by team members but as a project
manager you are not involved in that in
entirety in execution i am saying so
project quality management will have the
processes like plan quality management
manage quality and control quality so
plan quality management is part of
planning process group
manage quality is part of executing
process group whereas control quality is
part of monitoring and controlling
process group so the next knowledge area
to look at is project resource
management so when we say resource
by default we think about human
resources
so that's how the knowledge area was in
the fifth edition
so it was called as project human
resource management but as the
discussions happened has the realization
happened it is not about just
human resource
many resources involves
technology resources facility resources
so the renaming of that knowledge area
happened in sixth edition as project
resource management so project resource
management focuses on
ensuring identification of those roles
identification of those resources having
a plan in place so that resources can be
managed better so predominantly when we
say resource it's quite obvious we
think about human resources
so which is very very unpredictable kind
of resource whereas when it comes to
technology resource it is predictable
the nature the behavior the
configuration everything is predictable
but only those human resources are the
one which requires a special treatment
a special approach to engage with them
so this knowledge area helps to identify
roles within the project team as per the
project management team structure
defined so there should be project
management team structure defined and
what needs to be delivered from which
are the roles which also include how
they fit into overall structure of the
project so these team members or
resources need to be acquired if it is
human resources those needs to be
educated an induction needs to be done
about the project and they need to
become fit into the project so when i
say people it's quite obvious conflict
occurs
various different preferences they come
across with they have their own
experience backgrounds and dynamics
associated with them so close monitoring
is required mentoring is required
demonstration of leadership skills are
required
so generally we speak about three main
ways of demonstrating leadership which
involves
authoritarian leadership then lazy fair
leadership
and participative leadership so
authoritarian is also called as
autocratic which means the project
manager will become
hold that authority power with that
power
the project manager demonstrate this is
how it should be makes the decision so
such power demonstration may be required
when something needs to be influenced
strongly and direction needs to be set
and decision needs to be made but when
it comes to
participative leadership when some
problems needs to be resolved when
people's involvement is required that
needs to be encouraged that is very
essential reviewing or creating
solutions that approach leadership style
is required but when it comes to lazy
fair delegative approach so where there
are specific domain experts who will do
it so assigned to them and then monitor
review with them that is delegative
approach so these three leadership
styles has to be demonstrated
effectively while doing doing project
resource management
so team will have their own dynamics so
that needs to be understood and
accordingly dealt with
so this knowledge area has
around six processes that is plan
resource management estimate activity
resources acquire resources develop team
managed team and control resources so
plan resource management and estimate
activity resources are part of planning
process group acquire resources develop
team and manage team are part of
executing process group whereas control
resource is part of monitoring and
control process group so next knowledge
area we are going to look at is project
communication management
so when we say project communication
firstly we need to understand what is
this communication is all about
so communication is used to convey
something to someone so there should be
two parties the communicator and the one
who receives it means sender and
receiver so very important here is when
sender sends certain message
at the receiver's end how it is received
is the meaning what is actually
perceived
by a receiver is same as what is meant
by the communicator means sender so this
will become a big gap if what i told
versus what someone understood if there
is a gap
then the communication is not effective
so it is very essential to understand
this dynamics communication should be
very effective and based on that
communication there is always a
resultant action
so always communication will have two
parties minimum one is sender and
receiver and in the receiver's
perspective one is to understand who
would be the receiver generally when i
say project manager project manager
communicates with sponsor project
manager communicates with team members
project manager communicates with
customers
project manager communicates with other
functions within organization suppliers
who are external to the organization now
each of these communications will have a
specific objective and intention
so project manager should understand
that and what sorts of vocabularies
jargons which needs to be used while
communicating the words
the communication methods which needs to
be used the communication channel
the language the syntax
understanding all of these will become
very important while doing the
communication in the project so project
communication management is the area
that informs the team and stakeholders
about the project
so the communication management system
is determined along with how it is done
and how often it is done how frequently
the communication has to be made so
managing communication should also
involve reviewing how effective the
communication is
and how the regularly the modifications
are being done to ensure the
communication is actually fulfilling the
requirements of communication needs
that needs to be discussed regularly and
looked at is that helping so it is very
essential as the stakeholders are
identified their communication
requirement should also identified
and
what communication why is that
communication how often how frequently
the communication has to be made what
channel what template which has to be
used and what language
so all these needs to be understood
signed off
so when you go and
inform or sends a message to the sponsor
it will have specific objective of that
communication similarly when you send it
to team member specific objective here
in this two aspect the frequency will
change
the language will change
the stakeholders to whom the
communication is made by changes
and impact it has to create in that
communication will also change so that
needs to be understood the project
manager should be very sensitive about
it so communication management plays
very important role whereas 90 percent
of the time project manager will be
spending
his effort and time in communicating if
that is not effective
it is difficult to become successful in
project management
now let us look at the processes in
project communication management
so there are three processes that is
plan communication management
manage communications and monitor
communications
so plan communication management is part
of planning process group
managed communication is part of
executing process group
monitor communication is part of
monitoring and control process groups
the next knowledge area is project risk
management
so when we use the term risk it's all
about an uncertainty what we're speaking
about so every assignment we take up
every initiative we do everything
involves risk
similarly project also involves risk so
risk which is termed as an uncertainty
of certain occurrence
are both positive as well as negative
the positive risk we call it as
opportunities whereas negative risk we
call it as threats so each of this risk
has to be treated certain way so before
you treat or decide on certain treatment
of the risks identified risks needs to
be analyzed so qualitative analysis
quantitative analysis has to be done and
risk responses has to be planned so the
project risk management is the knowledge
area which will identify how the risks
are
itemized categorized and prioritized in
the risk register
similarly risks are prioritized and
qualitatively and quantitatively
analyzed
so based on their impact on the project
the necessary response plan will be
defined
so risk has to be controlled by
reviewing the risk register regularly
and removing the risk that no longer
impact the project now the risk once
identified mainly risks are identified
some set of risks are already identified
captured in project charter whereas in
detail risks are identified during the
planning associated with many different
aspects of the project the risk related
to scope schedule time cost quality
resources maybe procurement stakeholders
so risks are categorized accordingly and
identified now this is not the list
which is made it is not an exhaustive
list which is made in one go so this
acts as a basic list as the project
progresses all these identified risks
needs to be evaluated on continual basis
and also new risks needs to be
identified regularly so that what are
the kinds of risks which comes up are
understood and then response plans are
accordingly taken so this helps in
managing the risks effectively and
efficiently
the processes involved in risk
management knowledge area are
plan risk management identify risk
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis and
plan risk response which are part of
planning process group
whereas implement risk response will be
part of executing process group
and monitor risks this will be part of
monitoring and controlled process group
so when we say identify risk this is
when you identify the risk here and
captured in the risk register and as i
mentioned earlier this is not a list
which is exhaustive so at the moment
whatever the risks are being identified
so these risks are analyzed now as part
of this planning qualitatively as well
as
quantitatively but the analysis of the
risk assessing those risks should
continue throughout the project life
cycle
because the impact level of the risk
would vary as it progresses throughout
the project lifestyle now
as we have a risk response plans defined
and for some it is already implemented
some you cannot implement you need to
make yourself ready to tackle the
scenario of issues when it occurs when
risk occurs you need to handle those so
have that capability built or having
some contingency plans any of such
actions are taken
and project should be ready means when
risk occurs the impact occurred and i'm
just okay with it that will not work so
project will get impacted it may
escalate the cost it may delay the
project closure many things it will
happen
so proper analysis and then
actions in time
right risk response plans can be
implemented so for
positive risk for opportunities
generally acceptance
or exploit or taking advantage of that
would be the kind of response we will
see
for the negative risk the threats the
kind of responses what we would see is
like avoid
or have a contingency plan or mitigate
the risk in terms of having some
measures implemented transfer risk is
another thought which is certain so if
someone says avoid risk
that behavior is called as risk average
behavior someone who don't even take
risk so
if i take up this i have the risk of so
much so i will not even take up that
such behaviors so those are the kinds of
risk responses may come across which
needs to be implemented as part of
executing process group
then whatever the plan whatever the
implementation which has happened that
needs to be monitored as part of
monitoring and control so next knowledge
area for us is project procurement
management so when we say procurement so
every project involves procuring
something
so a main decision which happens here is
make or buy decision so should i make it
myself should i create
myself within within the organization or
should i
do something or purchase something
so make or buy a decision so when i
decide i am going to buy certain things
from outside because we cannot make
everything as part of our organization
because the direction of the business is
totally different
if i am a bank and i am doing an i.t
project i need not go and sit and start
configuring a server
so i need not hire people who configure
and then they come and sit here and i
start managing them so my entire focus
of banking services which i need to
focus on
will go for toss i should not do that so
insured instead i'll give to an experts
so procurement of an id services from id
service provider i will do so to giving
it to the experts rather than doing
myself which helps me to have that
expertise coming to me so procurement
management involves in identifying those
resources the products or services which
needs to be procured
to use in my project
so that i need not spend time on that so
this involves identification of the
suppliers having those subcontractors
right so they will have an engagement
through a contract and monitoring and
managing them and establishing a
relationship with them and engaging with
them in appropriate way that is required
it is very essential to be done in every
project so that way project procurement
management would guide in terms of
handling all the procurements what we do
from outside external to the
organization so this knowledge area
handles outside procurements like hiring
subcontractors
outside needs of projects are identified
and how much they are determined this
involves a statement of work terms of
reference request for proposal and
choosing a vendor so to do this bidder
conference happens floating request for
proposals can happen request for
quotation can happen
so many such actions are taken
and the processes involved here are
three mainly so plan procurement
management which is part of planning
process group
conduct procurement which is part of
executing process group and control
procurement which is part of
monitoring and control process group so
the next knowledger is project
stakeholder management so when we say
stakeholder who is the stakeholder
stakeholders are internal stakeholders
are external stakeholders are the one
who influence stakeholders impact they
will get impacted they are influenced so
likewise
for every project every initiative
organization takes there are
stakeholders for me for my project i
need to identify all the stakeholders
so now identification of stakeholder
engaging with stakeholder managing the
stakeholders will become very essential
so as part of this knowledge area after
identification of stakeholders the need
of stakeholders needs to be understood
so not every stakeholders are identified
will have very close to the project they
are not in very close proximity to the
project the distance of the stakeholder
from the project may be far
still they may have an impact because of
this we need to understand that if i am
building a
flyover construction of flyover is
happening obviously people living in the
region will get impacted but they have
no direct involvement in the project
however their cooperation is required so
likewise as as we identify the
stakeholders we need to understand
what kind of impact or influence that
stakeholder will have
on them or on the project from them this
needs to be analyzed so stakeholders
needs to be identified their concerns
need to be identified and must be
managed some stakeholders would come up
with certain powers authorities so we
need to understand that as well
so each of the stakeholders needs to be
listed out their concerns prioritize
based on their impact on the project
then the stakeholders need to be engaged
and determine if their needs are being
addressed if not what can be done to
rectify those if at all any
issues exist
so various stakeholder state also can
exist there is a stakeholder who should
be very supportive in the project
actively involved in the project but the
stakeholder may be in another state so
we may require to engage with the
stakeholder
bring that
clarity explain and then
ensure that stakeholder is supportive to
the project some stakeholders may be
resistive some stakeholder may be
neutral
some stakeholder would be very
supportive
unaware so various different state of
stakeholders would exist but one needs
to analyze
what kind of state that stakeholder
should be
in this project that needs to be
discussed understood and then decide
so accordingly engagement should happen
so stakeholder engagement plan needs to
be defined very clearly
so now here we have four processes so
one process in initiating process group
that is identify stakeholder then plan
stakeholder engagement which happens in
planning
manage stakeholder engagement which is
executing process group and monitor
stakeholder engagement is monitoring and
control process group as i mentioned in
risk management in stakeholder
management also identification of
stakeholder analyzing the way
stakeholder engagement should happen and
deciding that engagement this is very
dynamic which has to happen throughout
the project life cycle and this is not
one time register what we create like
stakeholder register if we create it is
not one time register it is dynamic
which gets updated throughout the
lifecycle of the project welcome to pmp
exam preparation tutorial from simple
learn i am cmr chandra mr a certified
project management professional so as
part of this tutorial we are going to
understand what is pmp who can get pmp
certified pmp exam pattern syllabus and
exam preparation for pmp which involves
5 process groups 10 knowledge areas 49
processes and also we will look at
finding of simply learn about project
managers salary who is certified bmp
versus who is not certified what is pmp
pmp stands for project management
professional which is one of the most
popular and recognized certificate in
project management so it serves as a
benchmark for project managers all
around the globe so pmp certification
examination is offered by pmi and the
entire subject entire domain area of
project management based on pmbok
released by pmi so pmi is a global
recognized non-profit organization which
provides project management
certifications include pmp so according
to pmi global survey people with pmp
certification receives 20 percent higher
salary than those without the
certification so who can get pmp
certified so for getting pmp certified
one needs to have relevant experience
and training there are two eligibility
requirements option one one more holds
secondary degree should have 7500 hours
of leading and directing projects and 35
hours of project management education
provided by registered education
provider like simply learn option two
holds four year degree should have 4500
hours leading and directing project and
35 hours of project management education
from education a registered education
provider like simply learn certificate
is valid for the period of three years
and it has to be renewed every three
years to renew the certificate one is to
furnish a proof of 60 professional
development units so professional
development units can be acquired by
attending the training sessions learning
and also volunteering in many pmp
initiatives i mean pmis initiatives on
project management events the
examination fee for project management
certification would be 555 usd for pmi
non-members and that would be 4.5 usd
for those who are pmis members pmp
examination pattern so pmp exam is
closed book exam and it is based on the
pmbok guide released by pmi exam will
have 200 multiple choice questions out
of which only 175 questions are used for
scoring and 25 are pre-test questions
the duration of the examination would be
4 hours and there is no negative marking
so pmp certification exam result is
declared immediately after the
examination a congratulatory email will
be sent by pmi within one to two weeks
while a physical certificate within four
to six weeks so pmp certification is
based on the project management body of
knowledge guide which is a collection of
standard terminologies rules and
guidelines for project management
released by pmi so pmi ensures regular
updates to pmbok guide to keep it up to
date currently the sixth edition is the
latest version in the market pmp
syllabus and exam preparation the
syllabus of pmp examination is based on
the pmbok guide as i mentioned earlier
and to understand the syllabus and
prepare for the exam one needs to be
familiar with following terms those are
5 process groups 10 knowledge areas and
49 processes which are defined as part
of the project management framework
defined in pmp the examination
will be based on the five domains so it
includes initiating planning execution
monitoring and control and closure
accordingly the percentage of questions
from each of the domain areas are
mentioned here so 13 percent from
initiation stage 24 from planning 31
percent from execution 25 from
monitoring and control and seven percent
from closing pmp exam is going to change
from first july 2020. so starting first
july 2020 the pmp exam will focus on new
exam pattern which involves mainly three
domains that is people process and
business environment the number of
questions
i mean the percentage of questions in
the pmp examination will be like 50
percent from the process 42 percent from
the people and 8 percent from the
business environment domain 5 process
groups the five process groups as
defined in pmbok of pmp is initiation
process group planning process group
execution process group monitoring and
controlling process group and closing
process group so the initiating process
group involves the idea and processes
needed to begin the project the vision
of the project and the steps to achieve
it are taken into consideration let us
look at few questions related to
initiation process group which of the
following is not true about project
charter option 1 project charter is
written by the project manager option 2
project charter defines the purpose of
the project option 3 identify and
authorizes the project manager option 4
project charter is authorized by
executive management answer is project
charter is written by the project
manager because the question says which
of the following is not true about
project charter so project manager does
not write does not involve while writing
the project charter that is the reason
project charter is written by project
manager is the correct answer for the
question one question two which of the
following tools and techniques cannot be
used to identify stakeholders
stakeholder register is the answer
question 2 which of the following tools
and techniques cannot be used to
identify stakeholders option 1 expert
judgment option 2 stakeholder register
option 3 meetings option 4 stakeholder
analysis answer is stakeholder register
stakeholder register is the output of
the process identify stakeholder whereas
expert judgment meetings stakeholder
analysis are the tools and techniques
question 3 which of the following is not
true for a project option 1 projects are
constrained by limited resources
projects are planned executed and
controlled option three projects create
a unique product or service projects are
ongoing and repetitive that is option
four answer is projects are ongoing and
repetitive so it is true for operation
but not for project question four when
is stakeholder analysis performed option
one when managing communication on your
project option two when developing the
project charter option 3 when creating
the project management plan option 4
when putting changes through change
control answer is when developing
project charter question 5 which of the
following is not included in a project
charter option 1 business case option 2
risks and constraints option 3 resource
management plan option 4 budget limits
answer is resource management plan so
resource management plan is created
during the planning process group inner
knowledge area resource management
planning the planning process group
defines the vision of the project in
greater detail the steps to establish
communication between the project team
and the stakeholders throughout the
project are also taken question 1 how
well is the project going if the cpi and
spi both are greater than 1 option 1
under planned cost and ahead of schedule
under planned cost and behind schedule
option 3 or planned cost and ahead of
schedule option 4 or planned cost and
behind schedule answer is under planned
cost and ahead of schedule if cpi is 1
both cost wise and schedule wise project
will be going as per the plan if cpi and
spi are lesser than one that indicates
cost wise and schedule wise the project
is not doing good cost why it is over
budgeted whereas schedule wise it is
behind the schedule but in the given
question cpi of project spa of the
project both are greater than one which
means project is ahead of the schedule
and cost wise it is doing very good
means there is some saving question two
what part of the procurement is the
project manager if he she is in the
middle of creating a request for
proposal rfp option one conduct
procurements option 2 plan procurements
option 3 control procurements option 4
close procurements plan procurements so
during plan procurement process creation
of request for proposal would happen
while identifying the supplier
identifying the one who supplies the
bidder or the probable vendor would
happen in execution through conduct
procurements whereas defining rfp
creating rfp would happen as part of
plan procurements question three what is
the expected monetary value for the
project if there is a sixty percent
chance of hundred thousand dollars
profit and forty percent of a u.s dollar
one hundred thousand loss question three
what is the expected monetary value for
the project if there is a sixty percent
chance of a one hundred thousand dollars
profit and a forty percent of a us
dollar one hundred thousand loss answers
options are one hundred thousand dollars
profit sixty thousand dollars loss
option two that is option three twenty
thousand dollars profit option four
forty thousand dollars loss answer is
twenty thousand dollars profit so the
way this is calculated is the sixty
percent of one hundred thousand dollars
would be sixty thousand dollars and
whereas forty percent of one hundred
thousand dollars would be forty thousand
dollars so the profit percentage of
sixty thousand minus forty percent of
loss that is forty thousand so
difference of that would be twenty
thousand dollars so answer is twenty
thousand dollars profit question four
which of the following techniques is not
required to establish a cost performance
baseline for projects determine budget
process option 1 cost aggregation option
2 bottom up estimating option 3 expert
judgment option 4 historical
relationships answer is bottom up
estimating question 5 what is a work
breakdown structure numbering system do
option 1 determine the complexity of the
project option 2 helps in automating the
wbs using appropriate software option 3
provide a hierarchical structure for
each wbs element option 4 present risks
of the project answer is provide
hierarchical structure for each wbs
element so wbas element helps to
understand each levels of the product
breakdown the activities assigned to it
and the efforts required to accomplish
that deliverables as a result execution
the execution process group involves the
members of the team performing their
tasks as planned although the project
plan is finalized there may be changes
in requirements that come from the
stakeholders question 1 which statement
in reference to a desirable
communication model is false option 1
noise should be at minimum level
receiver must reply to the message after
decoding it option 3 receiver should
first acknowledge and then agree with
the message option 4 receiver should
send a feedback message to the sender
answer is receiver should first
acknowledge and then agree with the
message question 2 which of the
following is not a hygiene factor
according to herberg's theory answers
options are option 1 salary option 2
professional growth option 3 security
option 4 recognition answer is
professional growth as per the herbex
theory the hygiene factors include
salary security and recognition but not
professional growth question 3 which of
the following is not an interpersonal
skill to manage stakeholders
expectations as a project manager
options are building trust resolving
conflict risk taking and active
listening answer is risk taking risk
taking is a kind of response or a
behavior an organization or an
individual have towards a specific risks
whereas it is not an interpersonal
skills so interpersonal skill includes
building trust resolving conflicts and
active listening question 4 which of the
following should be cooperatively
prepared by both the buyer and the
seller during the team agreement process
options are option 1 contract option 2
contract procurement statement of work
option 3 request for proposal option 4
human resource plan answer is contract
procurement statement of work question 5
there is a software project team of two
analysts four developers and three test
engineers one new test engineer will
join the team in two weeks what will be
the number of communication channels
option 155 option 250 option 345 and
option 4 36 answer is 45 so to calculate
this we will use the formula n into n
minus 1 divided by 2. so n refers to
number of team members now in the given
question there are totally 10 members
that is two analysts four developers
three test engineers and one new test
engineer would join the team so totally
it will be 10 members 10 project team
members so when n is equal to 10 so
total communication channels would be 45
monitoring and controlling the
monitoring and controlling process group
refers to tracking and reviewing the
progress and performance of the project
the process of monitoring and control is
continually performed throughout the
project life cycle question 1 the
project could not be completed by the
accepted deadline so the project manager
issues a change request what should the
change request authorize option 1
additional resources using the
contingency fund option 2 escalation
approval to use contingency funding
option 3 team overtime to meet schedule
option 4 corrective actions based on the
causes answer is corrective action based
on causes question 2 an activity has
early start es of d3 late start ls of
day 13 an early finish of day 9 and late
finish lf of day 19 the activity options
are is on critical paths option 2 has a
lag option 3 is progressing well option
4 is not on the critical path answer is
the activity is not on the critical path
so if the activity is on critical path
there will be no float the value of
float in critical path will be zero so
in the given scenario the value of float
is 13 minus 3 that is ls minus es or 19
minus 9 that is lf minus ef which is
equal to 10 so that is the reason the
activity is not on the critical path
question 3 what does schedule
performance index spi of
0.75 indicate option 1 project is over
budget option 2 project is ahead of
schedule option 3 project is progressing
at 75 of the rate originally planned
option 4 project is progressing at 25
percent of the rate originally planned
answer is project is progressing at 75
question 4 which of the following is a
conflict resolution technique that may
be used in the project option 1
withdrawing option two directing option
three organizing and option four
controlling the answer is withdrawing
the conflict resolution techniques that
may be used in the given option with the
drawing whereas directing organizing
controlling are not the conflict
resolution techniques question 5 in the
process of monitoring and controlling
which of the following process is
equally important to monitor and control
option 1 quality control option 2 change
control option 3 scope control and
verification option 4 corrective action
answer is change control closing the
closing process group involves
assembling a report of all procedures
throughout the project life cycle the
closing process group marks the formal
closure of the project management
implementation question 1 what is the
scenario of the project called when
resources are cut from the project
option 1 extension option 2 addition
option 3 integration option 4 starvation
answer is starvation question 2 which of
the following is performed when a
project is cancelled or ends prematurely
it describes the reasons for
cancellation or failure and documents
the deliverables that were completed
option 1 starvation option 2 close
procurements option three post bottom
analysis option four post project review
answer is post martin analysis question
three during the closing the final
project report communication are based
on options are stakeholder management
plan option 2 communication management
plan option 3 project charter and option
4 contract answer is communication
management plan during the closing the
final project report communications are
based on defined communication
management plan question 4 what should
the project manager do among as the
following to complete administrative
closure option 1 update the records
management plan option 2 satisfy all
exit criteria transfer all deliverables
and store all project documents option 3
transfer project resources and update
the lessons learned option 4 review the
scope baseline answer is satisfy all
exit criteria transfer all deliverables
and store all project management so
these administrative closures has to be
completed while project manager do their
activities as part of project management
while closing a project question 5. the
close project or phase process is not
performed when option 1 canceling
projects closing projects closing
project phases option 4 reactivating
projects answer is reactivating projects
whereas
the close project or phase process has
to be performed while closing the
project cancelling the projects and
closing the project phases whereas
reactivating projects at this point in
time the close project or phase process
is not performed so there are 10
knowledge areas defined in pmbok project
management framework as part of pmp so
the 10 knowledge areas includes project
integration management project scope
management project cost management
project schedule management project
quality management project resource
management project procurement
management project stakeholders
management project risk management
project procurement management and
project stakeholder management so let us
go through those one by one number one
project integration management the
project integration management involves
the coordination of tasks resources
stakeholders and other project elements
the project integration management keeps
track on how one project elements impact
another so this provides a end-to-end
picture of the project and project
manager will perform the very important
processes for project manager for
managing the projects will be there in
integration management in a way project
manager is also called as project
integrator project scope management
project scope management ensures that a
project includes all the necessary steps
to meet the project objectives and the
project scope statement may change
during project life cycle in case change
in the scope is requested formally so
when we say scope of a project it
involves product scope as well as
project scope which means the features
functionality of the product or a
service or result which is being
produced as part of the project will
have a specific scope to be accomplished
accomplish that you need specific
resources processes tools techniques so
this itself will have a scope so when
you visualize the scope of a project it
should be like project scope what
activities resources as well as products
used to produce the result defining that
part of the scope and also defining the
scope of the result the product service
which is an unique output of a project
so scope focus should be on the both
project schedule management so project
schedule management refers to dividing
the project into several tasks each
having their deadlines and budget
project schedule management defines the
order in which the deliverables must be
completed so which means all the
deliverables all the activities which
needs to be done to deliver that result
has to be put in a specific sequence and
order so that accordingly project
executions can happen project cost
management project cost management
includes estimating managing funding and
controlling costs in the project it
focuses on managing and monitoring the
funds regularly to keep the investors
and stakeholders updated this involves
estimating budgeting and monitoring of
the project cost project quality
management so project quality management
refers to the processes of quality
planning quality control and managing
quality throughout the project the
process ensures that the deliverables
achieve the defined quality criteria in
compliance with the defined processes
project resource management project
resource management involves planning
estimating and acquiring resources
necessary for the project the process of
resource management is a must for the
effective and efficient growth of the
organization so when we say project
resource it involves technology resource
human resources and any tools any
documents which are required as a
resources to be used as part of the
project project communication management
project communication management keeps
the team and stakeholders informed about
the current state of the project so
communication management is also used to
award critical failures a project must
have effective communication management
so communication management plays a very
critical role in any project and
wherever there is no proper
communication happening in any part of
the project life cycle that may result
in failure so communication is very
crucial for the success of any project
mainly project manager spends 90 percent
of the times in the project
communicating so this itself shows the
importance of communication in
delivering projects project risk
management project risk management
refers to the process of identifying the
risk and performing risk analysis on the
identified risks the risks are optimized
with respect to the amount of impact
they possess to the project so risk can
be positive which is called as
opportunity risk can be negative which
can be called as threat all the risk
needs to be identified and
identification of risk assessing risk
and having risk responses has to happen
regularly throughout the project life
cycle it is not the one time activity
project procurement management project
procurement management refers to dealing
with outside procurement of project like
hiring of subcontractors procurement
management impacts the project budget
and this schedule project stakeholder
management project stakeholder
management refers to identifying the
stakeholders and finding out what their
concerns are the success of project
depends on the satisfaction of the
stakeholders so the stakeholder list
involves sponsor customer supplier
government agencies the team within the
project management team structure and
anyone and everyone who will influence
influenced impact impacted directly and
indirectly can be called as stakeholders
it is very important to understand who
are the stakeholders what are the
requirements of stakeholders and
accordingly engage with the stakeholders
to ensure the success of the project by
fulfilling the stakeholder requirements
the 49 processes defined in 10 knowledge
areas and 5 process groups are as part
of project integration management
develop project charter develop project
management plan direct and manage
project work manage project knowledge
monitor and control project work perform
integrated change control and close
project or phase scope management
processes would be plan scope management
collect requirements define scope create
wbs validate scope and control scope the
processes in project schedule management
are plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity durations develop schedule and
control schedule processes in project
cost management are plan cost management
estimate cost determine budget and
control costs the processes in project
quality management are plan quality
management manage quality and control
quality processes in project resource
management are plan resource management
estimate activity resources acquire
resources develop team manage team and
control resources the processes in
project communication management are
plan communications management managed
communication and monitor communications
the processes in project risk management
are plan risk management identify risks
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis
monitor risks implement risk responses
and plan risk responses the processes in
project procurement management are plan
procurement management conduct
procurements and control procurements
the processes in project stakeholder
management are identify stakeholders
plan stakeholder engagement manage
stakeholder engagement and monitor
stakeholder engagement now let us look
at project manager's salary the salary
of the project manager who does not have
pmp certification that will be around 91
whereas the project manager who has
pre-mp certification has 20 percent
higher salary compared with the one who
does not have pmp certificate it would
be around 111 000
and today we will learn about pmp
certification before we begin let's have
a look at an incident where two project
managers jon and ted are talking to each
other john is a senior project manager
while ted is a part of his team jon
finds ted to be upset so he asks him is
there anything he can help him with to
which ted replies that his project
failed john further asks him what could
be the possible reason for the project
failure ted tells him that it's because
he was not able to manage the time and
budget now jon asks him if he is pmp
certified to which ted says he isn't
then jon suggested that he must take the
pmp certification which will not only
give his project better performance but
also help him upskill in his career so
today we will discuss about pmp
certification in detail let's first have
a look at all the topics we will cover
we will begin with what is pmp then we
will check top 10 reasons to get pmp
certified followed by the basics of pmp
then after we know the pmp basic
concepts we will check who can get the
certification and pattern for the pmp
exam then we will learn about the pmbok
guide which is an integral part to
prepare for the pmp exam finally we will
see the cost and the validity of the
certification so without any further ado
let's begin with what is pmp pmp or
project management professional is the
world's most renowned project management
certification for project managers this
certification is provided by the project
management institute now when we know
what is project management professional
or pmp certification let's have a look
at some reasons why you should get pmp
certified today i will give you top 10
reasons to take pmp certification pmp
certification helps you become a better
project manager the process that helps
us acquire the certification goes to
several phases like gaining project
management experience and passing the
pmp exam which helps you in bringing
sanity to the project manager the
process helps project managers to learn
different industry trends have practical
knowledge and several other project
management constraints the second reason
that we have is project management
certification makes our resume more
valuable as we have discussed earlier
that pmp certification is the most
renowned project management
certification so having it on the resume
will definitely help the interviewer
recognize our skills there are companies
that only accept project managers who
are pmp certified pmp certification not
only helps in switching the job or
finding a new one it helps in
progressing in the current company as
well the third reason that we have is it
provides more job opportunities when one
acquires the pmp certification it proves
that one has expertise in completing the
project effectively and efficiently so
the certification increases the trust
factor of the interviewer in you and
increases your probability of getting
that job the fourth reason that we have
is salary hikes pmp certified project
manager is one of the highest paid jobs
around the globe and this trend will
continue to grow the global survey by
the project management institute shows
that pmp certified project managers tend
to get 20 percent more salary than the
non-certified project managers the next
reason that we have is pmp certification
validates your dedication to the job the
certification requires several months of
training it requires several hours of
project management experience and
exposure this experience and exposure
explains the seriousness of a project
manager towards its career path then
sixth we have is pmp certification is
globally acknowledged pmp certification
is the most renowned certification all
over the world it helps project managers
to be a part of different types of
industries all over the globe pmp
certification is the most renowned
certification all over the world project
managers who are pmp certified may get
jobs in different types of industries
all over the world pmp certification not
only provides theoretical knowledge but
also helps in gaining practical
knowledge which further helps in
increasing the confidence of a project
manager the next reason that we have is
better project performance pmp certified
project managers tend to deliver better
projects than the non-pmp certified
project managers this is because pmp
certified project managers are well
aware of five process groups 10
knowledge areas and 49 processes which
helps them have a clear picture of
different aspects involved in a project
the 8th reason that we have is it
increases your networking opportunities
there are several communities that one
becomes a part of when they sign up as a
pmi member these communities have
meetings regarding new job opportunities
and this helps in having a professional
network the ninth reason that we have is
job security job security is a major
reason that a professional thinks off
before opting for a particular
profession today in the world of
recession where companies are drowning
the demand for pmp certified project
managers goes on increasing the last and
the 10th reason we have is expertise in
practical application when one appears
for a pmp exam they need extensive
preparation they need to have thorough
knowledge of process groups and
knowledge areas which help them develop
several essential skills and move ahead
in their career now as we move further
we will look into the pmp basic concepts
the pmp basic concepts are the five
project management steps these project
management steps start from the day we
begin our project to the day we end our
project they begin from initiation to
closure the first step that we have is
initiation planning execution monitoring
and controlling and closure now let's
have a look at each of them in detail
the first step we have is initiation
initiation involves defining the project
scope this is the step where we explain
what our project will have for whom we
are making that project it helps us to
identify our stakeholders who all will
be the part of that project and
determine the project feasibility after
this step of initiation when we have
decided the scope of our project the
second step that comes is planning in
the planning phase we define a flow to
all the activities of our project we
define this flow keeping in mind all the
constants of a project like time
resources and risk after we have defined
the flow of these processes it is time
for us to look at the execution in the
execution phase we evaluate the plan and
the sequence of the tasks we have made
we finally put the plan in action and
the project tends to start after the
project building has started and the
process of execution has started it is
time for the monitoring and the
controlling phase in monitoring and
controlling phase the progress of the
project is tracked and important steps
for quality assurance are taken in
monitoring and controlling phase the
work being done is compared with the
work as defined in the project plan in
this phase the progress of the project
is tracked and important steps for
quality assurance are taken finally we
have the closure step in this step the
deliverables are delivered to the client
the documentation of all that took place
during the project life cycle is done
and project is fully evaluated now when
we have seen reasons for getting pmp
certified and we know the basic concepts
of pmp it is time for us to know who can
get pmp certified for getting pmp
certified there can be two cases the
first case says you must have a
secondary degree a secondary degree
means high school diploma or an
associate degree or a degree that is
globally equivalent to all of these then
you need to have 7 500 hours of leading
and directing projects and 3 500 hours
of project management education there
can be two cases first case can be you
must have a secondary degree that means
a high school diploma associates degree
or the global equivalent degree then you
must have 7 500 hours of project
management experience and 35 hours of
education in project management the
second case can be you must have a four
year degree along with 4 500 hours of
project management experience and 35
hours of education in project management
now when we know who can get pmp
certified we will see the pmp exam
pattern the exam comprises of 200
questions out of which 175 questions are
used for evaluation one can answer these
questions if they have thorough
knowledge of five process groups and ten
knowledge areas the time provided to
complete the exam is for us the
questions that are asked are of
different types the most common type
being formula based situation based and
knowledge based now when we have
discussed about the exam pattern
discussing about the pmbok guide becomes
very important so the next topic that we
have is pmbok guide pmbok guide or
project management body of knowledge is
a book that comprises of several
processes and different terminologies
needed to crack the pmp exam the whole
syllabus of pmp exam is covered in the
pmbok guide by the project management
and 10 knowledge areas apart from this
there are 49 processes that are divided
amongst 5 process groups 10 knowledge
areas finally let's have a look at the
cost and validity of the pmp
certification when we talk about the
cost of the certification there can be
two cases the first case can be if we
are not a member of project management
institute the exam fees is 555 us
dollars the second case can be if we are
a member of project management institute
the exam fees is 405 us dollars if we
talk about the validity of the
certification a certificate is valid for
a period of three years after every
three years the certificate needs to be
renewed to renew the certificate one
needs to furnish a proof of 60 pdus or
professional development units after so
much information that thanks john for
his time and promises to take the pmp
certification at the shortest notice now
let's have a look at the salary trends
of a pmp certified project manager and a
sample resume if we consider the salary
of a non-pmp certified project manager
it is approximately ninety one thousand
dollars while if we consider the salary
of a pmp certified project manager it is
approximately one hundred eleven
thousand dollars which is approximately
twenty percent higher than the
non-certified project manager's salary
now let's have a look at the resume of a
pmp certified project manager if you are
somebody with pmp certification and
looking for a project manager or a
senior project manager role your resume
should look something like this the
summary in the beginning would include
how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager like here james
brown has written he has more than 10
years of experience with generating and
building projects then when you talk
about your experience you should put
something that emphasizes on the
responsibilities that you had your area
of expertise put something that shows
your skill set for the desired post and
also something that you learn from your
former job role this shows that you have
command over your work and also the
determination to skill and upskill
yourself like here james brown has three
years of experience as an assistant
manager training new associates and then
more than three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only led
projects but also learned new project
management tools like trello and
primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here james brown has
divided his skills into two parts where
he has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included a
skill of agile and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
then putting your certifications play a
major role this proves that you are up
to date and updated with current market
trends james brown has his
certifications in c and java and more
importantly he has his project
management certification project
management professional in this session
we will discuss about project manager
roles and responsibilities let's first
have a look at all the topics we will be
covering today first we will see who is
a project manager
then we will check the roles and
responsibilities of a project manager
moving forward we will analyze the
salary of a project manager and the
steps that will help us become a project
manager finally we will see a project
manager's resume so without any further
ado let's get started with who is a
project manager project manager in
simple words is a professional who
manages the project project manager
plays an integral role from the first
phase of the project life cycle to the
last phase of project lifecycle this
individual is a part of all the
activities that produce the final
deliverables and strive towards the
success of the project now let's
consider some must-have skills of a
project manager first we have is strong
communication skills the communication
skills help the project manager to
communicate the organization's mission
and vision to the team members in a
clear concise manner these communication
skills help project manager to explain
their thoughts and requirements to
customers and stakeholders the next we
have is effective leadership skills that
helps in forming a team of skilled
professionals and lead them in the best
possible manner the next skill that a
project manager must have is a team
management skill as a project manager it
is very important to know how to manage
your team to achieve a common goal with
complete harmony a project manager must
have strong negotiation skills as
project managers have to negotiate at
each and every step this negotiation
might be with the customers stakeholders
or team members these negotiation skills
become of utmost importance when project
members get into a fight or an argument
then we have critical thinking this is
what makes a project manager more
effective and efficient in project
management this thinking capability is
needed to take difficult steps talk to
stakeholders and resolve several issues
throughout the course of the project the
last skill that a project manager must
have is risk management skill handling a
project is an important step but what is
equally important is risk management
this is the process required to identify
analyze and respond to the risk factors
throughout the project life cycle now
when we know who a project manager is we
must have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of a project manager
the first and foremost role of a project
manager is to set up a project scope
check its feasibility and determine the
resources that are needed to satisfy the
project scope second role that a project
manager has is the development of a
project plan according to the project
scope the plan is needed to encourage
the team to hard work with all their
dedication next a project manager is
supposed to set deadlines for the
project deliverables he or she is
supposed to manage time as a priority
and communicate with the team at regular
intervals next important role is to
analyze track and control the budget of
the project project manager has to make
sure that the project does not run out
of budget and is optimized as possible
moving forward effective communication
is one of the most important skill of a
project manager he she is supposed to
maintain communication with all the
stakeholders throughout the project then
we have is the identification and
evaluation of risk in a project project
manager must take steps to minimize the
effect of risk in a project the next
role of a project manager
is to track and control the performance
of the team this helps in yielding the
best outputs with the least number of
resources last role a project manager
must have is to provide reports and
documentation of all the steps involved
in project management this helps in
future projects and makes sure that the
mistakes that happened in the project
will not happen again in ongoing
projects now it's time for us to check
the salary of a project manager the data
shows that an average salary of a
project manager in india is
approximately 14 lakh rupees per annum
while the average salary of a project
manager in united states is 83
215 dollars per year the next important
thing we must learn is how can we get a
project manager's job there are four
important steps that one must fulfill to
become a project manager the first step
is to have a bachelor's degree it is
important for a person to be a graduate
one can hold a bachelor's degree in any
area of interest like marketing computer
science or even engineering this
entirely depends on the type of project
manager one wants to be the second
important step is gaining project
management experience this means that a
person must have experience in leading
and directing projects project
management experience helps in taking
different project management
certifications which further help in
having a good paying job the third
essential step is to learn project
management tools there are different
project management tools for different
area of interest these tools help in
quick and efficient management of work
project management tools are used widely
by organizations now learning these
tools will increase the chances of
getting selected in one of those
organizations the fourth and the last
step is getting project management
certified project management
certifications help an individual to
increase the value of their
certification and validates their
dedication to the job nowadays several
organizations have made it compulsory
for a project manager to be project
management certified there may be
several project management
certifications out of which project
management professional certification or
pmp certification is one of the most
common and widely accepted
certifications the project management
institute or the pmi predicts that there
will be 22 million new project
management jobs by the year
2027 now it's time for us to know how a
resume of an aspiring project manager
looks like if you are somebody looking
for a project manager role or a senior
project manager role then your resume
should look something like this the
summary in the beginning would include
how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager like here james
brown has written he has more than 10
years of experience with generating and
building projects then when you talk
about your experience you should put
something that emphasizes on the
responsibilities that you had in your
area of expertise put something that
shows your skill set for the desired
post and also something that you learned
from your former job role this shows
that you have command over your work and
also the determination to upskill
yourself like here james brown has three
years of experience as an assistant
manager where he trained new associates
and then three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only led
projects but also learned new project
management tools like trello and
primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here james brown has
divided his skills in two parts where he
has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included his
skill of agile and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
like trello and primavera then putting
your certifications play a major role
this proves that you are up to date and
updated with current market trends james
brown has a certifications in c and java
and more importantly he has his project
management certification in project
management professional or pmp here as
part of this video we are going to look
at few possible questions which one
would face while going through an
interview this will help them to prepare
for interview and also help to
understand what kind of questions would
come across when they face the interview
in addition to that
these questions also has an insight
towards the role of project management
itself
so let us look at one by one
question number one how do you define a
project
so as per the pmis
sixth edition a project is a temporary
endower undertaken to create a unique
product service or results
the temporary nature of projects
indicates that a project has a definite
beginning and end so when we say this
temporary end over undertaken to create
a unique product service or results each
project will have a definite start date
and end date
once the project team is formed once the
project objectives are achieved so the
team which is formed the human resources
which are onboarded to a project
so those are disseminated sent backs to
their respective functions or
departments and project will be
concluded as complete so project can be
simple or complex and may be managed by
a single person or a group of them so
every project will have a life cycle so
from beginning to end it starts and end
where it acquires lot of resources where
it will divide the project life cycle
into multiple stages or phases where
project is being done and deliverables
will happen through the milestones
during that life cycle
so projects are often broken into small
tasks to utilize teams trends and
increase productivity
question number two
what is a project charter
so project charter is a short document
that explains the entire project so this
will become a basic document which will
be given to a project manager so that a
project manager can understand what is a
project management is all about
so this document would include the
objectives of the project
how will they be carried out who are the
stakeholders
identification of risks advantages of
the project and the budget so project
charter plays an integral while planning
the project as a plan is something that
is used in all the phases of project
life cycle
it is very essential because it provides
all the necessary insights a project
manager is needed while taking up the
project
after getting the project charter the
first job a project manager supposed to
do is to identify the stakeholders even
though project charter will have a basic
list of stakeholders so project manager
has to contact those stakeholders
establish the list of stakeholders for
the project understand the requirements
in detail and further move towards
planning
what is meant by scope of the project
so project scope is most essential part
of project planning that helps in
determining the list of specific project
goals or deliverables so when we say
this
project will have a definite unique
deliverable which has to be created so
this will have a specific description of
the specification as well as the
features functionalities of the
deliverable
so to accomplish that features
functionality of that output what we are
going to create as a result of a project
within a project lot of activities are
done the processes the tools the
resources which are utilized for the
project all falls under this scope
so when we say the term scope it is very
important for us to understand the scope
of a project versus scope of the product
the scope of the project involves all
those processes resources and activities
what we do to accomplish the result
whereas product scope is the one which
we speak about the result itself the
features functionalities of that result
itself so one needs to understand the
difference between this project scope
and product scope and define accordingly
so this will help in identification of
the project's output
and why that output is created and how
this particular product or services or
results will help organization or
business to accomplish their objectives
this should be the basic understanding a
project manager should have so it
includes everything that is to be
achieved by the project which means
all those results what needs to be
achieved all those value which has to be
created by the results so we need to
keep in mind the result itself is not
the ultimate objective of an
organization it is not
instead the result will help
organization to accomplish their
objectives
for example if you take in hr department
if they introduce an intranet portal for
claim processing
so the application what is created as
part of the exercise of
initiative where my employees should
submit their claims through a specific
portal now that is to reduce the time
the processing
duration as well as the efficiency and
effectiveness of the processed claim
what is submitted
so this is an outcome
so keeping that outcome the objective
this portal is created the portal itself
has the features and functionalities
which project will focus and create that
results so through that result
organization would accomplish their
objectives that should be kept in mind
so understanding the scope is essential
so while understanding the scope also
need to understand how this particular
output the product results
is going to add value to the business
what is the outcome of that that is also
very important to understand one is
understanding the scope ensuring the
project is delivered within that scope
and all that required to be done to
accomplish that scope has to be done and
only that
not anything more than that not anything
lesser than that
what is project life cycle as i was
mentioning during the question three
there is a project scope
so project itself has a life cycle
so this project scope falls under this
project life cycle so project life cycle
refers to
the beginning and end of the project so
there is a life
so you initiate a project trigger a
project project is actually started and
as it starts it progresses creating the
results and then it ends
project can end in various different
scenarios one is by accomplishing the
objective of the project the ultimate
results the deliverable it creates and
then ends
our project may also get closed
prematurely so we are not going to look
at the why the project is going to close
prematurely at the moment
our idea is to understand what is
project life cycle and to visualize that
so this entire span of time the project
spends from the beginning to end it
involves various different stages or
phases whatever the term you want to
call it and in each of these stages or
phases there is a milestone deliverables
which are measured and that will be part
of the ultimate deliverable what is
going to be delivered as a result of a
project
so it involves all the activities all
the processes all the resources which
needs to be acquired managed and then
the results need to be accomplished
ultimately
so
here in a project life cycle
it involves five process groups which
mainly focuses on different different
activities and dynamics of the project
which we call it as an initiation
process group
planning process group execution process
group monitoring and controlling process
group and closure process group
so during initiation process group the
creation of a project charter
appointment of the project manager and
identification of this key stakeholder
will be done
this can be initiation of the project as
a whole or as a part of a specific stage
or a phase
now all this process group what i
mentioned initiation planning execution
monitoring closure all of these process
groups can be looked at their
involvement in the entire project life
cycle at the same time it can also be
seen as part of a single fix
so each of the process groups are
applicable like initiation of a project
if i say similarly initiation of a stage
or a phase
so the planning process group involves
the process of creating the plan for
achieving the project's objectives so
this would create the detailed plan for
entire project or a skeleton plan for a
project if it is a agile or rolling wave
project
if that approach is taken like rolling
wave or progressive elaboration or agile
approaches
then the skeleton of the project plan is
created if waterfall approach is taken
it's quite obvious the comprehensive the
detailed project plan will be created
project management plan is also involved
in this
now in addition to this as you progress
in the project for each stage or a phase
there needs to be a plan which is
detailed further compared to the project
plan itself which will become ultimately
part of big plan of a project
the execution process groups involves
the project management processes for
identification allocation and management
of resources required for executing the
project deliverables
so here the actual execution happens
being a project manager the focus should
be on managing the project
so many a time i have seen project
manager is going and doing tasks looking
at the task level transaction level
which was not project management thought
so one needs to ensure
the project management is not about
deliverables in terms of doing the tasks
it's about getting the deliverables from
the team
so active involvement in terms of
acquiring the resources
checking whether the accomplishment of
results has happened needs to be done
throughout the project life cycle so
it's all about directing and managed
project works and at the same time
managing the knowledge which is acquired
during the project life cycle
the monitoring and controlling process
groups involves the process for project
manager to monitoring and controlling
the project now this involves reviewing
this involves creation of reports this
involves concluding yes project has
delivered or not delivered
identification of the deviations and
initiating with the change request for
necessary corrections so monitoring and
control will be done throughout the
project life cycle and only with an
effective monitoring and control we can
see the success in a project
so the closure process group involves
the process which is required for
formally closing the project where
everything including what went wrong and
what went right all through the project
is summed up so here especially in the
closing process group we will not focus
on acceptance of the deliverable instead
we'll focus on sign off capturing
lessons not all the formalities which
needs to be completed as part of a
closure
then where are we going to accept the
deliverables this happens in monitoring
and controlling so while doing the
monitoring and controlling we will
validate validate against what is
planned comparing with what is being
delivered so when you compare both one
would understand what is delivered
versus what actually was planned
so their acceptance happens once the
acceptance happens there only then the
project moves towards closure
project or phase either of that so when
we say closure process group it involves
the process for a closure of that face
whether accomplishment of all the
objectives all the deliverables of the
phases done or not is checked if it is a
face
if it is a project in the project
perspective if everything is complete is
checked and then it moves to closing
process group
where the lessons learnt the formal sign
of everything will run as part of this
closing process group
what is the importance of process groups
so process groups are set of processes
that are applicable to various stages of
the project as i mentioned earlier each
of the processes has a defined set of
inputs
and produce defined outputs by applying
a set of tools and techniques on the
input
the initiation process groups involves
the processes needed to initiate the
project that is develop project charter
and identify stakeholders the two
processes the project charter will be
handed over to the project manager and
formal declaration of appointment of the
project manager will be done further
project manager has to identify the key
stakeholders and take forward the
project as per the direction set in the
project charter so in this group in this
process group initiation process group
it is a formal declaration of
appointment of project manager to the
project but one needs to remember should
not get confused in real time we see an
individual who is about to become a
project manager for a project sits and
create a project charter we have seen
that in reality
so does it mean that what is told here
is wrong compared to what is practiced
that is not the idea many organization
thinks if we involve the project manager
to be project manager of a project while
creating the project charter itself the
level of information the detail that
person will have about a project will be
more compared to a person we will become
a project manager
after ending over the project charter so
there is a difference the person takes
the project charter and become aware of
the project that is one scenario the
person actively involved in creating a
project charter and then become a
project manager that is better scenario
where the person will be more informed
but ultimately the accountability of a
project charter lies with the sponsor
formal declaration of appointment of
project manager confirmation of that
happens only when project charter is
approved and handed over to the person
who is to be project manager so that's
where actual initiation of project
happens
then project manager can move out and
start identifying the stakeholders and
start collecting the details of the
stakeholders the requirements and
stakeholders cannot give all the
requirements comes coming to their mind
they need to restrict to those project
detailing what needs to be provided the
planning process group defines the
detail plan of the project which
involves the planning for scope time
cost quality resource risk procurement
stakeholders communication and
integration of all these subsidiary
plans each of this plan like scope
management plan schedule management plan
cost management plan quality management
plan resource management plan risk
management plan procurement management
plan stakeholder engagement plan
communication management plan so all
these plans are called as subsidiary
plans so all these plans are integrated
and detailed project management plan
will be created so this involves various
tools and techniques like expert
judgment meetings analogous estimation
parametric estimation decomposition part
critical path method
depending on the specific area which has
been focused on while planning for
example expert judgment is a common
technique used across all the areas like
scope time cost quality all of these
nine areas knowledge areas which i was
mentioning expert judgment meetings are
mostly seen as a technique used during
each of these planning whereas when it
comes to critical path method
so critical path method is about
scheduling so we will see the technique
only in mostly schedule management
similarly if i speak about decomposition
we see that in scope management so
likewise there are specific techniques
which are specific to a specific
knowledge areas which we need to
identify as we go through the entire
framework itself
similarly there are common techniques
used across the knowledge areas which if
you can identify that common techniques
which are used across knowledge areas it
is easy for us to remember and recall
those similarly specific techniques for
a specific knowledge area the execution
process group involves the processes to
direct and manage the project works the
active involvement of the members of the
team is seen performing their tasks to
execute the project works
although the project plan is finalized
there may be changes in requirements
that come from the stakeholders which
are considered for further modifications
so actual involvement of team delivering
something acquiring the team
onboarding the team onboarding the
supplier
identification of them doing the bidder
conference
engaging with stakeholders
all this action should happen so because
the main focus of execution process
group in project management perspective
is directing and managing project work
and managing the project knowledge which
is very very important
the monitoring and controlling process
group refers to tracking and reviewing
the progress and performance of the
project the process of monitoring and
controlling is continually performed
throughout the project life cycle so
here i think as i mentioned earlier as
well so it is very essential for us to
understand whether project has delivered
all those required deliverables or not
are the deliverables are fulfilling all
the features and functionality which are
defined during the planning that
validation should happen any deviations
are found change requests arised and
these change requests are approved once
it is approved then it comes to
integrated change control process
through which changes are executed
then the closing process group involves
assembling a report of all procedures
throughout the project life cycle the
closing process group marks the formal
closure of the project and completion of
its deliverables now let us move to the
next question
so question number six name 10 knowledge
areas as mentioned in the pmbok
so the 10 knowledge areas are project
integration management project scope
management project schedule management
project cost management project quality
management project resource management
project communications management
project risk management project
procurement management and project
stakeholder manager the project
integration management basically focuses
on unification and integration of all
the project to manage it in an
integrated way a project manager is also
called as an integrator which means a
project manager should have an
end-to-end visibility of the project so
all the rest of the nine knowledge areas
the plan which is created as part of all
the next nine knowledge areas
those are consolidated and a
comprehensive project management plan
will be created in project integration
management so this is the only knowledge
area where we see the processes in all
the process groups whereas in the rest
of the knowledge areas if you see we
don't see any processes in initiating
process group except stakeholder
management
so integration management has one
process similarly stakeholder management
has one process in initiation process
group similarly in closing process group
only integration management has a
process no other knowledge areas has any
processes so this is the only knowledge
area where we find processes in all the
process groups which means it is very
important to look at a project in an
end-to-end view perspective a full view
of a project should be known to the
project management only the project
manager can become successful in doing
the project management the next
knowledge area project scope management
which focuses on ensuring collecting
requirements defining scope creating
work breakdown structures
and scope baseline so scope management
focuses on ensuring the necessary scope
is defined and provided so that during
execution projects are delivered
accordingly and monitoring controlling
of the scope the validation of the scope
will be based on what is defined in the
planning what is planned as part of
scope management
similar to scope management in schedule
management once that work breakdown
structure is created it is very
essential to understand what it takes in
terms of efforts what it takes in terms
of duration and in what sequence project
deliverables are completed
in what sequence activities are done so
schedule management focuses on that the
critical the important technique what we
use when it comes to schedule management
is critical path method so in a given
project when we establish a network
diagram so we may see multiple paths
from beginning to end of the project
so some paths will be the longest path
which is called as critical path and
that will be the minimum time which is
required to complete the project so
schedule management plan provides us a
detailed schedule of a project along
with sequencing and duration and at the
same time that is considered as a
scheduled baseline
then the cost management so when we say
cost it is very essential for us to
understand it is an outgoing money
outgoing monetary value so projects
incurs cost when i say project incurs
cost there needs an investment from the
organization who is actually doing this
project
so the cost needs to be assessed means
an approximation of the cost needs to be
done a budget has to be allocated to the
project and within that budget the
project needs to be completed it cannot
go beyond that so budget is established
allocation of budget and confirmation of
budget happens and cost perspective
monitoring of the project happens based
on what is that specific budget it has
within that project has to done that
will become a baseline cost baseline so
to measure the cost and schedule a
technique called earned value management
is used well the terminology like cost
performance index schedule performance
index actual cost earned value planned
value budgeted completion estimate to
complete so these are the terminologies
which are used as part of earned value
management now let us move to quality
management project quality management
so it is very essential for us to ensure
all the processes all the activities all
the templates defined by the project are
complied with that is first thing while
doing the project during the project
life cycle similarly the deliverables
which comes out of a project at the end
of the project or at the end of the
specific phase or specific stage or
specific milestone so those deliverables
should be according to the
specifications defined and agreed upon
so quality management focuses on
establishing that quality management
approach so that project compliance is
maintained at the same time the results
what is delivered is as per the
specification what is agreed
the resource management focuses on
ensuring all the resources which are
required for the project are acquired
configured installed if it is a
technology resources if it is a human
resources the necessary induction of the
project the brainstorming required for
team to understand what is the project
is all about is given and the necessary
skills and capabilities are there with
those human resources and these team
members execute the task of the project
so project resource management plays
very important role
and now here when we say scope when we
say schedule when we say cost when we
quality in each of this in other
knowledge areas as well
the involvement of each of these
resources are essential so what
resources gets into scope management
what resources gets into schedule
management what into cost likewise for
each of the knowledge areas we see
various different resources used when i
say schedule management effort has to be
established while we establish an effort
it is also required to understand what
is the skills and capabilities required
so schedule management definitely work
very close with resource management
similarly this each of this resource
comes with cost so obviously cost
management is involved then quality yes
so who is going to do the quality
management so roles and responsibilities
needs to be clearly articulated defined
if it is a human resource in resource
management coming to communication
management so communication i think
plays very important role as we know 90
percent of the time project manager
spends on communications
many times we see project managers like
look only communicating many team
members have told me mentioning that
project manager only does communication
project manager only ask questions
now this impression to the team gets
created because they only see what
project manager is doing is
communication because team comes in when
everything is done everything is set
right so there they see project manager
during the monitoring and control mainly
not during initiation not during
planning not during closure so many team
member comes and goes during the project
they only see project managers reviewing
and asking the questions so because of
this they assume project manager only
communicates project manager only ask
questions but it is very important to
ask questions but there is a perspective
and objective behind it which already
project manager is involved and created
like a plan like signing off
coordinating with stakeholders
understanding requirements many things
has done in all these areas
communication is involved
so it plays very vital role so then
project risk management every
initiatives organizations takes every
investment organization does there is a
risk
so already the identified risks are
evaluated and project is taken up by the
organization which means the business
has already understood what is the risk
associated with this particular project
considering that they have taken up a
project but while doing this project
while doing the project management lot
of risk comes across project manager
should keep identifying the risk
assessing the risk analyzing the risks
qualitatively and quantitatively
depending on the level of impact of the
risk so risk means we already know it is
uncertainty of certain occurrence an
outcome it may be positive or negative
positive you can take advantage of that
you exploit it you enhance it whereas
negative risk you mitigate you respond
you'll have a response plans like
accepting those
or transferring it sharing it
transferring means you outsource or you
take an insurance
so that is negative risk responses next
the project procurement management the
projects would involve certain
procurement so we need to ensure for
this project what is that i am creating
myself and using it
what is that i'm going to procure from
external suppliers so whichever we
decided in make or buy decisions
whichever we have decided that we need
to procure from elsewhere
so procurement management plays a very
important role here so identification of
what needs to be procured what quantity
we need to procure who would be the best
supplier what are the criterias while
selecting the suppliers you may float an
rfp a proposal request will be respond
which will come in you may float a bit
when you evaluate the best vendor or
supplier you onboard them then you start
issuing a po formally for them to supply
and then procurement happens so end to
end management of the supplier right
from our modding the suppliers doing the
bidder conference establishing an
agreement and then engaging with them
for reviewing their performance all
these are involved as part of
procurement management the 10th
knowledge area the projects project
stakeholder management so stakeholder
means any entity or individual who
involves in the project directly or
indirectly they are impacted they
influence the project and they get
influenced so very importantly if we
think about stakeholders we can think
about customers we can think about
sponsor we can think about team members
suppliers who plays very vital role in
the success of the project so engaging
with the stakeholders managing the
stakeholders plays very important roles
and if every nine knowledge areas there
is something which are done right but
something wrong than with the
stakeholder management entire project
may go for toss so one is to be very
careful understanding the dynamics
associated with each of these 10
knowledge areas and then dealt with them
accordingly and integration management
would integrate all of this as i
mentioned earlier so that end-to-end
visibility of the project can be seen so
that is about 10 knowledge areas
mentioned in pmbok
the next question question number seven
why is the project planning considered
as the most significant step in project
life cycle the project planning is more
significant
this will provide all the baseline plans
like as we saw in the previous question
scope baseline cost baseline schedule
baseline so all the baselines required
which will be referred right each of the
baselines are considered based on these
baselines project needs to be executed
now many deviations to this baseline
plans need to have a formal approval for
necessary corrections so already we know
there are nine types of subsidiary plans
for all the nine knowledge areas scope
schedule cost quality resource risk
procurement communication and
stakeholder these are the nine knowledge
areas which will have subsidiary plans
which will get integrated in integration
management so without having a clear
plan clear directions so execution will
not have any specific direction to take
so you cannot measure the deliverables
so what to do
when to do who will do all these are
defined as part of the planning and that
plays a very important thing so if you
look at the entire framework of pmp most
of the processes out of 49 processes we
can see in planning process group almost
like 24 processes out of 49 50 of the
processes almost can be seen in planning
process group which itself indicates how
important the planning process group and
planning activity for a project
so why the project plan is considered
most significant let us look at few more
points so one is it provides visibility
in terms of what project is all about
what is that we are going to deliver
and what kind of results are we going to
create what is that we are aiming for we
get a better visibility so next
increases employee satisfaction because
there is no confusion each team member
understand what needs to be delivered
and what is that performance of the team
members how it is measured is also
visible and that is happening in reality
because you cannot deviate on what is
being planned so that should happen in
actual execution as well so obviously
employees are not confused now the team
members are not confused they are
delivering it according to what is
planned and it is easy for them also
because it is a better visibility
and they have a clarity about it
next is quality assurance and control
so as we know quality management is one
of the knowledge areas so doing timely
audits testing all the deliverables
compliance checks so all these ensures
the approach what we are selected
covering all of this ensures the project
is delivered as we planned then reduces
project risk because all the risks are
identified we have understood what other
risks are and we keep identifying the
risk and analyzing those and when we see
risk there is one unique nature of risk
where exactly the risk occurs
accordingly the impact to the projects
will be there for example when i start a
project if there is a risk associated
with human resources which i have not
even onboarded non-availability of a
specific resource very less impact but
when i am on board a resource and then
project execution is happening and
execution is at peak
now what happens it is quite obvious
risk impact will be higher compared to
the risk which would have occurred in
the beginning of the project so meaning
as we progress in the life cycle of a
project the identified risk will have an
impact differently at the different
parts of the life cycle depending on the
nature of the risk and state of the
project so since it is visible to us we
have a risk management knowledge area
which emphasizes on doing all of this so
since we are doing it it will become
visible for us to have effective risk
management so next question
when is stakeholder analysis performed
already we know stakeholder means an
entity or individuals who involve
directly or indirectly who get
influenced will get impacted are all
called as stakeholders understanding who
are those stakeholders who are
basically straight in terms of having
impact or impacted so we need to
identify them and manage them we may
have a stakeholder like competition to
our organization but do we really manage
them not required we might require to be
sensitive what competition is doing is
this project is unique so that the
details of this project the
information on about this project is not
leaked to the competition is not shared
with competition in that sensitivity you
need to ensure monitoring it you need
not manage the competition here but you
need to monitor what is happening
relating to computation similarly
stakeholder like team member so you are
required to manage them you cannot just
keep monitoring you need to manage them
so that there can be the results which
is required to be created has created
now next is customer if you say you need
to engage with them you need to discuss
with them you need to review with them
that customer is getting what customers
ask for
right so stakeholder may be anyone who
is affected because of project
stakeholder analysis plays an important
role to identify and analyze their needs
right so the analysis is generally
performed whenever there is a need of
any clarifications over quantitative and
qualitative data the clarification helps
in understanding the interest of the
stakeholders which plays a vital role in
the success of the project as i
mentioned earlier
so next question for us what is the role
of stakeholder in project management
so stakeholder as we know refers to any
organization or entity that can have any
positive or negative effect due to
project
because their interests are most
important their positive impact need to
be kept in mind while any negative
impact need to minimize while planning
for
executing any activity during the
project so it is very important to
understand the stakeholder perspective
view
next question what are some essential
features to be kept in mind while
choosing a project management tool
so project management tools basically
assist the project manager and the
project team
in doing the project effectively
and i think efficient way of doing
project is also ensured
because many processes are automated
and
the transaction will become easier the
collaboration become easier creation of
dashboards and reports which will
provide the visibility of the
performance of the project
so let us look at some of the essential
features required by project management
tools so risk management just now we
discussed about risk management and its
importance if a project management tool
assist while identifying and managing
risk because when we identify risk we
update those in a risk register so if
tool has established risk register where
we can keep inputting this particular
risks and keep alerting the specific
details about we have a frequency of
analyzing the risk repeatedly the
identified risk so informing us
reminding us telling that this calendar
is like this you may require to analyze
those that will help in making it better
right risk assessment as well as updates
in terms of managing the risk
or also lessons led earlier some risks
which of similar kind which are
identified are managed like this so
lessons learnt recalling those
coming to resource management so tool
can able to help us in terms of
calculating the expenditures and
distribute them among the tasks so that
it is helpful in terms of better
management of resources as well as the
cost associated with that
then dependencies milestones and
critical path
so most of the project management tools
what we have come across minimum they
will have this capability establishing a
gantt chart helping in terms of
establishing a network diagram
which will provide us a visibility in
terms of what is that the project flow
would be how the project flow would go
on and how the project is going to
complete what are the activities
dependent on each other so what are the
relationship between each of the tasks
what are the milestone deliverables
duration of the project what are those
activities happening in parallel so
visually graphical representation it
would give so it should also
minimize simplify the tool should have
that capability it should also have a
minimal interfaces or ease of doing
things like drag and drop interfaces so
ease functionalities maintaining smooth
maintenance and the support which it can
help us in terms of doing a project
management better
so basically tools helps us in terms of
assisting to have efficient and
effective project management
so all the information should be handy
so that it is there with us always so
third party integration like a tool must
be able to help us in terms of
collaborating with other tools
which would help us in sharing
information it would help us in terms of
for providing better visibility
any other tools which are there in the
organization if i am speaking about
documentation records sharing or any of
the reports or creation of the
dashboards these are the capabilities
which tool can have and at the same time
this can have an interface with other
tools like dropbox google drive
which will help in have a better
visibility and better collaboration so
agile workflow system when we say the
functions features functionality of
this particular tool should help us
becoming agile so moving faster means
quick inputs and feedbacks given because
when we say agile we are moving faster
when we are moving faster there should
be quick feedbacks which should be
coming back so that necessary
corrections can be made quickly so to do
this if tool can assist us in providing
those details
of increased flexibility and
transparency so that would help in
becoming more productive
then dashboards to manage projects
dashboards which will provide what is
complete what is not complete what is
the status of the project how is the
performance so this would help ins
having a quick visibility into the
performance of the project and also the
progress of the project to track them so
that what is complete what is not
complete and how it is progressing is it
ahead of schedule behind schedule is it
within budget or over budget the
visibility to that will always help in
terms of getting better project
management done
then customizable workflows so the tool
should be able to adapt to the unique
process to track work progression so
then um if it provides the mobile
application integration so better to
have team to know what is the status of
it anytime anywhere so that ease of
moving forward faster in the project
management and making decisions will
become easier because always having
right information in right time with the
right people is very essential so that
decision making can be more informed and
quicker
then collaborate easily the tool should
enable user to share documents files
status timelines and tasks with ease and
quickly with many people then delegating
tasks easily you should be able to
delegate tasks assign roles and then
ensure they have access to the right
information
so that's all about uh tools now we'll
move to the next question
so what do you think is the difference
between projects programs and portfolio
so this looks like a very uh generic
question which is asked by any uh
individuals during their interview
but even though this question doesn't
focus on project in specific it is very
essential for project manager to
understand the difference between these
three so that hope to ask for what will
be known to the project manager so the
definition of project is like a
temporary end over it's an activity that
is used to create a unique project
service or results we saw that we
understood already whereas program is a
collection of related projects which are
managed as group to achieve better
effectiveness and efficiency so when
which you don't get when you manage a
project individually if you group it and
manage you can share resources you can
optimize
the resources and cost you can
standardize that you can achieve through
program management so portfolio
management is again a group of projects
and programs which may be related
unrelated but strategic objective
accomplishing strategic objectives of
the organization is very essential so
all these projects and programs and
other related works are grouped together
with a common strategic objective of
organization
so
the project manager versus program
manager versus portfolio managers what
do they do so project manager expects
change and implements processes to
manage and control the project in terms
of accomplishing the project objective
whereas program manager expects changes
from inside and outside the program to
provide strategic benefits as i
mentioned earlier like standardization
optimization so portfolio manager
monitors changes in the overall context
of the strategic plan of the
organization
is this projects or programs or whatever
we do in this organization are they
aligned to strategic objectives are they
helping to accomplish the strategic
objectives so project managers manages
and coordinate the team to ensure
success whereas program manager manages
the program staff and the project
manager providing leadership and vision
the portfolio manager may coordinate or
manage the portfolio management staff
then monitoring part of it project
manager monitors and controls tasks to
produce the products results or services
of the project whereas program manager
monitors the progress of components to
lead the program to success portfolio
manager manages the aggregated portfolio
performance and value indicators
so planning part of it project manager
develops monitors and controls project
plans throughout the project life cycle
whereas program manager develops the
program plan and performs high level
planning to guide component level
planning whereas portfolio managers
perform planning at a portfolio level
the scope the project manager will
develop monitor and control throughout
the lifecycle of the project whereas
program manager has a program which has
a wider scope aimed at meeting the
benefits and goals of the organization
or as
has a scope that changes with change in
the strategic plan and goals of the
organization so why the strategic goals
or plans would change the directions
would change
that has various different reasons maybe
business scenario market conditions etc
the success of the project is based on
time taken to finish the project the
budget within which it is completed the
scope the customer satisfaction the
quality defines the success whereas the
program success is measured in terms of
benefits it delivered as it expected
from the program then the portfolio
success
is the aggregated performance of all its
components programs and projects
question number 12 what are the skills a
project manager must possess
typically a project manager would
require to have effective communication
skills so communication skills help in
terms of establishing better
relationship because it plays a vital
role there what do we communicate when
do we communicate how do we communicate
matters because it's not about just
verbal communication or return
communication
there is non-verbal communication
through body languages through
expressions which individuals do the
communication so it is very essential to
have a
right method and right approach towards
communication so the project manager
should possess that skill good
leadership skills so many times the term
leadership is confused with the position
of a leader
no so leadership is basically capability
of an individual so if a specific
individual having that capability can
influence people can inspire can
motivate project manager having a
leadership skills it's very essential it
is a must required skill only then
project manager can make
the people listen to him people will
respect him because the behavior will be
guided through that capability strong
team management skill which requires a
an engagement which requires
communication and leadership skills work
very closely with this team management
skills so understanding the team
dynamics
ensuring the right education right
skilled individuals are in place and
they're monitored and managed
it is very important so there should be
a little bit of mentoring which needs to
be done to the people regularly so that
team gets what is expected out of them
and they do accordingly then effective
negotiation skills a lot of scenarios
which comes in terms of negotiating in
various different scenarios negotiate to
ensure things have been in place or in
the interest of both the parties
involved in the negotiation it is very
important to involve and make a right
discussion right set of discussion so
that stakeholders are benefited now who
are these roles we are speaking about
who would involve in negotiation we can
think of customers while establishing an
agreement we can think of teams while
having some conflict resolutions which
you take team will have a conflict you
may require to resolve
so suppliers related uh issues which
needs to be resolved so negotiation is
very important but always
negotiations would be in the interest of
both the involved parties
then critical thinking
so critical thinking in the sense not
just
seeing what is there it's about how to
set it right how to take it forward in
the right direction so what could cause
visualizing things is very important
risk management skills it's quite
obvious the most ignored area have what
which i have seen throughout is risk
management so i don't know what is the
reason risk is ignored many of the
projects what i have seen almost like 80
to 85 percent people don't even look at
the risks so it is very essential to
look at the risk and manage the risk
only then project can become successful
so question 13 what will be involved in
project scope management so we already
know project scope means it involves
both
project scope as well as product scope
now scope management basically ensures
project includes all those necessary
things to be done in terms of activities
in terms of processes in terms of
resources that project objectives can be
accomplished so this particular process
project scope management describes the
project scope and documents how it will
be designed validated and controlled
throughout the project life cycle so it
collects requirement so collect
requirement process engages with
stakeholders discusses with them to
understand what is the requirement
collect the requirements document the
requirements and establish requirement
management plan then based on this
requirement established scope has to be
defined means the detailed description
of the project and product has to be
developed and a list has to be created
that includes all the requirements then
creating the wbs work breakdown
structure once the scope is defined so
now the decomposition of that scope
definition what is given has to be taken
into the lowest possible level it has to
be like logically further it cannot be
subdivided right
so decomposition basically helps in
terms of breaking down those ultimate
deliverable to multiple lower level
parts for example if i consider a car i
can think about two broad categories
like exteriors and interiors now in
exteriors i can think of a body of the
car the rear view mirror the wheel the
bonnet the glass so i can just decompose
like this now until i decompose to the
mirror further i cannot decompose in the
mirror what are all the things we can
think of mirror cap mirror glass mirror
mount so further can i subdivide this no
so each of the components involved
in all the perspective in the car
perspective broadly initially decomposed
it to the level interior exteriors and
further down the line we have to go to
the next level of components further
down the line we again decompose it now
at the lowest level we actually
look at the effort estimation activity
resource required all these we look at
and we'll do bottom up to consolidate to
see what is the scope so which will help
us in becoming scope baseline so while
lead scope is a process in monitoring
and controlling which involves reviewing
the deliverables with the customer or
sponsor to ensure successful completion
and formal acceptance of the
deliverables so formal acceptance is the
key requirements when we validate the
scope if it is not according to the plan
that is rejected and it is sent back for
change and necessary corrections
then control scope so in this process
the status of the project and product
scope is monitored changes to the scope
baseline which is actually defined as
part of the planning if anything is seen
in terms of deviation that needs to be
corrected the change request would be
raised
then next question tell us about some
project management tools so some of the
most common and popular management tools
which i have come across are listed here
like plutio basecamp teamwork projects
zoho projects asana jira software trello
i think details of this you might
require to go to individual tool
sections and then review those better if
you can able to create a comparison
sheet always helps in terms of
understanding what is that features
functionality of this tool has so one
more tool which is not mentioned is
microsoft project so which is also
another popular tool which is used and
similarly i can mention like primavera
so each of this has its own advantages
disadvantages so you may require to list
out what do you exactly want in terms of
when you take up a tool for project
management and what each of this tool
has if you can able to create a
comparison sheet that would help you in
terms of selecting the right tool for
your organization and projects
question number 15
what is the significance of monitoring
and controlling in the project life
cycle so as we know monitoring and
controlling is a process group so this
involves tracking the project's
performance alongside the planned
project management activities this also
focuses on comparing actual and planned
performance so we have defined that in
the planning so what needs to be
accomplished how it has to be
accomplished what templates are to be
used what needs to be delivered we have
defined it in planning so that needs to
be compared with actual thing what is
created and what is that how are we
doing this currently how it is done is
it complied with
assessing performance to determine any
corrective actions are identified their
status reported and appropriate
responses to risks are taken so ensuring
an accurate information base
providing information to support status
reporting measuring progress and
forecasting adding forecasts to update
cost and current schedule information
making sure approved changes are being
implemented upon successfully performing
monitoring and control the processes
within monitoring and controlling
process group so the possible outcomes
would be like the change request work
performance reports update to project
management plan and project documents
maybe if everything is okay well for
example validate scope which comes under
this process group so if when we
validate if everything is ok as per the
plan then it is accepted deliverable
which will move towards the closure if
it is not obviously it leads towards
change requests
so question number 16 is what's the key
difference in the roles of the project
and program manager so project manager
is basically focuses on projects and its
success of the project as we know
already whereas program manager looks at
all those projects which fall under the
program are managed together and taken
forward in the required direction so
program manager plans program level
activities and the schedule of projects
so program managers defines terms of
reference for projects the starts stops
and monitor progress of constituent
projects manages program level risks and
issues they set up policies and
procedures for projects they resolve
conflicts they determine the program
standards similarly project manager
focuses on planning a project based on
dependencies and interfaces given by the
project manager so works within the
defined tar terms of references given
for the projects runs a project reports
to program manager manage project risks
and issues and escalates them to program
manager if required if at all a project
is part of a program if it is not then
that escalation goes to sponsor so
project manager runs projects according
to the policies and procedures uses
resources assigned to project manager
and delivers the products that satisfy
the requirements question number 17
what are the types of risks involved in
the project so we know that one of the
knowledge areas in the project
management is risk management it is very
essential for us to identify assess and
analyze risk and have the risk response
plans so while doing it it is also very
important for us to understand
categorizing the risks depending on
where exactly what category this risk
falls into
depending on the impacts for example
some of the list which is given common
types of risk there is categories you
can think of it may be related to cost
schedule performance technology or
technical strategic
legal market risk risk related to
external hazards and it goes on so these
are the minimum set of list which we can
think of in any project the the kind of
risk are associated with which area so
when i say cost associated risk it's all
about monetary related where we invest
where we actually monitor that budget
involve that budget incur that cost
related to that schedule in terms of
doing it faster doing it slower doing it
as per the plan so various different
details which are associated with the
schedule likewise each of these types
what we have mentioned will have a risk
accordingly associated with them so
question number 18 what is the
difference between the risk and the
issue in context of project management
so when we say risk is always we look at
in the future so it's an uncertainty of
outcome when we say we are looking in
the future it may be next moment in the
future but it is risk which is focused
on the future so risks may be positive
or negative any risk we identify may
have positive or negative impact whereas
risk response will be in accordance with
the risk response planning and this are
documented in risk register
so issue is always the one which we have
in front of us to manage so it is
focused on present always negative it
will have negative impacts so response
will be in accordance to the issue
workaround provided and these are
documented in the issue register so next
question question number 19 how does
project scheduling help in project
execution project scheduling make sure
there is a sequence of how all the tasks
will be performed after the resources
are estimated and plan is made the
schedule plays a very important role
because when to do
when it is planned it is very essential
to do accordingly so providing the
sequence what activity has to be done in
what sequence it's also very important
so this must be carried out first and
what should follow needs to be clearly
understood
the optimized scheduling of tasks
provides the best possible output with
the allocated resources and that has to
be done within the scheduled time within
the deadline
question number 20 what do you
understand by quality control now
quality control refers to activities
needed to evaluate if the project meets
all the requirements with respect to the
scope of the project planning now when
we say a control we should think about
the output of a project the deliverable
it has the specifications so relating to
that specifications the features
functionality is what needs to be
delivered is it delivered accordingly so
project managers defines the standard
that the project must fulfill to be
successful quality control includes
validating the deliverables satisfying
the requirements of the stakeholders
identifying the cause of poor project
quality and taking necessary actions to
eliminate problems
right question number 21 explain the
forming in team dynamics basically when
we say team dynamics it involves various
different stages like forming storming
norming performing and adjourning so
farming happens first now this happens
when the team first meets each other so
when they meet each other
they get introduced to each other and
get to know their backgrounds experience
and areas of expertise the team members
discuss about the project discuss the
project objectives and beginning to
think their role in the project they're
beginning to understand
they know what is this project is all
about so in detail what is this project
is all about will be understood by them
in storming which is the next stage in
the team dynamics
question number 22 so what is work
breakdown structure and how does it
affect the work estimates of tasks or
activities work breakdown structure is a
hierarchical replica of all the work in
the project for example if i take up a
specific object specific products or
services which we are bringing out as a
result for example if i take a car so
how will i visualize various different
parts of the car it's very difficult in
one go in in execution perspective and
creation perspective
we may require to know every parts of it
in detail so work breakdown structure is
established using decomposition as a
technique
which means for example if i take car as
an example car has a hole when you
visualize broadly i would classify that
into decomposing to the first level like
exteriors and interiors after exteriors
i can further decompose the exterior
part of it similarly after interiors i
will decompose it further in exteriors
what are the things i can think of like
exteriors in terms of glass in terms of
body in terms of tires in terms of wheel
bonnet mirror rear mirror which is
outside so likewise there will have
various different decompositions level
that is a second level of decomposition
next third level of decomposition i can
go in each of these parts what i said i
can further elaborate those if i take
the rear view mirror as an example so i
can think about mirror cap i can think
about mirror glass i can think about
mirror mount so these are the various
different decomposed levels below mirror
similarly if i come to interiors we can
think about entertainment system you can
think about seeds we can think about ac
right so we can think about uh anything
else like dashboards now each of these
components further i can decompose so
the idea of decomposing is i am going to
understand what are the various product
parts are involved to make a bigger
product as a whole so once i accomplish
that i will have a details at each of
these levels and consolidate upwards as
shown in the picture here the first
level task one task two task three
before i assign these tasks i will have
the product breakdown structure first
and from bottom level i start adding up
the activities effort estimation and
then i keep consolidating upwards
similarly i will put the cost components
to it i'll estimate the cost involved
with the one which is required and then
i go upwards and consult it so wbs helps
in organizing the work in a manageable
sections so this would help in
establishing additional details which
would help in defining tasks helping in
estimation helps in when i say
estimation it is not just specific
estimation it's about cost estimation
schedule estimation effort estimation
and then this will also help us in terms
of sequencing further so work breakdown
structure will also have something
called wbs dictionary which gives the
description of all the wbs elements
next question question number 23 what is
meant by the term spi now spi refers to
schedule performance index so schedule
performance index is a measure of
schedule efficiency expressed as a ratio
of earned value to the planned value so
when i say earned value earned value is
the actual work which is completed the
value the budgeted value for the actual
work which is completed and planned
value is the budgeted value of the work
which is supposed to be accomplished as
per the plan now this will help us in
understanding how the project is
progressing in schedule perspective if
spi is lesser than 1 means it is behind
schedule spi is more than one it is head
of schedule if sp is one it is as per
the plan schedule is as per the plan
question number 24 what is the
significance of agile project management
so when we say agile the terminology
itself refers to quick response flexible
moving faster so while we do agile
project management it is very essential
to look at the various dynamics around
so it may be a quick response what you
need to give right so predominantly
agile methodologies are today adopted in
various types of industries so currently
we see more and more in it and software
industry than
product development marketing campaigns
even in constructing companies some of
the reasons that encourage industries to
take up agile methodologies are
high product quality high customer
satisfaction reduced risk better and
faster roi now let us look at the
question number 25 what is the
significance of agile project management
so the agile project management
frameworks involves continuous planning
and testing so there are various
different frameworks each of them having
their own unique qualities so it is very
essential for us to understand what are
those various different agile frameworks
and how they are going to contribute to
become agile so the most popular agile
frameworks some thoughts which actually
depicts and supports organization to
become agile or one of that is kanban
framework so kanban framework is used to
implement agile software development and
requires real time communication so work
items are represented on a kanban board
allowing team members to see the state
of each work at any time so this means
on the board so work in progress work
which has to be done and who has to do
it all these details are captured in the
kanban board now very important point
here is when these are captured it's
very essential to understand it is a
visual board so when it is a visual
board it's quite obvious anyone who has
actually have a task against them they
don't hesitate they need to complete it
it forces them since it is a visualized
system it works on their consciousness
so it is also called as pull system so
because people pull the work from that
list whatever is given and then
accomplish it so this will also help in
tracking the progression
of a project how it is progressing how
the project is progressing how the tasks
are being completed how quickly they are
completed so it is easily visible and
that makes things to move smoother and
faster
so scrum framework so scrum framework
helps in dealing with complex problems
and making it possible to deliver high
quality products see at the same time it
helps in managing complex advanced work
with little emphasize on software
development so it uses the terminologies
like sprint product backlog sprint
backlog daily scrum
retrospective meeting so three roles
predominantly we come across that is
product owner stub master and then
self-organizing team
so next framework is hybrid framework
which you can think of so it is the
combination of agile methods with
non-agile methods hybrid can handle
requirement changes and it can deliver
products in stages so in hybrid model
planning is done using a waterfall
approach while the agile approach
handles execution and delivery
so lean framework so the lean framework
works on the concept of maximizing
customer value with fewer resources and
zero waste hence lean focuses on the
flow of products and services instead of
focusing on separate technologies
companies can act upon with changing
customer needs and requirements so very
important points to observe here zero
waste means in the flow the way the
processes are connected to each other in
that flow we should identify what are
those which acts as a bottlenecks
resulting in waste so we should
eliminate such bottlenecks so these
elimination of bottlenecks helps in
reduction of waste at the same time
increasing the value to the customers so
in the downstream from the point where
bottleneck you have the entire capacity
will get limited to the downstream
capacity i'm speaking about will get
limited to the bottleneck where that
particular issue exists right that needs
to be resolved elimination of waste
should happen
so waste is a result of anything which
is a non-valuating activity right so we
need to identify as per the lean
perspective so the defects are not
allowed to move forward to the
downstream that is the whole idea behind
it so next question 26
why does a project manager need to be
proactive okay so we always have this
question coming around proactiveness
versus reactiveness when should we be
proactive when should we be reactive
that we need to understand now more
proactive in nature the project manager
or any manager who is more proactive
will basically visualize the future
so they act today so that tomorrow
something negative in fact will not
happen so a proactive project manager is
actively able to determine the several
communication needs of the stakeholders
so a proactive project manager is able
to identify the risks in the early stage
of the project it is very essential so
what is that going to happen in future
that needs to be visualized act today so
that that occurrences can be handled
better or eliminated
question number 27
what does a critical path method implied
so firstly let us understand what is
critical path means so critical path is
basically a longest path in a given
project network diagram so that would be
the minimum time required for a project
to complete so any delay in any of the
activities or tasks in critical path
delays the project duration so in
critical path method so it is a crucial
tool for determining the progress of the
project to ensure that project is on
schedule so as i mentioned any delay in
any of the activities or tasks in the
critical path delays the project itself
so monitoring on these activities in a
critical path will become more important
so that project can happen as per the
plan as per the date what is given so
critical path method helps in
determining the essential or critical
path by finding out the longest stretch
of dependent tasks so that each
dependencies each flow from left to
right from beginning to end has to be
visualized and monitored very closely so
that project finish date is not uh
delayed it happens according to the plan
so next question defined planned value
actual cost and earned value so when we
say planned value planned value is the
approved value of the work that needs to
be completed within a given period it
serves as a baseline and needs to be
calculated before work can be started it
is also known as budgeted cost of work
scheduled so formula to calculate
planned values planned percentage of
work completed into project budget
assume your project budget is 10 000
whatsoever the currencies let us assume
10 000 is my project budget so my
project duration is 5 months each month
i have a plan to complete the work worth
of 2000 so which means that 2000 is my
planned value
the work which is supposed to be
accomplished within the end of that
first month is work worth of 2000
so if i do the work which is lesser than
work worth of maybe lesser than 2000 i
am behind schedule if i complete the
work worth more than two thousand then i
am ahead of schedule so planned value
will become that reference the two
thousand what i mentioned as a planned
value the work worth of two thousand i
am supposed to complete before the end
of the month one if i say any work which
is completed according to the budgeted
value i will make this planned value as
a reference to decide whether i am
behind schedule or ahead of schedule
actual cost actual cost refer to the
value of total expenses that you have
incurred for the work done till date for
example in the previous discussion
relating to the planned value at the end
of month 1 the planned value was 2 000
so that is the work worth which was
supposed to complete now let us assume
that we have completed the work where
the work work relating to that actual
work completed is around 1800 means i'm
behind schedule for sure but at the same
time to complete the work worth of 1800
how much i incurred actually so if i
have incurred actual cost also 1800 then
cost wise i'm according to the plan but
behind schedule because i've only
completed the work worth of 1800 against
the work worth of 2000 which is a
planned value and behind schedule but to
complete it the actual cost i incurred
is 1800 so cost wise i'm according to
the plan if my actual cost is lesser
than 1800 then i'm doing very good in
cost perspective if my actual cost is
more than 1800 then i'm using more money
means over budget so actual cost helps
us in relating to planned value to
define whether cost wise how am i doing
so it is also known as actual cost of
work performed so this will be used to
calculate cost variance and cost
performance index
earned value earned value represents the
value produced by a project it is also
known as budgeted cost of work performed
in our example the earned value is 1800
meaning i have completed the work worth
of 1800 that is the earned value which
says behind schedule when i compare
earned value with the planned value it
it will tell me whether i'm behind
schedule ahead of schedule or according
to the plan now for this earned value of
1800 if i incur the actual cost of 1800
then cost wise i'm doing good if my
actual cost is lesser than earned value
then cost wise i'm very good
right if i incur more than earned value
for example to complete the work worth
of 1800 i incur the cost of 2000 then
i'm not doing good i'm over budget so
the combination of earned value and
planned value helps us to know the
scheduled perspective the project is
behind or ahead or according to the plan
schedule perspective whereas the
combination of earned value and actual
cost helps us to understand whether
project is within the budget or budget
or according to the plan question number
what is the purpose of procurement
management plan the procurement
management plan defines the procurement
requirements and how it can be managed
from developing a procurement
documentation through to contract
closure the plan identifies and defines
the items that need to be procured the
contracts that need to be used for
supporting the project how the contract
is approved and criteria for decisions
to be made has to be looked at the plan
also includes other items including
considerations for procurement risks and
procurement risk management deciding how
cost needs to be determined standard
procurement documentation usage and
constraints to procurement
question number 30 when is post martin
analysis performed in the project
management a postmartem in a project or
project retrospective
refers to process that's performed at
the conclusion of the phase for a
multi-stage project this aim to help
identify process improvements that can
prevent future risks and to ensure best
practices are repeated
postmartems involve a combination of
quantitative and qualitative data it
also includes qualitative data like end
user stakeholder and team satisfaction
potential for reuse and the quality of
end deliverable that is perceived
question number 31 what is the purpose
of risk register a risk register is
basically a tool that is used to
document risks and the actions to handle
each of those risks the management of
risk is an ongoing process that has a
project team raising risks with the risk
manager or a project manager who then
locks the risks and determines an
appropriate course of action to handle
the risk risk register also needs to be
reviewed regularly to ensure the
appropriate actions are performed it
could be reviewed in every project team
meeting or at the end of each phase of
the project life cycle
question number 32 when do we use a
grant chart so as we are discussing
about critical paths network diagram
critical path method so by using a
project tools we first establish a gantt
chart so gantt chart is basically a
visual view of tasks scheduled over a
period a gantt chart is useful for
outlining all the tasks involved in the
project along with their order shown
against the time scales so since it
gives the pictorial representation it
helps us in understanding what tasks
will be completed after which tasks and
how the dependencies of each task will
be can be easily understood it provides
an overview of a project its associated
tasks and then
when they need to be finished are
clearly understood a gantt chart is
helpful because it provides a detailed
view of all tasks and ensures one can
create a workable schedule and the right
people are assigned to right task it can
be used to determine the practical
aspect of the project it enables to keep
the team and sponsors informed about the
progress of the project
question number 33 what is the
significance of the critical path method
so critical path method or cpm is a tool
that is used to schedule project
activities so cpm is used to create a
model that includes tasks required to
complete the project dependencies
between the tasks the durations required
to complete an activity the critical
path is the longest path in all the
available paths in the project and the
duration of the critical path will be
the minimum time required by the project
to complete
question number 34 what are some tools
required for arriving at improvement in
processes so process improvement
comprises a set of actions implemented
by a company to enhance performance cost
reduction increasing profits etc so some
of the tools some organization can use
to implement a successful process
improvement strategy can be comparing
and baselining a project so with this we
can get an overview of how the process
is performing in comparison with other
similar processes flowcharting which
helps them segregating the processes
activities events etc value stream
mapping it helps clearly understand the
workflow and helps organizations
identify waste cause and effect analysis
these help organizations determine the
root cause of any problem hypothesis
testing which helps in testing to
determine whether a hypothesis would be
favorable to the organization or not
question 35 how do you work with three
point estimation method so the three
point estimation method is also called a
spurt estimation which is a tool that
can be used to help increase the
accuracy of cost and time estimates
there are three parts with the different
estimates that is optimistic pessimistic
and most likely the optimistic estimate
is the amount of time required to
complete the project assuming everything
in the project goes according to the
plan pessimistic estimation is
estimation considering the worst case
scenario and is an estimation given in
everything goes wrong that is the
assumption so most likely estimation so
this is most likely to happen and falls
under the pessimistic and optimistic
estimates it falls in between them
pessimistic and optimistic so the
formula to calculate three point
estimate would be pessimistic plus
optimistic plus four most likely divided
by six will provide the three point
estimation
what do you understand by the term rate
raid log is a project management tool
that tracks risks actions issues and
decisions it provides a simple way to
organize the information so the main
advantages of raid log is to enable
you to think in an organized and
strategic way the raid log has all the
questions that could be asked by
stakeholders the data is easily
accessible and acts as a measure for how
well the plans are being carried out the
raid logs makes the process of decision
making more consistent it provides a
place where all decisions made can be
compared
question number 37 what are some
techniques used for defining scope so
here are some tools and techniques to
define scope that is expert judgment it
which requires to bring in experts on
domain product analysis which needs to
break down the final deliverable into
smaller components to ensure all the
steps are being taken alternative
generation so in alternative generation
it's need to brainstorm for the best and
most effective way to create it for the
product facilitated workshops which
allow different people with different
ideas to find common ground for a
project
question number 38 what is waterfall
model
waterfall model is a project management
approach in which a project is completed
in several phases a big plan is executed
linearly expecting there will not be any
changes in the plan waterfall model is
in contrast to gel model does not
respond well to frequent changes any
changes which comes in between while
following the waterfall methodologies
making that changes will be difficult
and bit complex
question 39 on what basis would you
decide if a particular risk should be
avoided or mitigated the risks which are
having high impact negative to the
business are awarded by the
organizations usually so
awarding is the first decision what
organization makes for sure but however
there may be some discussions which are
made before the decision of being made
relating to avoiding that risk instead
having some workaround for that risk or
making certain arrangements so that
impact of the risk can be reduced or
bringing down the probability of
occurrence of the risks considering
something which will have higher
negative impact they may not be
worthwhile to take up so in that case i
think avoiding is the best decision once
the organization is considered to take
up after identifying and analyzing the
risks then organization would work on
risk response plan for all the risks
which are identified
so what is evm the earned value
management so earned value management is
a project management technique that is
used to measure the project progress if
you recall the terminologies like earned
value planned value actual cost
scheduled performance index cost
performance index these are the
terminologies which comes as part of
earned value management it calculates
the project performance and progress by
combining constraints like time scope
and cost
so question 41 what is the difference in
product life cycle and project life
cycle so project life cycle refers to
the sequence of stages or phases the
project undergoes from the time it is
initiated till it is closed so this
project life cycle involves five process
groups which is initiating process group
planning process group executing process
group monitoring and controlling process
group closure process group which should
be there throughout the project life
cycle along with the 10 knowledge areas
and 49 processes
product life cycle includes all that
phases that define the growth of your
product so creation of the product till
expiry of the product so within the
product life cycle we may have multiple
project life cycles so one project life
cycle for introduction of product one
project life cycle for modifying or
updating the existing product one
project life cycle may be for
improvement one project life cycle may
be for removing the product from the
production so in product lifecycle there
are four phases that is market
introduction market growth market
maturity and decline and saturation
stage
question 42 define capability maturity
model so capability maturity model is an
approach to improve or refine
development process in an organization
so it is an elaborated structure of
elements that helps in defining the
features of an effective process
next question 43 what do you know about
triple constraint the triangle in
project management so basically the
triple constraint refers to scope
schedule and cost right so it helps in
actually analyzing the project status
the way project is progressing and these
are the three critical considerations
mainly which needs to be made so further
to these triple constraints scope time
and cost quality resource and risks are
also considered as a constraints so any
change in any of the constraints would
have an impact on other constraints
question 44 what is a decision support
system decision support system is an
information system used in decision
making activities in an organization or
a business it analyzes data sets and
extracts information that may be used to
solve complex problems and take
decisions how many types of dss are
there so there are several types of dss
that is data driven model driven
knowledge driven and documentary one
question 46 what are some general
metrics that are used to calculate if a
project is progressing on track so if a
project is progressing on track it is
very essential to consider the
productivity which means units of input
units of output actual cost that is
total cost per time period to time
period cost variance which refers to
budgeted cost of work versus actual cost
of work schedule variance
which is
the difference between budgeted cost of
work perform and budget cost of work
scheduled cost performance index which
is earned value to actual cost
question 47 what is meant by a milestone
in a project a project milestone
provides a way to observe measure and
monitor the performance progress of the
project these represents intermediate
stages that needs to be fulfilled before
getting to the final objective or goal
milestones can provide a basis on which
progress can be monitored they can also
proof for explanation while reporting on
project status it can be used to provide
course corrections and learning
experiences it can also be used to
maintain accountability and motivate
staff
question 48 how can you estimate the
activity time of a project the activity
time or duration refers to the process
of evaluating the number of work periods
required to finish individual activities
with the resources available these help
achieve the project objectives on set
dates and delivery schedules decided by
project management team and key
stakeholders
here are some tools and techniques to
calculate activity durations so those
are expert judgment analogous estimation
pert method three point estimates
parametric estimating alternative
analysis published estimating data
vendor bid analysis etc
question 49 what do you think about csf
critical success factor in a project
management so csf or critical success
factor are found in the project
management plan and can define what can
be defined as success for the project
some characteristics of critical success
factor involved for example time was the
project completed within the given time
period
cost did it stay within the budgeted
cost quality did it meet the
specification level stakeholder was the
result accepted by the end user project
changes where scope changes are minimal
and are agreed upon performing
organization did it affect the corporate
culture commitment is required from team
members clients top management and all
stakeholders which is very essential and
it is one of the main critical success
factors goals must be specific
measurable attainable relevant and time
bound there must be process for quick
identification resolution of conflict
good project leadership is to be
established risk management policies
have to be established there must be
proper project planning that needs to be
done then best practices need to be
applied at all stages proper
communications but takes place to ensure
information is passed across
question number 50 what do you
understand by the term sow so sow
or statement of work is a document that
includes and define each aspects of the
project it is a foundation for the
project plan so before planning and
executing the sow lays down the entire
landscape of the project so it consists
of introduction the purpose of the
project the scope of the project when it
is done where it is done the tasks
milestones deliverables schedule
standards success how are you going to
determine the success means how do you
know the project is success what is that
you are going to measure or consider for
measurement requirements then any other
things which needs to be considered as
part of sow as part of that specific
project and then closing so sow can be
of three categories which will have
design details level of effort time and
materials which defines an hourly
service and the materials required to
perform the tasks which may be
performance based focuses on purpose of
the project resources and quality
expected from the output
question 51 what is a fishbone diagram
and when is it used so fishbone diagram
which is also called as ishikawa diagram
is a visualization tool that used to
categorize potential causes that is
problems for an issue to identify the
root causes so fishbone diagram is used
in product development and
troubleshooting processes it helps in
team brainstorming for potential causes
and then represents them in a diagram
based on their degree of importance so
when this diagram is used it helps us in
identifying the possible causes of an
issue to develop a product that can
address issue with current market
offerings to several areas of weakness
or bottlenecks in the business process
to handle recurring issues or employees
burnout to ensure any correction will
resolve the issue
so question 52 what is the parito
principle or 80 20 principle so as the
name itself indicates the pareto
principle states that 80 percent of
consequences come from 20 percent of
causes indicating an unequal
relationship between inputs and outputs
it can be applied to range of areas like
manufacturing
management and human resources it is
usually focused on businesses that are
claim-based some of the advantages of
pareto principles are increased
productivity increased profitability
identifying and fixing problems and
improved customer service
question 53 can you tell us about your
past project so now while answering
these type of questions firstly we need
to understand this question is open and
generic in nature so while answering
such questions following points has to
be considered so identify what is that
project you have done so state the
objective of the project project
deliverables your roles and
responsibility in the project and what
have you achieved in that project what
was accomplished what went well what did
not go well then project duration
project budget and actual cost incurred
in the project question 54 if customer
is not happy with the project what will
you do as a project manager so in any
given project customer satisfaction is
very important to ensure success of a
project in the scenario where customer
expresses their dissatisfaction one has
to ensure understanding the reason for
dissatisfaction so are all the
requirement fulfilled or not project
manager has to confirm that first was
customer involved in all decision making
activities etc to confirm that his
customer is informed about everything so
before customer is dissatisfied is
always
good and important that customer is
satisfied that needs to be ensured
so it is very important to be customer
to understand and customers pulse is
understood and handling the customers
accordingly so allowing customer to
become a dissatisfied customer is not a
choice to have so one needs to ensure
customer is not at all dissatisfied in
the first place beyond your control if
customer is still dissatisfied better
you work on it to understand why the
customer is dissatisfied what is the
cause of it and address it
question 55
what are the different kinds of project
you have worked upon so these type of
questions are again generic in nature
while answering those questions please
ensure you speak about various different
domains of the project which you have
and that should have variation in
different say different domains of the
project what were the deliverables of
those projects projects nature and
complexity unique challenges in each
different type of projects then project
duration budget and actual cost
question 56 did you ever face the
situations where the project team was
demotivated and what did you do to bring
them back on track so as we know project
team plays very important role in
success of any project it is very
critical to keep them motivated the
demotivation may happen for various
reasons so one is to keep the following
points in mind while dealing with the
team that is team engagement so
engagement may be both formal and
informal so rewards and recognitions for
the team for the good job they have done
conflict management wherever the
conflict occurs it is quite obvious
whenever the team is involved conflict
occurs performance evaluation and
monitoring mentoring is very key so
wherever it is required to mentor
wherever it is required to give them a
good perspective of the project and
their learning and capability so
mentoring and coaching is very essential
and also providing opportunities for
education and training so that they will
have a better learning and accomplish or
acquire the required skills question 57
if you get your dream job and i assume
this is your dream job what value you
think you will be adding to the
organization so this question is very
tricky one and also a generic question
so one is to ensure while answering this
question to discuss the following points
why the job is your dream job whatever
the job you are speaking about why do
you say that that is your dream job what
is the reason why what would be your
motivation point in this dream job what
exactly is motivating you there in this
particular job how this dream job can
link to objectives of organization and
the profession and roadmap of the job
role so what is that you are going to
become while you become this in future
what could be the roadmap of this role
question 58 what challenges have you
encountered while dealing with other
team members as already mentioned
project team plays very important role
in success of a project each team member
comes with the different skills maturity
mindsets and background which put across
many challenges some of the important
changing scenarios means challenging
scenarios is team not collaborating
individuals performance and motivation
levels in each of the projects role
preferences and the allocated roles
performance appraisals communication
gaps various things which actually
brings the challenges and also motivates
people to behave certain way they are
behaving question 59
share from your experience the
challenges you faced while using project
management tools so we all know that
tools plays very important role in our
management activity similarly the
effective management of project requires
an efficient tool every tools has its
own uniqueness and has its own
advantages and disadvantages so some of
the challenges one would face while
using the tools would be selection of
right tools for the given project tools
features and functionalities
customization of tools the dashboards
and reports teams ability to work with
tool their skills and capabilities
matters
question 60 can you tell me about the
most difficult complex project you have
worked on this question is open and
generic in nature again while answering
such questions please ensure you discuss
the following points what was the
complexity in the project whichever the
project reference you are taking why do
you consider that project as a complex
or difficult what was the size of the
project in terms of deliverables budget
geography team tools and techniques etc
was the project successful or not and
why question 61 when do you know the
project is off track so it is very
essential for every project manager to
ensure project is going as for the plan
so there should not be any deviations
from the actual plan so every project
will have a set plans based on which
project have to be completed
successfully due to various different
scenarios projects go off track
recognizing and correcting those is very
critical and crucial so one needs to
follow a specific approach to ensure
project will not go off track so but we
need to understand whether project is
going off track or not so one of the key
thing which we need to know is spi and
cpi so spi's the scheduled performance
index the cpi the cost performance index
so when spi is lesser than one which
means project is behind schedule when a
space
one then it's as per the schedule if a
space greater than one which means
project is add of schedule similarly for
cpi if cpi is lesser than one project is
over widget cpi is more than one project
is under budget recipe is one project
budget is as per the plan so similarly
the results of audits and testing done
as part of quality management also
reveals the details related to
compliance and of specifications which
needs to be corrected if they are not
expected
next question have you manage remote
teams and outsource resources so these
questions come from the scenario where
you have to manage the team not
reporting to you directly and they are
managed by different individuals while
having such resources the dynamics will
be different so while managing such
resources one has to
ensure the engaging with them is
different than the way the individuals
are engaged the internal teams so it is
required to engage with that team more
often the performance of the team
members has to be well known to the
reporting manager and that needs to be
communicated regularly
the next question if you could go to the
past and do one thing differently as a
project manager what would you do and
why so every project manager who has
managed several project earlier will
think of doing better which they have
done already so this is because of the
experience they had while doing the
project and the insights there today
compared to the day they did that
project so while answering this question
following points has to be kept in mind
what went well and what did not go well
why do you think they happened and what
would have been the better solution why
do you think it could have been done
better why did you not do it earlier the
way you're thinking the right way of
doing it today so what was the cause
were you not informed about it or there
was some force which was working on you
to take it in that way what made you to
do that way so why are you thinking that
this is the better way to do it what are
the reasons that you need to mention
so next question as a project manager
what is the most common challenge that
you face so obviously when you say take
up a project as a project manager every
project manager will come across various
different challenges every project will
have various challenges to deal with
project managers has to prepare
themselves to handle those they should
not shy away from those so typical
challenges which project manager would
come across would be the scope
perspective not clearly defined so not
having proper sign off between customer
and project organization then the
deadline dates or schedules which are
given are not realistic low budget
allocated low cost allocated
capabilities and skills of the team then
project environment etc
and with that we have come to the end of
this pmp certification full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics related to this video
then please ask away in the comment
section below our team will help you
solve your queries thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here